Loyalty to the Khan.
Whoa!
Wait, should I watch this or should I wait?
Um...
I don't know.
Anyway, I'm gonna just press start.
Go away, Campbell.
Welcome back, Master.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome.
Welcome, welcome to Metal Gear.
This is solid, but it's Ghost Babble.
I'm excited to see you play the first MGS game I ever got to play.
I was an N64 kid.
Let's go!
Thanks for the superchat.
Cooper, thanks for the gifted.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
The title screen lasts for like two seconds.
It's her, the babbling ghost.
It's me!
My voice is a little shot today.
I was up late recording stuff.
So, if I sound a little squeaky, I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Let's just let this run.
I'm not gonna pay attention to it just yet, though.
We'll just let it run while I talk.
Because I have a couple things to say first.
Stop!
It's distracting me!
Okay.
I...
So, I...
Oh.
I was planning on playing...
Stop it!
I was planning on playing Ghost Babble anyway, obviously.
I said I was gonna play some of the Metal Gear games that I haven't yet played.
In between me going to 4.
But...
I also was just like... I was asked not too long ago about joining a group of streamers for MGS Con.
We called ourselves the Cobra Unit.
But...
And I was like, oh, well, if I'm gonna be streaming Ghost Babble anyway, I can at least promote MGS Con a little bit.
So if you don't know MGS Con, this will be their third year.
I went to both years.
And for this year, they asked if I wanted to be a host for the convention.
It's only if we meet the stretch goal, which if we don't, that's okay.
But if we do, that's really awesome too.
Mainly, I have the Kickstarter in the pinned.
If you want to donate, if you're just like, yeah, this seems pretty cool, I like Metal Gear.
It's run by some really cool people.
And they're all very passionate about Metal Gear, obviously.
And they work really hard to get all the voice actors and people associated with Metal Gear to come into the con.
And apparently they have really big plans for this year.
Or I guess next year.
So if you're just like, this seems cool, maybe you can go.
If not, you could check it out.
They have an online digital con as well.
Basically, if they don't reach the stretch goal, that's fine.
But if they don't reach the goal at all, the convention won't be able to happen.
So it's kind of like...
I think they're all very much having high goals for the next year.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But any superchats sent today, of course, I will send those to the Kickstarter.
And any donos as well.
Or if you want to donate directly to the Kickstarter.
If you're just like, oh, I want to go, I want to support this or whatever.
Yeah.
So...
What?
What the?
They gave me more time.
Ontario, California, how confusing.
I know, right?
Oh my gosh, it's so confusing.
Because if you get a plane ticket, it's going to say Ontario, CA.
That's so confusing.
Who decided this?
I love this game, thank you for playing it.
Thank you!
Thanks, Nicholas, for the superchat.
I'm doing my part.
Thanks, AJ.
But yeah, so...
You know, if you...
Like I said, if you like Metal Gear, and you're just like...
You want them to be able to keep doing these conventions.
Thank you!
Sorry, I had to turn the notice down a lot, because it's...
The game is very loud.
What's your emotion for battle then, Minto?
Freak.
Yeah, the freak.
Yeah, see, everybody gets it.
The freak.
I'm planning on buying the VR pass.
It'll be my first con VR or otherwise.
Let's go!
Yeah, so...
You know, like I said...
You know, obviously, you know...
I was going to play this anyway.
But I was like, I should...
I would like to...
And I'm not like really affiliated with the con.
But like I said, they're really great.
They're really nice people.
They do so much to kind of keep the Metal Gear...
Metal Gear energy alive.
And...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Time to go Canada.
No!
I can't go, but it's really cool that you're going to be a host.
Sorry, I can't do more.
What?
No!
That's so...
What are you talking about?
I mean, at all.
It's amazing.
Thank you, Brandon.
Ghost babble?
She sure does.
I hate that I know Ontario, California.
Because...
Rasslin?
Is there...
Like a...
A...
Wrestling ring there?
I've heard of Ghost Babble for decades at this point.
First time seeing it.
Let's go Solid Minto.
Yeah!
Yeah, I...
Honestly, I don't know so much about this game.
To be honest.
I know a little bit about the story, but like...
Not a ton.
So I'm very excited to check it out.
For Metal Gear Minto.
Thank you!
Hot dog!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, Jacob.
Thank you, Verilant.
Thank you, Ronan.
Let's go to Alaska.
Anyway.
I don't want to waste so much time.
Let's enjoy Ghost Babble!
Oh my gosh, Metal Gear!
Thank you!
This game isn't like...
The MSX ones, right?
Like, I should be fine on normal.
Right?
Got the digital tear.
Let's go!
Happy to donate to the cause, Minto.
Thank you!
My wife and I are celebrating...
Our 9 year wedding anniversary today.
We started watching your streams together over the summer and became huge fans.
Could you wish my wife, Corrine, a very happy anniversary?
Stay freaky!
Thank you for the pink!
Oh my gosh.
Stay freaky!
Happy...
Wedding and 9 year anniversary!
Corrine!
Happy birthday!
Opening intro doesn't play again.
Okay,
we'll let it play again.
We'll wait for that to play and then we'll get into it.
Thanks, Mod.
Oh my god.
Stay on the main menu to watch the intro.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you!
This is kind of like a third MSX game.
With the modern quality of life enhancements.
So not as difficult.
Okay.
We should be fine on normal, though.
Then.
Yesterday, I played Devil May Cry 2.
And I had a bit of a headache.
Towards the middle-ish of it.
And the headache, unfortunately, continued today.
So, I'm like...
I just took some medicine.
Hopefully, it kicks in soon.
Take it easy, boss.
Thank you!
Like I said, my voice is so raspy.
It's so squeaky today because of recording.
There's been just so much that I've been...
I've been non-stop.
Go, go, go.
For like this whole week.
I'm just...
I wanna nappy.
I missed the DMC2 stream.
Was the game really that bad?
I had fun.
I think I just have fun hanging out with you guys.
And like...
Streaming, right?
Are you aiming to beat this game in one sitting too?
I would like to.
Because it's not so, so long.
I think it's about the same as...
DMC2.
Which is why I started at the same exact time.
Yeah.
Yeah, I...
But it's all exciting stuff that...
You know...
I am doing.
So, I can't complain.
It's just busy, busy.
Was it bad?
I had fun.
But was...
When is it gonna come back?
Hello?
It's so quiet.
For those who don't know, this is a Gameboy game.
So that's kind of fun.
Not so Deadpool!
Thank you for the 5 gifted.
Wait, so is this Ontario, Canada or Cali?
Cali!
Ontario, California.
It will play.
I think it just takes a minute.
Don't worry.
Just takes a minute.
Because it did it earlier.
It was because I think I pressed new game.
And was in that menu and it kind of reset.
But that's okay.
We can just kind of sit and talk.
Let's sit with our thoughts.
I didn't have to think for very long.
Thank goodness.
I closed my eyes and I could see the light.
It was blinding through my eyelids.
It's a chance to catch a stream on my birthday.
I will sing a happy birthday.
Hold on, after this though.
Remind me, okay?
Campbell, it's been a long time, Snake.
Didn't expect to see you again.
Drink?
Got scotch?
Single malt, straight up and neat.
If I remember right.
That you do.
This house?
Build it myself.
Oh my god, he's a handyman.
Didn't know you were a carpenter.
Call me Sabrina.
You know, it's already been three years.
Since you left.
How's Alaska been treating you?
Colonel, did you come all the way out here with the cavalry to make small talk with me?
Trouble, huh?
The world is on the brink of nuclear holocaust.
We came to request your help.
Request, as if I have the choice to refuse.
You do.
I know you too well that you can't be ordered or coerced.
But you'll say yes.
Because you need to.
Let me tell you about it first.
I can't feel like a robot.
I love all these lasers on Snake.
A week ago, a C-5 Galaxy transport plane on a classified mission to South America vanished.
These dramatic pauses too.
Terrorists?
Of course.
But the problem is what it was carrying.
Nuke.
Yes.
And some.
It was Metal Gear.
How's the audio by the way?
Maybe it's a little quiet.
A nuclear capable bipedal armored vehicle designed to realize the possibility of nuclear strikes from anywhere on the planetary surface.
The devil's candy of mass destruction to change the meaning of nuclear warfare.
And it was on that plane.
But I...
Yes, you destroyed Metal Gear in outer heaven seven years ago.
But the U.S.
government recognized the strategic advantages of Metal Gear.
And secretly extracted the data from outer heaven.
The development continued just under a different flag.
The South American hop was probably for a field exercise.
Christ.
Metal Gear's researchers were also on board.
The idea of Metal Gear in terrorist hands.
Goosed Washington into finding out it's new location in just a week.
A common came in today.
Where?
Gindra.
Goosed?
Central Africa.
Fairly small.
I heard there was a civil war going on.
An armed uprising by a separatist ethnic minority.
And that peacekeeping troops were...
Oh wait, and that peacekeeping troops were deployed.
So the hermit keeps up with the news.
That's so rude.
Don't call Snake a hermit.
Metal Gear is in the hands of the armed separatist group Gindra.
Liberation Front.
Commonly known as GLF.
She's my GLF.
Their leader is General Augustine... I didn't get the last name.
Charismatic and armed to the teeth.
They'll operate out of a virtually impregnable fortress.
Galloway.
In the mountains.
Sorry.
Neither the Gindran government nor the UN can get to them.
We also have intel that they recently hired several top class mercenaries as consultants.
We suspect that the mercenaries executed the Metal Gear hijacking.
So they plan to win their independence by threatening nuclear strikes with Metal Gear.
Not the consultants.
Snake, come with me to Gindra.
We need you.
We need the legend.
Don't call me that.
I know all the names for a killer.
And that's one of them.
A military dictatorship in possession of... Metal Gear?
Damn it.
You know they won't hesitate to push... that button.
And millions will die.
Well maybe the US shouldn't have created Metal Gear!
Colonel, I'm not in FOXHOUND anymore.
You're saying you won't go?
Why can't you leave me alone?
Alaska is quiet and my life is good.
You won't change your mind?
No.
Even if I tell you that the fortress, Galloway, GLF's home base, was once called...
Outer Heaven?
What?
The very same place where you went to war seven years ago.
Destroyed Metal Gear and became the legend.
Is there a connection?
I don't know.
But the fact is, there is Metal Gear in Outer Heaven.
Once again, you believe in coincidence.
I believe in conspiracy.
And you want me to find out.
I'm asking you to join me.
Campbell looks mighty wrinkly here, doesn't he?
If the past is at your heels, you turn around and face it.
Am I wrong?
End it once and for all, if only that were the case.
What did you do for a Scooby snack?
It's all back there, in Outer Heaven.
Tell me about this mission.
Oh my gosh, more.
Your mission is to infiltrate the Fortress Galloway.
Rescue the hostages and neutralize Metal Gear before its assembly is complete.
I saw ass.
Steve Gardner, the National Security Advisor, is in command of this mission.
Gardner himself?
America's best-kept secret just got hijacked.
And may be used in a terrorist attack.
Who else?
A national crisis, in fact.
A global one, I'd say.
And one more thing.
Okay, Columbo.
The Army's Delta Force is already in Galloway.
Carry out the mission in concert with them.
Whose bright idea was this?
Wait, there's more people there?
John Parker, Army Chief of Staff.
Top Army brass, huh?
Metal Gear's development was under Army control.
They, of course, want to do something about the situation themselves.
The dead.
In addition, four people will serve as your backup personnel via the Codec.
Oh my god!
Mei Ling!
Awfully young.
Doesn't look like a soldier.
PhD candidate at MIT.
Incidentally, she developed the new radar and Codec system you'll be using.
She'll be in charge of mission logs saving as well.
It looks like a dog head.
I thought so too!
When you have a question about the radar or the Codec or need to log in, save, contact her at frequency 140.96.
Brian McBride, Africa Desk Director of Operations, Central Intelligence Agency.
CIA.
Don't look so disgusted.
McBride effectively planned this mission.
Mission.
Ed has expert knowledge of Gendron affairs.
Ask him about the mission, GLF, or Gendron environment if you need to.
What's his Codec?
Frequency is 141.52.
Ronard Lensenbrick.
Wait, alias is what?
I've heard of him.
Word is he's about as trustworthy as a weasel.
Oh, his code name is a weasel.
Some say as good as Solid Snake, the legend.
So why isn't he working the field on this?
So true.
The US government apparently has more trust in you.
Looks like a JoJo's character.
I doubt that.
Anyway, weasel's a player in the mercenary circle.
He's well up on soldiers of fortune from all over the world.
And we know that GLF contracted some major ones.
If you run across a live one, get weasel.
I'm the Codec, sorry.
I'll wake up eventually.
He'll have something useful for you.
I have field control of this mission.
Frequency is 140.85.
If anything happens, contact me ASAP so I can stay on top of it.
Didn't you retire from FOXHOUND two years ago?
Why this mission?
No one can carry this mission out but you.
I was only called in because I know you.
I also have a score to settle with the past.
We all have our shadows, Snake.
Talking like this is like I have to reach deep into my throat.
It's making me yawn.
Because it's like opening my throat because I have to talk like this.
You guys like my voice acting?
Snake, we've arrived over Outer Heaven.
Gallowade.
10 out of 10.
Ready to descend.
We're counting on you.
I know.
It's all back here.
This is what the timeline would have been like if Snake didn't rip off all his clothes in Briefing Room.
Spread your wings and fly.
I thought of it too.
I thought that too.
Nice!
Welcome to Ghost Battle.
Let's get into it, baby!
New game?
I'm going to do normal.
Oh!
My birthday is tomorrow.
I didn't want to distract from the collab tomorrow.
Sands of time got hands.
Okay, I have two birthdays I have to...
First was Cryocyte.
And then Merc, I'll sing for you too.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Cryocyte.
Happy birthday!
One more time!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Markel.
Happy birthday to you!
OK, reach deep in your throat.
Deep throat.
One more time!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, actually, it doesn't do that horrible... Oh my god, thank god for Mei Ling.
Thank god for Mei Ling, instead of getting the...
We now have proper codec sound.
Earlier I was on stream, I saw Trombone Champ.
It's getting a VR game, it comes out on the 26th.
Oh no, Trombone Champ.
This is Snake.
Colonel, can you hear me?
Successful Halo landing, I see.
It was a Halo jump.
Oh my gosh, Mint is so cute.
Nothing like skydiving at dawn.
Present location, three kilometers south of Fortress as planned.
Heavy security, sentries ahead.
Snake, make sure you stay out of their sight.
Mei Ling!
Oh my gosh!
Watch the radar to keep track of enemy movements.
I'll go over it again, just in case.
It was my birthday yesterday.
One more time.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Lama Radio.
Enemy...
Is that the famous Solid Snake?
Oh my gosh, I can't believe I'm being hit on by the legend.
What was I going to say?
I don't remember.
Oh, I remember.
I saw some people in pre-chat saying that this game might need a guide.
Unfortunately, the game is all on one screen, and then my other screen is vertical, so there's not a lot of space.
So, if you guys can help me out a little bit, if you have a guide up or if you know the game...
I might request you guys as my chat codec, okay?
We're chat codec today.
Backseating?
No way!
Permission to backseat, sir!
Permission granted.
Yeah.
Let's see, what is she saying?
Oh, okay.
Sorry, I thought I clicked... I pressed B on accident instead of A, so I thought I skipped the whole thing.
Alex, welcome to membership.
Only if you make the codec sound when calling us.
Which one do you want?
Do you want...
Or do you want...
Ghost babble being played by a ghost babe.
Okay, when I want help, I'll go...
The second one?
Okay.
See the radar at the top right?
The large dot is you.
The others are enemy troops.
Even Mei Ling suffers from... Oh, do I get to...
Oh, I don't get to move yet.
Got it?
Okay.
Once you've been detected by the enemy, the radar will be non-operational.
Be careful.
Okay.
Thanks, Mei Ling.
Your mission is to infiltrate Gallowade, work with Delta, force to rescue the researchers, and destroy Metal Gear.
Welcome to membership.
Our codec frequency is... No, that's not your codec.
Orders will be relayed via the codec.
My frequency is 140.85.
Wow, the sprites look so good.
Call if anything turns up.
Like, you can tell that snake's soul well.
Do I have any pets in any video games?
In video games?
No, I don't think so.
To use the codec, just press select.
And then start.
We'll be in touch.
When a call sounds, push the select button to receive.
Raise me on frequency 140.96 when you need to save.
First, get to the front of the fortress.
Oh my gosh, I would love to get there, Campbell, if you would just shut up and let me play the game.
Cut northward through the jungle you're in.
Roger that.
Yay!
Then I press start.
Oh, interesting.
Select shows me...
Oh wait, up, down is item, weapons.
I have nothing.
And then I press start to codec.
Oh, cool!
Where do we want to go, guys?
They said go north, right?
Okay, I'm being sneaky.
I'm being real sneaky.
This needs to be in volume 2.
I agree.
This way.
Alright, I'm being so sneaky.
Oh my god, there's just a guy here.
Wait, maybe I can kill him.
When he turns around.
Does he come down?
Ow!
Oh gosh.
Don't come over here!
Maybe he goes back up.
Let's go kill him.
Oh, he's just passed out.
Okay, I grab whatever this is.
I got a handgun!
Let's go!
Um...
Knockout!
Oh, that's a wall.
That was dramatic, wasn't it?
Everything's fine, guys.
Everything is fine.
That guy woke up so fast!
What was I supposed to do with him?
The map is a little misleading.
Because it shows... or rather the codec, right?
Not codec, sorry.
Because it shows... Oh, I can walk through here!
Oh my gosh, never mind.
It's not misleading at all.
I'm just dumb.
Is there anything in here?
5-7 ammo.
Pouches are full of ammunition.
Oh, okay.
Oh yeah, let me... what is it?
Select weapon.
What do you mean?
Oh, I have no item.
There we go!
5-7 handgun.
Oh wait, a handgun.
B to fire.
Suppressor, okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh wait, there we go.
Okay, B to fire.
A is our...
A is the pouch.
CQC.
Suppressor, okay.
This guy's not coming in here, right?
Leave, please.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
I just noticed the guy up there.
Okay, I think we're safe.
Nice.
Did it!
I'm sleepy.
Cool.
Big field.
I'm just gonna keep going on the sides.
Can I walk in this?
Oh, it's grass.
I feel asleep.
I see people on the radar, but I don't see people.
You can crawl in the grass.
How do I crawl?
I'm gonna catch Pokemon in here.
Start?
Oh my god.
That's so great.
Can I get in the mud too?
Oh gosh, I have oxygen in here.
Good thing this guy's vision sucks.
Go to sleep.
Sleepy.
He's so sleepy.
What's this?
Rations?
All the sound effects are so Metal Gear Solid.
Feast and flee.
Flee?
What does that mean?
Does this pause?
It looks like it does.
Item.
Now we have fogger.
Wait, what?
A device that emits smoke.
Fogger.
What?
How do I use it?
How do I use this thing?
Okay, weird.
Oh, it's emitting smoke, I think.
Cigarette?
It's not hurting my health then.
PDUs, keep one handy.
Oh no!
No!
Oh my gosh, don't see me.
How do I get across here?
I think I might have to kill a person.
Can you go under the bridge?
Oh my gosh, there we go.
Dummies.
Okay, onward!
Nintendo didn't allow smoking.
Keep the rating lower.
I didn't kill anybody!
What?
How did I kill...
Wait, terrible!
They don't even sugarcoat it.
Oh my gosh, they're just like...
Imagine being a little kid.
You're like 7 years old playing.
You're like 7 years old playing this game.
And they tell you you're terrible.
That's messed up.
They're like, the kids can handle it.
Metal Gear Solid, not really.
Punch out twice equals kill.
I see, I see.
Snake, we have new intelligence.
I wish I had new intelligence.
Bad news.
Wow, a Draco's!
Thanks for the 20 gifted!
How did you know?
You've never exactly been a messenger of joy.
Rip.
So...
Seems that Delta Force was wiped out.
What?
I was actually looking forward to...
Here, I'm going to... Hold on, I'm going to zoom in a little bit.
I hope that's okay, you guys.
I was looking forward to working with that.
I was like, wow, you actually get to fight with some other guys.
That's so exciting.
Are you serious?
Musicbox, thank you so much for the 20 gifted!
It's true.
But Delta Force, the best of army's best.
Ghost Bible, yeah!
So easily?
It means they were outclassed.
That's how weasel sounds now.
Those mercenaries on the enemy's payroll are all A-list guns.
You've been out of action for a while.
But I'm out there and I know what I'm talking about.
If you're going to take one of them on, give me a buzz.
A buzz, a buzz, a buzz, a buzz, a buzz.
Planning to give me advice?
That's what I was hired for.
It's a policy of mine to earn my keep.
Why aren't you here?
Frequency is 141.80.
Don't forget it.
Jason Funderburker?
I won't.
Snake McBride from the CIA here.
This guy looks like Ken Doll for real.
Don't underestimate GILF.
They are just another rebel group there.
Annual revenue from drug and rare metal.
Trafficking is more than 50.
I thought it was just going to be 50 dollars.
50 dollar million.
And their black market arms were financed by that money.
My hair is getting in my headphones.
All state of the art.
Be careful.
I'm with the Africa Desk of Ops.
I can provide data on not just the GILF.
But on things like the GILF.
Like kindred climate, flora and fauna.
My frequency is 141.52.
Snake, continue with the mission.
Infiltrate the fortress Gallowade.
That's it.
More?
Snake, first gain entry to the fortress.
Enemy security should be even tighter than your mom.
Sorry.
Than it was in the jungle.
Keep your eyes open.
Especially for surveillance cameras.
A surveillance camera.
Is there anything over here?
Nothing.
What if I punch this wall?
Looks like a secret.
A surveillance camera.
What is the range on the surveillance camera?
Not good.
Okay, we're going in bottom.
What is the range on these guys, I wonder.
Okay, not very good.
Kind of awesome.
A door!
Oh no!
There are people who use the door.
Wait, maybe I can make it in.
I'm infiltrating?
He just left the door wide open.
What's over here?
That guy is gone.
Another door.
Can I go through this door?
It's time for a shift change.
Is it all ready?
Come on, hurry up.
We're both in big trouble if they catch us slacking off.
Relax.
As if anyone ever comes out here.
Can I move?
I can't move.
Now I can move.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
It's scripted.
Oh my goodness, I was so scared.
Suppressor!
Can I... Can I get in these lockers?
Maybe not.
Okay.
Nice!
Suppressor, baby.
Might be being reckless, but...
Nice.
She spared him?
Yeah, otherwise I'll get terrible ranking.
Oh my god, that's a door.
I was gonna say, this looks like a boss area.
Don't kill them, Jesse Fox.
I can't kill.
Jesse Fox can't kill.
It's game over.
Looks suspicious.
It's so suspiciously empty.
Okay.
I'm so hyped you're finally playing this, one of my favorites in the Metal Gear series.
I have an original cartridge.
Oh, wow, nice.
Thank you.
What's over here?
I wanna explore a little bit before we...
Sleepy guy.
See, this looks like it's filled with lasers or something, right?
I have full ammo.
So if I just press start... Oh my gosh, I can crawl.
That's crazy.
I can just crawl normally.
That's so fun.
Wait, who's... There's someone over there.
Hello, sir.
Can you move?
Can you leave?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, not my way.
Oh my god.
Stop!
This guy sucks.
Oh my god, I just need to go.
Everything is a jump scare in this series, I swear.
Alright, let's go through here.
It's awfully suspicious though.
Oh, what's over here?
Fun.
Stop!
Can you knock out people in the game without harming them?
I think people were saying that it's two knockouts equals a kill.
So, honestly, I don't really care about rankings.
You know me.
I don't really care about that kind of stuff.
But...
Oh my gosh, go in.
But I think I can just knock them out.
Oh my god, there's someone up here.
Can you make the screen... Can you hold B?
Oh wow, fun.
Thank you.
How do I get past this guy?
Don't look over here.
Maybe I can knock him out.
Is there anything here?
Oh, no.
There's nothing here.
I did that for no reason.
This is fine.
B.
There's a car.
What was the point of that?
Nothing here.
These boxes are huge.
I look so tiny.
There was a door north.
I had the... It went boop boop.
Oh no.
It's a little maze.
Not a maze, but...
Thank you for the...
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
Knock him out.
Run over here.
Into this area.
Go into here.
Is it just ammo that I'm not gonna be able to carry?
Hello?
Wait.
Push.
Hello?
How do I... How do I get...
I need to shimmy.
I didn't know you could do that.
Oh my gosh.
I knew it.
Come on, snake.
You can shimmy.
Wow, this game is insane.
Lucky, thanks for the gift, dude.
Can they see me?
Hey, mister.
Can you see me?
Guess not.
And there's a door right here, too.
Oh, this guy is gone, so let's go through.
There's also another door over there.
Okay.
I'm just going through everything.
It's crazy.
What's this?
An R... S?
Or 5?
S or 5?
Mysterious.
R5.
So that's not a door up north?
There was a door that... Oh, this?
This is not a door, I don't think.
If it is, I can't do anything with it.
Oh gosh.
There was one of these doors here.
But on the other side.
But it needed a code.
Like a card, I guess.
That's a man.
Oh my gosh, that was close.
Let's see what this guy does here.
Does he come over?
He doesn't seem to.
It's a man.
Okay, so I think we're safe here.
Oh, there's a... I see the exit all the way on the right.
Oh my gosh.
Just a man.
I wonder how many bullets it takes to kill a person.
Maybe don't clip that out of context.
Careful not to accidentally knock on the wall, right?
At least one.
How do we want to do this?
Where does this...
Stuffed shark!
Thanks for the tank captain!
Okay, that guy...
This guy that's walking towards me now, he just...
I think I need to go...
Upwards and around.
Oh my god.
I took a risk.
I took a risk, baby.
Holy moly.
There's that one room.
I want to go in, but I don't know if I can.
Ration!
Actually blind guards.
Leave him alone.
Look, they're tired.
They're just sleepy guys, okay?
Hello?
What are you doing?
Oh shoot.
I thought he was asleep!
I
made it.
Is anyone out there?
Who could this be?
Can anyone hear me?
This is...
Who is this?
Thank god!
It's Aerith from Final Fantasy series.
Final Fantasy 7.
This is Sergeant Chris.
Oh, it's Chris.
Sorry.
Chris, you're very beautiful.
I'm so sorry.
Pretty lady.
Unless Chris... Chris is a gender neutral name actually I feel, right?
Chris is gender neutral.
It could be.
I can't tell.
It's fine.
Yeah.
This is Sergeant Chris Jenner of Delta Force.
A survivor of Delta!
Delta Force.
A survivor.
That's literally what I just said Snake!
It wasn't annihilated.
No.
Who are you?
The U.S.
rescue team?
U.S.
rescue person?
No.
I'm the black sheep you were supposed to work with.
Not Foxhound?
Foxhound!
Isn't this a Gameboy Metal Gear minto?
It is, yeah!
Solid Snake speaking.
First name Solid.
Last name Snake.
You always find me solid.
You!
I've heard things about you!
What kind of things?
The best saboteur ever.
The one who destroyed Metal Gear in Outer Heaven seven years ago.
What age does this put Snake at then?
I guess maybe, say he was in his early 20s.
In the first couple of games, then he's in his 30s or late 20s in this probably.
17.
He was on, you know, he should have been in Solidus' army.
Three years before MGS1.
And he's in his 30s in MGS1.
The legend.
Don't believe everything you hear.
Some say I'm just an attention seeking killer.
This is the skin of a killer Bella.
He's a grandpa now.
Stop!
He just feels perpetually 30 to me.
I get that though.
So, which is true.
Make up your own mind.
Sergeant Jenner, are there any other survivors?
From the unit besides you?
No, everybody else.
They're monsters sir.
They?
You mean those mercenaries?
Yes, especially the leader.
A man called Viper.
I was called that once before.
The subtitle Ghost Babble made me think this was a fan game for you.
Mental Gear Solid win.
Yeah, funny right?
There was nothing we could do.
Even if it wasn't an ambush.
An ambush?
The mission was leaked?
I don't know, but...
Sorry, I heard something outside my window.
This is an absolutely classified mission.
There is no way it could have been compromised.
Unless someone on the inside leaked it.
Wanna bet?
There's always someone who's willing to sell out.
What makes an American brass tick?
What?
What does that mean?
Good morning Mito.
Money, power, glory, women, men.
Both.
Can it.
There is no risk of spies here.
We literally have a man on our team named Weasel.
I don't know what you're expecting here.
But there's a guy on our team that they didn't even trust.
He's just as good as Snake apparently, but they didn't even trust him enough for the mission.
Pretty sure, aren't you?
Everyone involved in this mission has undergone rigorous background checks.
Especially Weasel.
This guy, okay, McBride is definitely the guy who's gonna betray us.
Also the shading on...
Give McBride some contour please.
Look at Snake compared to him.
It's crazy.
Snake is a chiseled Greek god and McBride over here is Silly Putty.
This poor man.
I see.
They're all trusting.
How about it, Colonel?
This is a top secret mission.
Only a handful of people know of it.
In the government and the military.
I have to agree with McBride.
Even Colonel looks better.
Colonel just looks old.
Snake is totally mewing though.
How about it, Colonel?
Alright.
Sergeant Jenner.
Is Metal Gear really inside the fortress?
Yes.
I still don't have the exact location.
But the assembly is apparently near completion.
And the researchers have been confined to another building.
Do you have the location of the researchers?
I'm sorry.
All I know is they're somewhere here in Gallowade.
Okay.
Real helpful.
How did you enter the fortress?
Through the drainage system.
Through the front door, dummy.
The drainage system.
Bingo.
You saw those buildings with recessed east walls?
Did we?
There are hidden access ways down into the... Oh yes, yes, yes.
We saw the ladders into the ground.
In those recesses...
Building with an indented east wall.
Entry into an underground route in the recess.
Got it.
Reese's.
Reese's booth.
Get yourself back there and get out of here.
No.
I'm staying here.
You're not.
You're just going to get in my way.
I have no time to babysit a brownie.
You get out.
No.
Sergeant.
I will not abandon the mission.
Wow.
Loyalty to the mission.
Also, loyalty to the con.
MGSCon.
Pinned Kickstarter in chat.
And in the description.
But... I have to finish this.
Amazing.
Subtle ad.
Thank you.
For your fallen comrades.
Why are we so quiet?
Snake.
Having an ally in the field could be useful.
Please, sir.
Alright.
You've got guts.
I'll grant you that.
Thank you.
We'll rendezvous inside the fortress.
In the meantime.
In the me... meantime.
Is meantime supposed to be one word?
Ulyssa.
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Gather as much intel as possible.
Got it.
In the meantime.
I think it is.
Really?
In the meantime is correct.
You watch out for your own back until then.
Of course.
And no cowboy acts.
I love the codec effects on their little portraits.
It looks so good.
I can't get over how good this game looks.
No cowboy acts.
What does that mean?
I know that.
Oh no.
I just did a cowboy act.
And one other thing.
Yes?
But sir, how am I supposed to practice my lasso?
Indiana Jones would hate this.
Can I call you Chris?
Okay.
We don't know each other that...
Rejected!
Oh my god!
Can you just imagine the game over screen?
Showing up.
Just mental damage.
We can easily change that.
Solid Snake you dog!
As comrades in arms?
That's up to you.
Okay.
My frequency is 140.25 Ask me if you have any questions about the fortress.
Chris.
Thank you!
Good luck Snake.
Can I call you maid?
We don't know each other that well.
Alright Snake.
Look for that way into the duct that...
Sergeant Jenner was talking about.
Can I call you freak?
Go to the building with the recessed east wall.
And get underground from the concealed entry point in the recess.
Now I saw buildings...
With...
Like...
You know...
Hello?
Chris!
Snake!
You need card 1 to open that door.
Card 1 should be in that truck to the north west.
Oh, cool.
Wow, Chris is actually so helpful.
North west?
Where am I?
Okay, I came from over here.
Wait, there weren't people before over here.
Now there are.
Oh shit, I shouldn't have left.
I
shouldn't have left.
There weren't people before.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
North west.
Truck?
All the way here?
I
feel like I'm lost.
Did the guards reset?
Because there definitely wasn't a guard right there before, I think.
More north and more west.
Am I not as north as it goes?
Keep going north?
Oh, okay.
Have I not been here before?
I was wondering what that... Oh, here!
Go in.
I got it!
Shimmy, shimmy, shimmy, shimmy.
Card ID 1.
And...
I didn't go that far from where I...
I'm so confused.
So confused where the heck I am.
Yeah, they...
Scared.
Wait, I think I'm good.
There we go.
Okay, now I don't know what this guy on the right does, so we'll chill here for a second.
Wait, what's down here?
What is over here?
Is this open?
What am I hearing opening?
You hear that?
Oh, here.
I found it!
I'm too good at this.
I think I found it.
Uh...
They're gonna hear the noise travel through the pipe and they're gonna think this place is haunted and I'll leave.
That's why it's Ghost Babble.
Is there a breakable wall?
I don't...
I don't know.
There has to be something here, right?
This isn't just a place you go to when you get caught and you wait for the alert to end, right?
Is this the wrong recess?
Dang.
Thank you, thank you!
This guy scares me.
Wait, can I... I can't go through there.
Okay.
Sometimes it's hard to tell where I can go and where I can't.
Hey man, where are you going?
I'm being so secretive.
So sneaky.
Wait, where is that door?
Okay, this is where we climb through.
Where was I?
Why is this all so confusing?
Just run, run, run, run, run, run, run!
Okay, we went into here.
There was nothing in here, I think.
This is the one that needs...
I got the key!
What are you talking about?
Do I have to equip it?
Is it one of these types of games?
ID card.
Don't turn around.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh wait, I think I need to go up here.
And then we do the same thing here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, this is it.
This is the one!
Can you sneeze?
Oh my god, I see it!
I see the pipe!
No!
Guys, I don't think this is the one.
Not this one.
I only remember...
Anything in here?
Bullets that I don't need.
Okay, there's this one over here.
Alright, we have to go all the way back.
I'm just gonna run.
I'm gonna not get caught on...
Oh my god!
I shoot...
Please don't kill me.
Please don't kill me!
Oh my god.
What do you mean I fall over ashes?
No!
Oh my god, I ran right into that guy.
It sucks so bad.
Oh my god, there's...
Run, run, run, run, run!
Just go!
Hide.
Shimmy?
Hide, hide, hide, hide, hide, hide.
They'll never find me.
Yeah, dummies.
Yeah, stupid.
You don't know how to shimmy.
Okay, you can leave.
You can leave now.
How do I use my ration again?
Maybe I should go get that other one that I couldn't pick up.
B to use.
Boss Toaster, thanks for the gift!
Okay.
Well, that was... something.
Oh my gosh.
What's in here?
A whole lot of nothing.
I thought, though...
I thought, though, that...
Yeah, you can see that there's a hidden entrance in the one...
In the other... what's it called?
Building right below me.
You can see it on the map.
Is this guy gonna turn around or...
What are you doing?
Okay, good.
Oh wait, this is the truck I just went into.
It's right...
It's like right...
Here.
Maybe not.
Crawl?
I don't think so.
Unless here?
No.
Once this guy moves, I'll go through.
This guy.
He's the one who got me.
What a jerk.
He's the one that caught me before.
I don't necessarily like that their positions reset.
Oh, what about down here?
Does this one have one?
Does this have a secret?
A little recess?
Oh, I got more ammo!
Snake, look out!
A camera!
Oh my gosh.
This is why I don't like that their positions reset.
This freaks me out.
Basically, I think back at the beginning though.
We went in this one, didn't we?
Almost positive we did.
Not yet?
Okay, let's try it.
ID card.
We didn't go in this one?
Got it right!
Yippee!
I totally thought I had.
Let's go.
Cutscene.
Yippee!
Terrible!
One guy.
I got one guy, you guys.
What a thrill.
Moshi moshi.
Chris, at the duct entrance.
Where are you?
In the building.
Right above the duct you are in.
Okay, come meet me down here.
Pretty near.
I'm about to find out what I can hear.
How?
I got an enemy trooper uniform.
Give that to me!
Terrible means good like Les Enfants Terribles.
Yeah, exactly!
I keep misspelling Master of Stealth as terrible.
That's okay Mint, most of my ranks are terrible and I know this game backwards.
Okay, that makes me feel better.
Thank you.
It should let me blend in and listen in.
Chris.
Don't worry.
I'll find out where the researchers are.
Wait, give me the uniform.
I need it more than you.
Don't overdo it.
The rank is a meme?
Okay, good.
Codename terrible Minto.
Hi Doug.
I watched your stream in my dream today.
I don't know what you were doing, but you had 300k subs.
Wow!
Maybe one day.
I know.
I'll go up to your floor and we'll rendezvous.
There.
I'll be disguised, so no codec contact.
Contact.
Make voice contact when I'm alone.
I'll go, hello!
Alright.
But aren't you wearing the same uniform as the enemy?
How am I supposed to spot you among all the enemy soldiers?
What's the plot so far?
Infiltrate Fortress.
Defeat Metal Gear.
What about my hairstyle?
I really thought they were going to say, what about my butt?
I have my hair tied up at the back.
You should be able to recognize me from that, okay?
Hairstyle, huh?
Even among the GILF soldiers, there are heaps of guys with long hair.
Yeah, you're right.
Okay, how about if I wear a red cap?
That's too obvious.
Alright, I guess that works.
If I see a soldier wearing a red cap with hair tied up at the back, it must be you.
Got it.
That's so obvious.
Alright Snake, see you soon.
Oh my gosh, an Ocelot cap perhaps?
Oh my gosh, I'm too popular.
Snake, rendezvous with Sergeant Jenner.
She's in the watchtower above.
Get through the duct and gain entry to the tower.
Is there going to be a boss over here?
Oh no, there's little guys walking.
I haven't been codec-ing.
Are codecs like fun in this game or...
Weasel.
Let's talk to Weasel.
That's a 5.7 pistol.
A handgun designed for low recoil.
High impact 5.7mm ammunition.
The 5.7mm is a new type of cartridge.
With its high muzzle velocity and pointed tip, it can penetrate most body armor without the usual downside of increased recoil and lowered targeting accuracy.
The 5.7's magazine can... Why is 7 like the N?
Capitalized.
Can hold 20 rounds.
Branding.
Wait, actually...
Oh, it's the brand.
The use of industrial plastic cuts down on weight and probability of malfunctions.
You can muffle the firing noise too if you can.
Find a suppressor.
That's what I did.
That's a mean little handgun you've picked.
Yourself.
Let's also call McBride because I like him.
I think he's going to betray us.
I've had the service records for that.
Sergeant Jenner looked up.
Real 5.7 actually has pretty intense recoil and a massive grip.
So the game just lied to us.
Jenner, Christine.
Age 25.
In service for 8 years.
As you can imagine from her having been chosen for this mission team.
Her records are exemplary.
Father and mother.
Most people do have a mom and a dad.
That's how most people arrive on the earth.
No siblings.
She enlisted when she was 17.
Parents divorced when Jenner was 12.
I don't think I need to know everything about her.
Mother got custody.
Alright.
The last name Jenner is her mother's.
Father is an entrepreneur.
Never missed an alimony or child support payment.
Thank you.
A very generous sum.
More than enough for just two people to live on.
Okay.
It feels weird for Snake to not repeat the last sentence of the conversation.
He does sometimes.
Jenner certainly didn't grow up hungry.
Joined the army immediately after graduation.
From a big name school with excellent grades.
I'm surprised they didn't give the school name and also her address and her phone number and her three sizes.
Cleared the selection process for Delta Force with flying colors only four years after completing basic training.
As you know, Delta Force doesn't take anyone less than best of the army's best.
There's more?
I know everything about her, but I also know nothing about her.
Since then, she's been steadily moving up and evaluations by her CEO have been consistently high.
She may be young, but there's no doubt about her abilities.
Goodness gracious.
Okay, this area is a little icky, I think.
They rendezvous up there.
Oh, uh, I'll go through here.
Nice.
I think I have all of this, yep.
Holy moly.
How do I get through here?
I think I...
What does the other guy do?
He's just chillin' there?
Oh, he didn't see me.
He sucks.
Sucks at his job.
Is that a pit or is that the way it's just shaded?
Is that like a... Oh, I guess we'll find out in a second.
Oh, he can hear me.
Oh my gosh, okay.
Good to know.
Alright.
If I... Can I walk?
That guy is asleep.
Once this guy goes down, we'll run up on him.
Come on, I'm sleepy.
Okay, keep on going.
Awesome.
A rat!
Rats.
Rats!
Oh.
Okay.
Is that a camera?
Yes, it is.
Oh, goodness.
What is all that?
Oh, there's people?
Or...
Oh my gosh, wait.
More cameras or people?
I can't tell.
Oh, that's people, yeah.
How do I want to proceed?
Call Mei Ling?
Why?
Oh, wait.
Why do I call Mei Ling?
Stop.
Oh, I almost used that on accident.
Actually, hold on.
We miss her.
What?
I thought there was a reason.
McBride should know about the fauna.
True.
The total area of Kindra is...
Oh my god.
553,000 square kilometers.
This doesn't help me!
Population approximately 5 million.
A relatively small state near the center.
Oh, shoot.
Of the something.
Under the rule of a military junta for the past five years.
Three years ago, the charismatic so-called general, Agustin Aguaban.
Led an armed uprising by the Kindra Liberation Front.
Aquaman.
Junta is a military dictatorship.
I see, I see.
A.K.A.
Guilf.
And the country has been in a state of civil war since.
This doesn't help me at all!
The UN Peacekeeping Force was deployed six months ago to put an end to the unrest.
But there has been very little progress.
Okay.
Guys, I'm going to go to the bathroom real quick.
Sorry.
I will be... Let me put on some music.
I'm going to put on the song that I played.
Oh no.
Shoot.
Oh, I can't access... No, I can't access my...
Okay, wait.
Hold on.
I have an idea.
I'm going to put on the song.
I have it.
You guys can listen to it while I go to the bathroom.
I just have to figure out...
Not video source.
Media source.
Okay.
I will be right back.
Did that work?
Yeah, okay, good.
Wait, I'm going to do this real quick.
Isn't this song cool?
It was given to us for...
For the streamers that are...
That are doing stuff for the convention.
For MGSCon, so...
It's an exclusive.
It's so cool.
I don't have the artist's name right now, but I'll put it in the description after...
It's one of the streamers' friends, I think.
I'll put it in the description after stream.
Okay, I'll be right back.
I'm back.
I feel like I always go to the bathroom at the same time.
Like...
I...
I start streaming and then about two hours in I'm like...
I gotta pee.
Okay.
Cool.
Alright.
You guys want me to call Mei-Ling.
Okay, let me do that real quick and then we'll...
I gotta figure out a plan for this.
Mei-Ling!
You rang, Snake?
Do I have to save?
I guess I should save.
Save completed.
Okay, cool.
Oh, that was so easy.
So fast.
Snake, I know this is a difficult mission.
Oh my gosh, I accidentally pressed B again.
But as long as you have confidence in yourself, you can carry it out.
Confidence is the first rule of success.
Like Emerson said.
Emerson.
So you're a literature expert too.
Oh, sorry, that's him.
Uh-huh.
I knew you had me pegged as a hardware geek.
No, not exactly, but...
You know, I did take electives in college.
Oh, that's her.
Sorry, I keep getting it mixed up.
You know, I did take electives in college.
I was gonna say, Snake, what the college?
Oh my gosh.
You know, I did take electives in college.
I purposefully tried to learn things outside of my major too.
I'd rather be a well-balanced engineer.
So that's why you're always quoting.
There's a lot to learn from things different people have said.
Oh, make sure you get your exposure too.
Oh my god, she's gonna expose me.
Alright, let's see.
These guys just kind of walk around together, I think.
Or they don't.
I thought they were like buddies.
Maybe now.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Yippee!
That wasn't so bad.
That wasn't nearly as...
Bats?
That wasn't nearly as bad as I thought it would be.
What's that over there?
A frog?
No?
Okay.
Time to go... that way.
What is all of this?
What's wrong here?
Soldier A.
Zyren, thank you so much for 7 months!
Is that poop?
I sure hope not.
Are you still hanging around here?
What if this is their bathroom?
Actually, guys, I didn't see a bathroom.
This could just be like a communal toilet.
You've already been ordered to withdraw from this area.
Soldier B.
Withdrawal?
I haven't heard anything about that.
What's going on?
There's a squall coming.
A squall?
The river is already flooded.
And there's going to be a whole lot of water around here soon.
First I've heard of it.
Oh my god, they were going to let Soldier B die.
Murd.
If I'd stay here...
You get the idea.
Murd.
Murdy.
What the hell is that name?
Come on, there's no time to lose.
How soon are we talking?
It's sounding very soon.
What's in here anyway?
Wait.
Rude.
What's up here?
Nothing.
OK.
I think the ladders are for holding on.
Yeah, it seems to be the case.
Is it going to be really obvious when it hits?
Oh no!
I think it's hitting!
Why does it sound so scary?
Sorry.
Oh I see.
Oh my gosh.
It happens so fast.
Please, please, please, please.
Get to the next one.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
These are so scary!
Please.
Get me up.
OK, I have to go through.
I think it's every five seconds.
OK, let's wait for the next one.
Here it comes.
Alright.
Go through.
I think... Oh no.
Why does it go through the wall?
Oh my god.
I'm not going to make it.
This one is craziness.
Flushed.
Run!
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Here it comes!
I can't go in that one.
Sucks.
R5 ammunition, let's go!
Here it comes!
Why is this ladder unusable?
Run!
Oh my gosh, snake!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Oh wait.
Secret.
Cardboard box!
Cardboard box in yellow!
Wait.
How do I use it?
Oh, I did a secret.
No!
Hey!
So fun.
I wish it was easier to switch.
Okay, so the next one...
Go, go, go, snake!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
This one.
No?
How do I...
How do I use this one?
The sound is horrible.
That's not this one either, right?
Oh, it was.
I'm just silly.
Oops.
Yay!
I see a red hat.
Red cap.
Is that not too obvious?
I know.
Okay.
That seems like...
What if they all... What if it's red cap day at the base?
Everybody wears red caps today.
Green cap.
Close.
Oh my gosh.
If I were in the walls, he'd be able to see me.
That's crazy.
More rations.
Maybe I'll use the one that I have.
Hold on.
I have to remember.
Okay.
Item.
Use.
Take.
Nice.
Okay.
Security.
This area almost looks like the one actually from Outer Heaven before.
Like in the original Metal Gear.
Like I feel like this one room below me...
This one room below me...
Is reminding me...
It's tool cameras!
And that would have been like the gas room and stuff.
Wait, I can box here.
Surely it won't...
The box works, right?
With...
The cameras, I imagine.
Let's see.
This is a test.
It worked!
Nice.
What's over on the other side?
Uh...
In box
we trust.
So true.
We got that at the perfect time.
Okay, green hat.
What are you gonna do?
Where are you gonna go?
Are you gonna go up?
Are you gonna go left?
Are you gonna go right?
You're going up.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thanks for making a decision.
Oh, what's in here?
A little hidey hole!
That's so cute.
Oh my gosh.
Brown hat.
Brown uniform.
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no, no.
Just a box.
Nice.
The floor.
I know.
I saw it.
Can you shoot fire extinguishers?
Honestly, I'm not sure.
Please don't...
Are you kidding me?
I'm gonna go hide in that hidey hole.
Ouch!
Run!
Hidey hole!
Hidey hole time.
You can't shoot the extinguishers, unfortunately.
Dang.
We're fine.
Oh, I didn't... Okay.
Well, now I know how the cardboard box works.
Look at me.
I look like a real snake.
They're scrambling.
They have no idea what to do here.
They have no idea what to do.
Bite his ankle.
I'm a chihuahua.
Do you crawl as fast as you walk?
I haven't really checked.
No, you're definitely slower.
Okay.
Let's see.
Let's box here.
Like so.
We'll just be sneaky like this.
Oh, wait.
This is his path.
Oh, shoot.
This is his walking path.
How do I want to do this?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, gosh!
Back to my hidey hole!
They have no idea where I am.
They're stupid.
The fact this works is hilarious.
I know.
I love when the AI is so dumb.
It's my favorite thing.
I love dumb AI.
Oh, dude!
That guy's path is all over the place.
Oh, shoot.
I walked on it before and he heard me.
But he didn't...
The first time I didn't get caught with the box.
It was the second time.
If I can just get over to that one little area that is free...
I'll be able to make it.
You know what I mean?
Can't you crawl on the grates?
Yeah, but I'm afraid I'll get caught.
They'll see me.
You know?
They'll see me crawling.
I'm gonna test something real quick.
Okay.
Cause I'm real slow.
Okay, hold on.
Here.
He's gonna move...
to there.
And I'm gonna do that.
There we go.
We did it, boys!
We did it.
Just took a little bit of a...
of a...
a way.
Okay, what's around here?
What's in here?
That doesn't seem good.
Okay, let's...
Wait.
Oh, no!
Their hair!
But they're... But they have a brown cap.
Interesting.
Okay.
And we go up.
No!
I have a card key.
Let me in.
Now still?
And we have a blue cap here.
Wait.
Wait, it was just blue.
You said that.
You guys... Did you guys see that?
Am I... I'm not crazy.
The hat was just blue.
Huh?
What was in here again?
Oh, that's right.
You think it's fine?
Let's...
Let's crawl.
Oh.
Yeah?
What are you gonna tell me?
My fogger?
Oh.
That's true.
The fogger.
How do I select start?
No?
Select then start.
Oh.
There we go.
Thank you, guys.
But it should be detectable if the beam passes through vapors or smoke.
Do you have anything that can produce smoke or gas?
Oh my gosh.
Good thing I ate these cigarettes.
Nice pall-eiding.
Thank you.
How far does the smoke go?
I'm scared.
Oh!
Okay.
Smoke.
So if I just like walk upon it.
Okay.
It's so scary.
I'm just testing every way.
Okay.
So down.
And over.
Sure.
What's in here?
More people.
Okay.
I don't need this anymore.
Especially because there is a camera.
She's so good.
Don't I know it?
They're not gonna notice me, are they?
I can probably shimmy past the...
The camera, I imagine.
Unless... Actually, let's wait for this person to go back.
Let's wait for them to come back up and around and then we'll go down.
So I don't have to shimmy.
This is kind of annoying.
I love how the box looks in this game.
It looks so good.
I can't get over how good this game looks.
It's so awesome.
We're waiting.
We're going.
Is this a door?
No, not the fogger.
Where's my card key?
Okay.
Gosh, I can't get through anything.
This sucks.
Denied all opportunities.
What is this guy?
Oh, that's not a guy.
That is a camera.
What?
No way.
The camera was so good.
I got the gas mask.
That's nice.
No, it was past me.
Are you kidding me?
It was past me though.
That's so messed up.
I'm donezo, I think.
One pixel off.
Do you think they're going to come up here and notice me?
Evasion...
Evaded.
Please don't notice me.
Gosh!
This is too real.
This is too... Just Battle Gear.
Wait, where the hell am I supposed to go then?
Hey!
Chill out!
Stop hitting me!
Shoot.
You're dead!
I
didn't get anything new.
A new card key.
I got the gas mask, but we haven't experienced a gassy room yet.
I think they respawn.
Yeah, they did.
That's okay.
I got the gas mask.
Yeah, but we didn't see a gassy room.
Did she forget she had a gun?
No, but...
If they respawn, what's the point anyway?
So, none of the doors in here...
None of the doors in here...
We have to go back.
Was there a way I didn't go before?
That was close.
I guess it's good that we got that, though.
Oh my gosh, I used a whole ration.
No way.
Oh, fogger there.
And then it was this way.
Yeah.
And then it was down.
And then this way.
Yeah.
Oh...
Alright, we gotta be careful of the cameras for sure.
That was so icky.
Is that a door right next to the camera?
Or am I crazy?
Is this... Oh, this is a door.
Is this a gassy room?
Maybe not.
Gas room!
We got it.
Snake, gas!
You've got to hold your breath in the gas.
Your O2 gauge will go down.
And once it runs out, your life will take a hard hit.
Put on your gas mask.
That way you can get through the gas without holding your breath.
And come out of that room alive.
I knew it was the gas room.
Nothing over here?
Okay.
Wait, why is there a way to hide in here though?
Oh my gosh, there's... Oh, no way.
What?
What are these guys doing though?
Huh?
Oh my gosh, no way.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna run out of O2.
Are you kidding me?
Okay, we gotta leave.
We gotta go back.
We gotta start over.
I'm gonna start over.
Nononononononononononononononononononono Okay.
Alright, we'll just run for it.
Gas.
I got our gas mask on.
That was so close, wasn't it?
How am I supposed to get past this guy then?
Oh, like this maybe?
I think they want you to leave initially, you know?
Shoot.
They're just like, otherwise you'll have no idea.
Wait, but their hair is not out.
The hair isn't out.
This isn't them, right?
This isn't Chris?
I don't think.
Oh my god.
No, it's not Chris!
No!
Oh my god, please.
This is so messed up.
This is so messed up, please.
Run, just run Snake!
And then... Oh, it stops in here.
The game is a little bit forgiving.
Just a tiny bit.
Just a tiny bit forgiving.
Okay, I'm gonna have to punch this guy out though.
I think.
Okay, good night!
Okay, level 2.
That guy is trapped in there.
What if he has to go to the bathroom and all?
He's trapped in the room that's next to the gas room.
They don't give him a bathroom or anything.
They hate him.
Alright, somehow we made it out.
Somehow.
Oh, I'm in this...
I'm in this area.
I just made a big loop.
Because this is where I first got caught by the camera.
Oh gosh, I'm gonna let it go all the way down.
As far down as it possibly can go.
Okay, now I can go.
Now, I go.
Where are we?
Is this an elevator?
What is this?
Oh, there we go.
I'm gonna get in a box just in case someone comes out of the elevator.
We're safe.
Think anyone's gonna ambush me on this?
Here we go.
Level 2.
Nice.
Oh, there's some stuff over there.
Whatever that room is.
Wait, I'm hearing something open.
I thought I heard a door go...
Maybe I'm crazy.
I thought I heard it though.
Guess I didn't.
Hey babe.
Still no?
Might have been the elevator closing.
Oh, I think you're right.
I think you're right.
Two...
Red herrings, that's funny.
Time to box.
I am once again a box.
Oh my god, that's a person, not a camera.
Turn around, go away.
Just a box.
Oh, still no?
Okay.
I am once again a box.
Gosh, this place is a horrible maze.
There was another door I think also.
The one over there.
I don't know if I have enough time to get to it though.
Yeah.
And the red hat person comes down here.
So I think I need to...
Let's get out of the box.
And crawl.
I just want to see what's in there though.
You know?
No way, they stop right here.
I wonder if I can knock them out.
Stop!
Oh, come on, I didn't even need it.
Nevermind.
Waste of my time.
Box, box.
Gosh, can you imagine if I hadn't gotten the box?
We'd be so screwed right now you guys.
Oh, this building design is horrible!
Who thought this was a good idea?
What the hell is this?
This is Big Boss' vision everybody.
This is what he would have wanted.
Okay, we are going to have to knock.
Be mostly box in there I think.
Big Boss loved Uzumaki.
He saw spirals everywhere.
Oh my gosh, I just realized the person coming up.
Oh, good thing I was still...
hidden.
Oh my god, do they just circle the entire...
What is this?
Oh, I think they meet, they kiss and then they turn back around.
Yep.
No, they swap places.
I don't know which way to go.
Honestly.
I think to that door up there.
Oh wait, there is a door down here too.
Beep beep.
They meet and they kiss?
Yeah.
It's a little meet cute.
Oh, we can go in here.
Okay, up there looks like hell.
Wait a second.
Oh, this looks exactly like the other room where...
Remember where my little hidey hole is.
Wait, is there anything else in here?
Oh, there is a door.
Hold on, there we go again.
Gas.
What about the other area though?
The other location?
I guess we'll eventually make it back there.
No?
Sees laser, gas.
Sorry, I meant I need the smoke.
That's where my brain was.
Not that I thought it was a gas room.
Just that I'm like, oh, I needed the gas, you know.
I don't think you can crawl.
They're double lasers.
I think vertically you can't see that there's two of them.
I don't think you can crawl.
And I'll stand by that.
Because I think that's the truth.
Correct.
Yeah, I thought so.
My instincts!
They all look to be doubles.
Yeah, I think just because it was...
It was...
Vertically, you can't really tell.
But yeah, that's the case.
What is...
Is there...
Oh!
I'll take it.
Nice.
More ammo.
And more ammo.
Oh, nice.
Okay, I'll take that too.
Good instincts.
Thank you.
Are there...
Is there ever anything in these holes?
I must check the holes.
Why does this room have so many hiding spots then?
Mysterious.
Okay, this is gonna be annoying.
Because we have to go the other way.
So we're gonna have to just follow this person.
Basically the entire way.
Unless I can knock them out and then...
Maybe they turn around here.
Nope, they just go around.
I'm gonna have to knock one out eventually.
So...
Because they're gonna meet.
They're gonna meet and they're gonna kiss.
Or I can just hide.
Where's another hole?
They're gonna meet and kiss!
Ryan!
Thank you so much for the Haka Super!
Tactical espionage, amigo.
That's me!
They kissed yours.
So lewd.
Alright, what's the way we didn't go?
Down this way.
Is there a hidey hole?
Oh gosh.
Okay, he goes up.
I'm missing my opportunity here.
Okay, around.
Now if I hide in here...
I'm sure...
He's gonna come around soon-ish?
Hopefully?
Because the ending is right down that hall.
Okay, here he comes.
Okay, bye!
Bye bye!
Sucker.
Oh, there was one down here, but...
What?
No!
Where do I go?
Huh?
No way!
The lasers.
Oh, they're timed?
So if I just stayed there longer...
That's what you're telling me.
Oh man, why didn't you tell me not to leave before?
Maybe you did and I just wasn't looking at you.
I'm sorry.
No!
Hold on.
Let's wait for...
You didn't ask.
Okay, everybody wants to be plissken today.
That's fine.
It was...
No, no.
This way.
Oh,
the laser is on the other side.
That's right.
Sorry.
I was scared for a second.
I was like, wait a second!
And then I go up.
Love seeing you play more Metal Gear!
Thank you, ComfyPanda!
Thank you for seven months too!
Okay, here we are back.
Wasn't so bad.
Alright.
So eventually it turns off?
I think this one eventually turns...
Oh.
Ah, I see, I see.
Yeah, take that!
I hope there was nothing else in there.
Actually, let's go back in.
Because I want to see if there's anything on the other wall.
Oh.
You have to have that equipped, silly.
Turn off!
Aha!
See, I knew there was another wall.
Or another door.
I knew it.
And it's...
Whatever.
Okay, nevermind.
I don't care.
Where is she?
She could have picked a closer location.
Like...
What the hell?
Chris!
Is that Chris that doesn't want to be called Chris?
I think Chris might actually be the one in the left.
I have a stinking suspicion.
That Chris is this one.
I knew it.
Hey!
Snake!
It's me!
Chris!
Come over here!
I'm going to give you a...
Oh, if you knew everything that I went through to get through here.
Halfway across the base.
Goddammit!
Follow me.
Oh, Chris.
30 minutes!
30 minutes, Chris!
There you go!
We won't have to worry about the guards here.
Good.
We can talk.
I'm terrible!
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
Chris is the lady in the heart!
Chris is...
The lady in the...
Like the box art.
Sorry if you heard that.
I'm having my sandwich.
Which is actually my breakfast.
But I've just been kind of nibbling on it all day.
Hi.
Wow, she really does look like everything.
What is it?
What kind of a sandwich?
Egg and bacon.
Lads and lasses and all in between, I think we need to face the music.
Our Oshie is terrible.
Yup.
Call your grandma.
Call your dog.
Call your mom.
Call your dad.
Sorry.
It's just that you're easier on the eyes than any other delta force operator I've met.
As soon as she was like, what is it?
I had a feeling he was gonna be like, I didn't expect you to be so cute.
Call Walt Disney?
No, don't call that guy.
Is that your idea of a compliment?
She is really pretty.
Absolutely.
Wow, that was the worst compliment I've ever heard.
Is that how you win the ladies over?
Yup.
Anyway, what did you find out?
Her smile faded.
Plenty.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, wait.
Oh, that was her.
That was him saying, what did you find out?
Plenty.
Only one researcher is left.
James Harkes.
A.K.A.
Jimmy the...
Jimmy the Wizard.
Why did they give him such a nickname?
Head of Metal Gear Development Team.
Give us Huey, man.
Supposed to be a genius.
Genius.
Get his location.
There are barracks to the north of this building.
Wait, so there is only one researcher left that killed everybody else off?
He seems to be held there.
In the barracks to the north of here.
Got it.
One more thing.
There are four mercenaries working as GILF's military consultants.
Oh boy.
I can't wait to know their names.
Please tell me.
Wow!
Look at them!
Oh my god!
Wow!
Tall man!
Oh, I thought...
For a second I thought...
I just saw...
You know, I know Chris is talking, but I thought his name was Chris for a second.
Slasher Hawk.
His signature weapon is a giant boomerang.
Okay.
Marionette Owl.
Expert assassin and master of nocturnal combat.
Wow.
Big guy.
Pyro Bison.
Who practices his own scorched earth tactics with a massive flamethrower.
These are giving absolute severe mother base names.
And their leader...
Black Art Viper.
Black Art Viper's got some hips, man.
Viper.
Poisonous snake.
They first appeared on the scene around two years ago.
Made a round of hot spots around the world before they set up in Gindra.
I like how it's basically...
It's basically prototype Gray Fox, prototype Psycho Mantis and prototype Vulcan Raven.
They're very, very good.
Rumor has it they're former U.S.
Special Forces.
American?
With their debut streaks.
That was good work in a pretty short time.
I tried my best.
Look at the abs on this suit.
Wow, you can really see how much it looks like the sneaking suit used in actual Metal Gear Solid.
Was that a good enough proof for you?
Let's just say, you convinced me you don't need me babysitting.
What else?
Anything wrong?
Yes.
What's wrong?
Like the fact that we Americans are not welcome around here.
Okay.
What?
Why?
They think that the U.S.
is blocking their independence.
No, America is the country of the free.
That the deployment of peacekeepers is an armed invasion to extend U.S.
control over Gindra.
Well, you guys...well, they stole the Metal Gear.
They caused it.
Like they...they stole the Metal Gear first and then they sent in the peacekeepers.
Is that not how that worked?
Is that...
Oh, it was reverse order.
The peacekeepers were six months ago.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Then...
I mean, well, I'm...we're already working for the U.S.
government who already, like, developed Metal Gear in the first place.
So, like, it's like...it's basically every single Metal Gear game where we...oh, gosh.
We're loyal to the mission anyway.
That's why they have such faith in the general.
Who wants to end U.S.
interference.
And win independence.
I thought our mission was for the good of the people of this country.
Welcome to Metal Gear, baby.
Oh, Chris.
Chris, she's...she's about to say...she's about to say are we the baddies right now.
But what we're doing may be...
Chris, why did you join the military?
Oh, classic Metal Gear.
What?
Well, maybe because I wanted something concrete.
Something concrete.
Like justice or discipline.
All the things we need to keep going.
Chris, the only thing you need on a battlefield to keep going is the instinct to keep living.
Wow.
Her sword is a tool of justice.
Yeah.
I don't want you to die.
Wow.
But...
Think about completing the mission.
About going home alive first.
Yes, I guess so.
I will, for now.
Oh my god.
Chris wants to...she's just like I give up.
I'm going after Harkz.
Jimmy the Wizard.
He must have some valuable information on Metal Gear.
Okay, I'll open the doors with my card three.
Yay!
You can trail me.
Okay.
Chris.
What?
You're going to be okay.
Don't worry.
With this outfit on, no one will spot me.
That's not what I meant.
You forgot your red hat.
I know.
Thanks.
Ladies first.
Oh my gosh, we're going to go meet the Wizard.
The Wizard and I.
Oh my gosh.
Chris.
There's a person.
There's someone else here.
Oh my god, Chris.
There's cameras.
Okay Chris.
Oh Chris, there's two other people here.
Chris, stop letting in more people.
Chris.
She's so chill.
Snake, rescue James Harkz.
I thought he was going to say the Wizard.
The chief of Metal Gear development team.
Harkz is held in the barracks to the north of the watchtower you're in.
First, follow Sergeant Jenner's lead and get to the north side of the tower.
More health!
Yippee!
That was close.
I was going to go knock this guy out.
In fact, I might do it if they come this way.
They don't come this way.
You got lucky, buddy.
I'm going to box up for the...
Don't come around though.
Okay, good.
What?
How?
What saw me?
No way.
Oh god.
The camera.
Are you kidding me?
Are you kidding me right now?
Are you squidding me right now?
Are you squidding me?
The dang camera saw me.
Okay, we're fine.
But the camera was off screen.
I didn't know this game was like that.
Okay, this person has to get back into their positions.
And I think I'm almost good to go now.
They don't come over here.
From what I remember, yeah.
They walk around.
That was my chance.
I need to go up.
Can you go down please?
Thank you.
Oh god.
Jimmy the Wizard is a reference to the 1989 Nintendo movie, The Wizard.
Which was basically one big Nintendo commercial and introduced the Power Glove.
There's lore to Jimmy.
Oh my god, please.
I can't tell if this person will be able to see me or not.
I'm around the corner, but I don't want to risk it.
Okay.
And we're gonna let it go for a bit.
And then we're gonna go.
And then we're gonna leave.
Oh,
there she goes.
Alright, bye bye.
I need...
My fogger.
Are these ones also timed?
Yep.
Goodbye.
Thank you.
Is there other stuff in here?
I wonder.
There's kind of like a corner area.
Disappear!
By the power of Jimmy the Wizard, be gone!
I don't think that one's on a timer.
Okay, nevermind.
Invested in Jimmy the Wizard.
Be gone!
Jimmy!
Lucky.
Oh, lucky lucky lucky.
So lucky.
Lucky.
Oh, wow.
Lucky ducky right there.
Hold on, I don't know what this person is about to do.
They're coming down.
Terrible rating secured.
Yeah, that's how we do it, boys.
Yawn.
Okay, leave.
Bless you.
They're like, who said that?
I hate these rooms.
Okay, so now we have to figure out which one...
is the correct one that we go through.
Disappear.
Oh my gosh, it actually worked.
Okay.
It's a maze.
Yes, it is.
Okay, they're gonna make me go all the way up, aren't they?
Disappear.
I wasn't risking it.
One more time.
I'll pay attention.
I got this.
Go.
Okay.
Disappear.
No.
Wait, the door is up here.
Just kidding.
I'm silly.
Oh, this is the room without the cameras.
Lockstorm.
Is this a person or...
A chaff grenade!
Is this a person here or a camera?
Oh, it's a camera.
Okay.
That's fine.
Good to know.
I'm not gonna waste my chaff.
Well, I don't wanna say waste, but I don't wanna use it right now because...
this room isn't actually so difficult to get out of, it seems.
Just have to be a little bit patient.
And I am a patient soul.
Oh my god.
That was close.
No.
No!
Don't do this to me.
I think there's a place to hide before they come back around.
Almost positive there is.
Might be tight though.
I was ready to break.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Wait, which way is it?
Is it the big circle?
Is it the small circle?
Wait, what's the small circle?
It's the small circle, right?
It's not the big circle.
Big circle leads to... Okay, it's the small circle.
Yeah, yeah.
It's where the red hat person is.
Okay, we got this.
Kissing inbound.
3, 2, 1!
Come on!
Our lips touch.
Uzumaki-ass map, man.
I hate this shit.
If they didn't wake up so fast when I knock them out...
Oh, I just take... Oh god.
Oh my god.
I crawled in there so fast like a damn lizard.
Oh gosh, that scared me.
Okay, we'll just wait for her to leave.
I thought she was turning around.
Tactical smooching action.
Come here.
Oh my gosh, what if the red hats and the blue hats...
Rival?
Like they're different teams?
Like the blue hats are, you know, one team and they're like all fighting against each other or something?
Alright.
I'm guessing I take the elevator.
Red vs.
Blue.
No, there was a green hat too!
Red run!
Thank you for the hot sofa!
Stop by to enjoy some tactical minto espionage action and support the next MGS con!
Looking forward to it.
Thank you!
Yeah, I appreciate it.
Oh yeah, and the brown hats.
Oh my gosh.
Blue here, frick the red team.
TF2 gamer.
We're going down.
We're going down, down.
And we're running around.
And we're following after Chris.
She's got a nice little butt.
And I hope that I can get a kiss.
Joy!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you so much!
I failed.
Wait.
There wasn't like an up, was there?
It was only down, right?
Or am I crazy?
I didn't see it.
Let's go up.
Sorry, I'm a little lost.
I'm a little lost ghosty.
I'm a little lost.
Oh, nope.
There was only down.
OK.
But where did she go?
Where did she go?
There she is.
Oh, I just had to go one door over.
Oh, silliness.
Oh my gosh.
Box, box.
Cardboard box on the right.
Alright.
How far do you go?
I don't trust it at all.
I'm telling you.
Oh no.
No.
Wait,
but this person didn't come over here.
And I think they come down, don't they?
Maybe not.
Turn around.
OK.
We're safe.
Honestly, Ghost Babble is really impressive.
Like, this is just a Game Boy Color game.
Not even GBA.
Wait, not even GBA.
It looks and runs great.
I know, right?
It's so great.
Time to frogger.
Fogger.
Not frogger.
OK, these ones... OK, I think I remember.
It was like around.
These ones don't turn on and off.
Down.
Do I go up?
Yes.
And over.
I have such, like, distrust, you know?
Chris!
This is my first Metal Gear ever and I was fine.
I never got past the first screen so I just did VR missions.
VR missions are fun too.
I actually practiced a little bit.
Oh, I say a little bit.
I did the first mission.
Before stream.
Thanks, thanks for the superchat.
Madeira, thank you for the superchat.
Mother Minto, I need to confess my sins.
As a kid, I owned this game and hated it.
I ended up buried in the bottom of a toy... OK, I thought you were going to say buried in your backyard.
Like, you just got rid of it.
You took care of it.
The barracks where Hark's is kept is to the north... northeast of here.
Got it.
I'll have to head east from here.
And I'll be OK.
What about you?
I'll check out the power plant.
OK.
The power plant.
East?
No, east.
It supplies all the power for this fortress.
Blow it up.
But there's something strange going on.
Hmm, like what?
It's an important installation.
Sure, but there's too much traffic.
Wow.
I'm going to take a look.
See what's up.
Could be Metal Gear.
Chris.
I'll be alright.
Don't worry.
Oh.
I want to go that... I was going to go up that way.
You watch your back Snake.
OK, I'm going to follow you though.
Like for a second.
I just want to see what's up there.
Snake, leave the plant to Jenner.
No!
I want to go see!
And head for the barracks.
Head northeast.
You're there.
OK.
No!
Bang.
Is that a camera or a person?
That's a camera.
You don't come up here, right?
Get looked at.
Oh my god.
That scared me so bad.
Just a box.
No!
I'm full of Russians.
We're fine.
Everybody?
Northeast.
First we go east and then we go north.
That's a person.
The final one.
The last one down there.
And then what do you do?
You walk.
And then...
That's it.
I'm late for the babbling ghost.
Thanks for joining, silly ass.
Oh, what's in here?
What's this?
Chaff grenade!
But my pouch... I only have three!
Don't be... Come on, don't be like that game.
Come on!
Don't be like that game.
Oh no.
It wasn't so easy.
I did it.
It was that easy.
Puzzles are one weakness.
Who do you take me for?
Are these people in cages or are these people?
What is that?
Oh, it's a bird.
An evil bird?
A bird that works for the enemy?
Oh, a dog.
Oh, it's a dog.
I just got here.
Is it showing the full screen?
Yeah!
It's a Game Boy game.
What happens if the bird...
Uh oh, I angered the dogs.
My bad.
Oh no, the dogs are out!
Oh no, it's just more birds.
Oh, and a sleepy man.
Wait, what's in here though?
There's no more dogs.
Is there anything?
Anything of value?
This bird is going to wake this guy up for sure.
Don't, don't, don't... No!
The guy is like the princess and the pea.
He wakes up with the tiniest little sound.
Don't touch the bird.
And don't touch the guy.
Ok, we're fine.
Everything is good.
Alrighty.
See?
Easy pea.
No, the dogs!
Oh my gosh, there's so many dogs.
Oh god.
Ok.
What the?
What did I
do?
They smell my tracks?
They go insane.
Do you think they'll notice the box?
I wonder.
Oh, what's this?
A grenade!
For the dogs.
Oh, nevermind.
I guess they don't notice the box.
Let's go back to this.
Who's coming here?
Who is it?
Oh, it's a regular guy.
A regular Joe.
Oh my god.
I'm a lonely, sickly, disabled woman in her late thirties.
I haven't lived my best.
But you give me a bright spot to look forward to most.
Sorry lady.
You stepped on my toes.
Thanks for being there.
Now be at that con.
Thank you!
Oh my god.
Ladyheadedspikes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for being here.
Glad that I can at least help a little bit.
That was...
Actually so crazy.
How did we survive?
Actual Metal Gear Survive tactics right there.
Shoot, this guy is so fast.
Too close.
Wait, I think so too.
Wait, he goes around to the side, doesn't he?
Oh wait, I think I messed up, guys.
Oh, I think I messed up.
Just run!
Just run, Psych!
Psychic machine, be damned!
Run, Psych!
Who cares about the stick?
Oh my god.
Oh shoot.
Ouch.
Oh my god.
I'm so dead.
Oh, that was a chop grenade.
Where is my weapon?
There we go.
OK.
What?
I lived.
Only three months left.
Until what?
Why is it so ominous?
The guy.
Yeah, the boss weapon.
I didn't realize... I thought...
I was like, is this a boss room for a second?
Oh gosh.
Why are there so many birds?
Why is alerting a... Birds just fly.
Why is alerting the birds like a bad thing?
I don't understand.
How dumb is that?
Are those penguins?
You guys, I have...
I have a legit complaint, OK?
I'm so sick of seeing these dang Christmas commercials.
And they have...
They have penguins in them.
Santa is from the North Pole.
That makes no sense.
Why would there be penguins...
In a North Pole commercial?
You know what I mean?
It's so annoying.
Fair point.
Thank you.
Sneak 100, real.
I might be John Metal Gear.
Oh my god, there's so many...
What?
He's spoovering.
Ouch.
No, I died!
I didn't have my ration equipped.
Where am I?
Oh, I start from here.
You know what?
Honestly...
Oh my god.
Mister, please, leave me alone.
What's over this way?
Instead.
Use my ration.
Grab new ration.
I was pretty much full on health, but whatever.
What's this?
Grenade, more grenade.
What's over here?
More stuff.
But yeah, I saw like a Target commercial today and it just made me so mad.
Because it was like, it showed the penguins...
And then it showed a polar bear like 2 seconds afterwards.
I was like, no, this is...
This is just stupid.
This is just dumb.
Do you think they'll catch me in here?
Oh, come on.
No way.
More grenade!
Leave me alone!
Stupid dogs!
Gosh, these dogs hit.
They hit!
Thank god.
No!
Stop!
Boomerang!
Die.
I'm gonna die.
Maybe, you know what?
I'm just gonna try again, honestly.
Just kill me.
There we go.
Because I'll see where it brings me back.
Oh, not great.
Did I at least press the button?
Okay.
Imagine if I had gone and I forgot to pre-press the button.
That's so cruel.
I hate the dogs.
They can sniff me.
I'm so far, so mean.
Go away!
Stop camping!
Okay, hold on.
Sniffer, sniffer.
Who's throwing that boomerang?
An eventual boss.
An eventual boss guy.
Okay, hold on.
I have to be a little strategic about this, I think.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Maybe I should have saved that ration.
Maybe I should have saved that ration, huh?
Maybe I was a fool.
Maybe I was a big ol' dummy idiot.
Leave me alone!
Which way did I go before?
I wonder if I can go this way.
Or if it's gonna alert the bird.
I hate this.
Thank god, okay.
Truly a baka.
Just a box.
Alright, we'll go the same way we did before.
Long way it is, yeah.
Seems to be the better way.
I guess.
I did it so smoothly before.
I don't know if I'll be able to...
Just kidding.
I was able to do it just as smoothly as before.
Oh my god.
Yay!
Grenade.
Actually, I am gonna use this one.
Wait, wrong thing.
Grab.
No.
Ration.
What are these?
Grenades.
Am I supposed to use the grenades against the dogs?
I don't know.
Here he is!
Oh no, I think I'm supposed to use the grenades against him!
Solid Snake!
Who's there?
No!
Oh my god, Vulcan Raven!
Not really.
Hawk.
I am Slasher Hawk.
He looks like... He looks like he's from He-Man or something.
Oh my god.
He looks so crazy.
No!
Thundercats!
He looks like Thundercats!
He's got the hair and everything.
One of the mercenaries that decimated Delta... Delta Force.
That's right!
A boring little clean up job.
I've had it with these mother effing penguins and this mother effing Christmas commercial.
That's truly mean.
Hopefully we only need to fight him once.
Why do you say it like that Nexie?
Why do you say it like that?
Lion-O!
Yes!
How do you know my name?
Your reputation precedes you.
Solid Snake.
It's a very special name to us, the Black Chamber.
Black Chamber.
Unlike the pawns here, we have no interest in the general's ideals or bid for independence.
Otherwise it will be Hawk too.
Oh come on.
Stop!
But let me... Oh my gosh, I saw a video the other day.
I guess when like... You know the company Peloton?
They do like the stationary bikes and you have the Peloton classes and stuff like that.
There was a compilation.
Apparently, I guess if you join their online classes, they'll read out your username or something.
It's like a stream or something.
And I just saw a compilation of them reading out stupid names like the Hawk Tua and the Huge Anus and stuff like that.
And it was just a full compilation.
And I was like hearing ones that I've never even heard before.
You guys have to step up your game.
But let me tell you this.
Black Chamber, not Foxhound, is the world's best special forces unit.
And I'll prove it with your dead body.
Oh boy.
OK here we go.
First boss fight.
Take this!
A boomerang.
Yeah, we heard about this in the codec.
Is the bird going to attack us too?
Because that's kind of messed up.
That's an overused white man's name.
My people call it...
This is a weapon of proud lineage.
And it's your guide into the afterlife.
Boomerang Bobby.
No, it's not a boomerang.
Outer Heaven is what you're remembered for.
And Outer Heaven is where you'll be buried.
That was hard actually.
Start digging!
DIGGING!
Oh my gosh.
Ouch.
I'm not even hitting him.
I think I have to... Hold on.
I think I
have...
There we go.
And... that.
OK.
Grenades.
He's up on a hill.
I see.
OK.
How do I use the... Oh wait.
I selected this.
I'm an idiot.
Sorry guys.
Oh, grenades.
Grenades.
Inflicts damage.
B to throw.
Oh, nevermind.
He has so much more health than me.
Oh my god.
This does big damage.
Holy shit.
Keep throwing these ones.
They're easier to dodge please.
Thank you.
What just happened?
This hawk is my totem.
And my protector.
God, he really is just...
Prototype Vulcan Raven.
As long as it flies, I will fight.
Go!
No!
Bird!
Please leave me alone.
Oh my god.
Now I have to fight the bird too?
No!
Leave me alone!
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch.
Oh my god.
We're getting him?
Nice.
This game is gonna lower my self-esteem, which I didn't even think was possible.
I didn't think it was possible to go any lower, but...
So sad.
Oh wow, we get death scenes too?
Wow, this is so awesome.
Hawk, why me?
You, all of you, took away my family.
The birds.
Terrible is maybe the funniest rank I've ever seen.
What are you talking about?
I grew up in Australia.
Nice, you beat him.
And the hawk too.
Oh my gosh, that's so funny.
But that's what a vampire would say.
You beat him.
Hawk too, bleh.
You get it?
Bleh, bleh.
Hawk too, bleh.
He's dying, don't choke.
Sorry, sorry.
What the people you call...
Oh, aborigines.
But that's not what I was born as.
Oh my god, he kinda looks so scary though with his eyes.
I was abandoned.
Parents took me in, raised me against...
The elders' opposition.
So cold.
Everyone was always so cold to me.
I'd go where the talking and laughter was.
And they'd scatter.
That's what you guys do.
I come back and you all say scatter.
Leave me with the ashes.
I tried.
I observed the customs.
The taboos.
More than anyone else.
I tried to win their acceptance.
But when my parents died...
They turned me.
They turned me out.
Wouldn't let me be one of them.
From then on, I drifted all over the world.
Notorious BSV, happy birthday!
Give me one second after this, I'll sing you.
And everywhere I went, I was an outsider.
Thank you so much for the pink superchat!
No one accepted me.
But Viper was different.
He took me in.
Accepted me into the black chamber.
It was my home and...
You!
All of you!
What?
I'll be dead.
But Viper...
I know that Viper...
Will avenge me.
Taste it.
Our bitterness.
Our grief.
No funeral pyre, Snake.
It's forbidden.
This hawk will carry my spirit home.
This is just Metal Gear, man.
This is just Metal Gear Solid.
Yes.
Finally.
Going home.
Will they...
Let me in?
This time?
It's so sad.
Written by Fukushima?
Wait, actually...
As expected.
I'm really sorry, Hawk.
Hold on.
I'm trying to get to a spot where...
I can sing happy birthday.
Nice.
Alrighty.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Notorious B.S.G.
Happy birthday!
Yay!
This is where we learn his hawk's name is Tua.
I wish we could go back to the times when Hawk came after Mike.
Why can't we go back to those simpler times?
When Hawk...
This is an elevator.
When after Hawk...
Wait, when after Mike came Hawk.
You know?
Oh.
This is why we explore, everybody.
Simpler times.
What is this?
I'm afraid to touch it.
You think I can touch it?
That's fine.
Stop being tired and go.
Keep patrolling.
Okay,
what's on the other side?
Why didn't she give us her level 3 card?
It's kind of messed up, isn't it?
I have a feeling someone is going to come over here.
Mike Tua.
No.
I
can't tell.
I'm seeing what the other person's route is too.
It's hard to tell.
I think I can go here.
Oh, it's not a person.
That would explain it.
Okay, nice.
Please let me in.
Nevermind.
I think I have to go get the level 3 card.
Probably in that other side.
Or upstairs or something.
This wouldn't be a problem if Chris had not been so selfish.
I don't think she needs the level 3 card at the power plant.
I'm just saying.
Oh my god, I'm stuck here.
Remember the chaff.
Actually, wait.
I think this was a mistake.
Okay, nevermind.
I'm good.
Alright, let's go knock this guy out.
That's not a card.
Okay, got it.
Oh,
I forgot this kills him.
I got terrible ranking.
Gosh, he has such a weak skull.
He's like a baby.
He has such a weak skull.
I'm sorry.
What's this guy gonna do?
I can't tell at all.
Okay, he's going down that way.
I can box here.
I believe.
Is he gonna go up?
Are you gonna finish this entire game tonight, Rinto?
It's not very long, so...
I'm going to attempt to do that, yeah.
There will be an attempt.
Keep patrolling, mister.
There could be a bad guy.
There could be an intruder.
At any moment.
It's so annoying having to switch the card keys though.
No, are you serious?
Okay.
Up we go.
Boxed and ready.
Well, I guess we didn't...
Oh no, the noisy floors.
The noisy floors.
Beware the noisy floor.
Just a box.
Stun grenade.
Nice.
I think this is also a... yeah.
Security camera.
Which way shall we go?
Go this way.
Why not?
Oh, noisy floor.
Sneaky sneaky.
Sneak around you.
I'll take your ammo.
And I'll go down.
There's nothing here.
Okay, let's go.
Let's leave this place.
Sneak sneak sneak.
Sneaky sneaky.
There we go.
Alright, back to box.
I think there was a door right down here as well.
So we shall go investigate.
The cameras are so slow.
Which I guess is a good thing.
But also a frustrating thing.
Another maze room.
Some more stun grenades.
We love to see it.
Uzumaki.
Game has been surprisingly good so far.
Yeah, a lot of people have always really praised Ghost Bevel.
What is the point?
What?
There's nothing here.
What is the point of these red...
These red areas.
Ah,
it's a fast travel area.
Loading gates.
Okay, that's what I thought it might be.
But...
Is this guy coming down or what?
Maybe I have time.
Nope, I
don't...
But it might be useful later.
Yeah.
I thought it might be like a fast...
That's why I was like, oh, if I'm as the box.
But I'm just a yellow box.
I'm just a yellow box.
Nobody wants me.
This is sad.
Alright, what else was there?
I think there was a noisy area.
Up there.
Up here.
There's a noisy area we can go through.
I'm going.
But I'm being very quiet.
Chop grenade.
Okay.
Maybe if you add the Amazon logo.
Maybe.
I'm not being noisy.
I'm being very quiet.
It's stealthy.
In fact, I might be...
Oh, what was that?
Grenade.
Oh my gosh, please give me something.
Anything.
Can I... I couldn't go through this door, right?
Oh shoot.
He's looking.
Oh, he's looking, looking, looking.
I'm waiting for him to come back.
Where else was...
Oh, I guess we can go upstairs.
We'll go upstairs then.
Because we're in the basement.
Back to box.
Oh gosh.
Took a bit of a risk there, but...
It's good.
It's all good.
I think we're good here too.
Nice.
Alright.
That guy couldn't see me, right?
I don't think so.
Okay, let's go to...
Floor...
Eight?
Wait, we're at B1.
Then we go to Floor 1.
And then we go to...
Eight?
I've never seen Minto focus that much.
Just chill.
Where are the child soldiers?
The ones that are like, I love daddy, big boss.
Oh no, it's like that Pokemon...
Oh my gosh, it really is just like that Pokemon...
I'm a yellow box!
We're going to the yellow box area.
Yellow, send me to the yellow area!
Send me yellow!
Yellow, yellow, yellow!
I'm a yellow box!
Team Rocket hideout.
Yeah, why should I?
I'm a yellow box!
Where are we going?
Oh, I'm going to be so lost.
But, this might be... Oh my gosh, do you see the radar?
It's so bad.
I'm a yellow box!
People say fast travel, but I think this might be the slowest fast travel I've ever experienced.
Cardboard box!
Oh, we're all the way here!
Okay.
We have to go all the way back to the conveyor belt.
How fun.
Just a box.
Red.
All my red boxes, rise up!
It's our time!
I'm going to change my weapon before I...
Let's change it to that.
I don't know, maybe it'll be useful.
Yosha!
And box.
But red box this time.
How fun.
It's really nice getting...
Oh, thank goodness he's blind!
Sheesh.
Okay.
Diagonal crawling?
What an age we live in, right?
Craziness.
There we go.
Oh wait, I need the box.
I need my hands for you.
Let me in.
Alright.
Upwards we go.
To the red box area.
How exciting.
And up once again.
Oh, again?
I am doing this correctly, right?
Like, the intention is to get the red box and then do it all over again, right?
I assume.
Well, here we go.
Wait a second.
I think I have to...
Can you change the box while on the belt?
Let's try it after.
Okay, and it's not like one of those things where you go through and it activates a switch and...
Okay, let's see.
We start as a yellow box.
Oh my gosh, this is some real, like...
Yellow.
Oh, I have to say yellow.
Wait, what if I'm a red box?
I'm kind of curious what happens.
Okay.
Alright, I learned my lesson.
I experimented.
There we go.
Okay.
I'm a yellow box.
Just kidding.
I'm a red box.
Where are we going?
I want to be... Oh, no, no!
I meant to change to the yellow box.
Dang it.
We're going to get returned to sender again.
No!
I'm a yellow box.
I wasn't fast enough before I realized what was happening.
Just kidding.
I'm a red box.
I'm a yellow box.
Before I forget.
Got distracted by grooving.
You are 100% correct.
That is exactly what happened.
What the... Oh, I'm all the way here?
Okay, we got to do it again.
Again.
Okay, so the second time is when it gives us the choice between red and yellow.
We choose yellow.
Again!
Let's do it one more time.
Probably more than one more time.
I'm not going to lie.
We are a yellow box for a while.
Here, we're yellow.
Yellow!
Next one, yellow.
Not red.
Yellow!
Red.
Which one do I choose?
One more time!
What's the shipping cost for a box of mint?
Return to sender.
The shipping costs are extreme.
Okay, yellow.
This song.
I'm going to hear it in my dreams tonight.
I think you need the blue box.
Well, we got to find the blue box.
Now red.
And then we immediately switch back to yellow.
So now back to yellow.
Wait.
Red?
I don't know.
This is new.
This is new territory.
We actually made it out somewhere.
Oh.
Take me home!
No way.
Wait, is this taking us?
Is this returning to...
I don't know if we've gone this way before.
Let's do red.
A new place!
An actual new place.
A place we can actually...
Gas!
And there's men!
No!
No men in the gas room, please!
ID card 3!
Oh shoot.
Okay, I'm going to have to take him out, I think.
Gas, gas, gas.
Okay.
Alright.
Letter 02.
Replenish.
Okay.
Men in the gas room.
It's kind of horrible and mean.
You don't think he'll die this time, do you?
Oh god.
Leave!
Uh...
We have... The world is our oyster now!
We have so many more locations we can go to.
Now that we're at level 3.
Have we been here before?
This place is so confusing.
Wait.
No, I don't know if we have...
I'm going to become a yellow box.
I don't know.
Wait, oh, I thought that person was going...
Oh, nevermind.
It all looks the same to me.
Me too!
I can't tell!
We're at the elevator.
Is this the first floor?
Yeah, this is the first floor!
But that's okay, because there's a door over here that I think we can now go through.
But I think it's good.
It's actually okay.
Yeah, bing bing!
And then bing bing!
Bing bing!
Nice!
What's this?
Chop grenade!
Is it time to save?
You know what?
Yeah.
It's been a minute since we've talked to... Oh.
Talked to anybody.
Let's talk in the codec a little bit.
Campbell, how's it going?
The engineer who designed Metal Gear is being held somewhere in that building.
Yeah, that's right.
I forgot we were looking for that guy.
Rescue him and get as much information about Metal Gear out of him as possible.
Okay.
I'll save.
What's up, Snake?
Okay.
Ever heard of this?
Dr. Coplethorn says...
Look, these quotations and sayings are great, but I'd also like to get to know you!
Foolish is the one who offers deep confidence in shallow alliance.
What?
It's a Chinese proverb.
Means that it's unwise to tell important things to someone you don't even know.
Great.
I wish these were voiced so I could eat some of my sandwich.
Do you guys mind if I take a couple bites?
I'm getting hungry.
I can't believe it's already been four hours.
I... it doesn't feel like it at all for me.
Like in most African states, Kindra is an ethnically diverse nation.
Since each group has its own language, there's a large number of languages in use within the national border.
On the other hand, the official language is French.
So you shouldn't have any trouble communicating your intentions.
As long as you brush up on your language skills.
Okay.
Where are... oh wait, I think I... I think I know where we are here too.
We've been here before too.
This is the elevator right over to the right.
Okay, so we just went in a circle, which is fine, but...
Yeah.
We have to find the blue box.
What other areas could we not go in?
Because we didn't have a card key.
We're
over there, I think.
I'm starting to not remember.
Take the card key to the... oh, to the conveyor belt door, you're right.
Do you want me to give you a hint where the blue box is?
Let me go to the conveyor belt door first, and then I will ask.
Thank you.
Yeah, let's do that first.
Let's go there, and then we'll...
Yeah, yeah.
Probably another branch up.
Yeah, I don't think we exhausted all of the options, honestly.
I have like no weapon, no nothing.
If I was Snake, I would have said, who asked?
True.
Okay.
Oh.
I have to go up.
Wait, oh wait.
No, this is where we... I'm so lost.
We have to go up one more.
This one.
There's too much to see, there's too much to see.
Okay.
What if I go as a person?
And this is yellow too.
And this one is red.
Because we didn't go yellow and then see if there was any more red, you know?
So it could be that there's more red options without going the other way.
Oh wait.
Red here?
Keycard 3.
Yeah!
We made it!
And some rations!
Lucky, lucky.
Oh no.
No!
Sun grenade, okay.
We're just dancing with this fella for a second.
I can't with this song.
The next time you're awake, can you record a video of you just wiggling?
I think that can feed us for a long time.
What are you talking about?
Blue!
Blue box!
Whoever was going to give me the hint, thank you, but I don't need it!
I got the blue box!
Alright.
I know where this is because I explored it.
I know.
Because I went entirely through it.
I went entirely through it.
And this is why you stay boxed, everybody.
I think they go down that little hallway.
Alright.
Okay, back to...
the rooftop.
I hate how slow the cameras are.
I mean, again, it's good that they're slow.
But also, why you gotta be so slow?
Stealthy box.
Upwards!
Don't mention fortresses.
I'm still scarred from Minecraft.
Minecraft.
You're scarred.
You're scarred from Minecraft?
Must be nice.
For that to be your burden.
Alright, blue belt.
Where are we going?
Yellow.
No, otherwise we're going to get returned to sender.
I didn't see where... I didn't see where the middle one went.
Oh no, wait.
I think we have to stay yellow.
I think the middle one just goes back down.
Okay.
Nothing here.
Wait!
I should have been blue!
This is back where we got the red box.
What?
Maybe I should have switched?
Can someone just... Okay, I'm asking...
I'm asking for hints now.
I got the blue box.
I'm getting blue box right now.
Wherever that one person was that said where... they'll give me a hint for the blue box.
If you can also give me a hint of what to do from here.
Or else I'm just going to look up my own guide, but that will take longer.
This section is exactly why a guide is useful.
Okay, I'm going to look up my own guide then.
ID, level card 3.
We need to get that one.
Blue box, got that one.
We need to get the thermal goggles.
Okay, so star, yellow, blue.
Wait.
We need to go to the storeroom.
Need IR goggles to reach hearts.
So I go to the storeroom?
I have to go through the... since I need the IR goggles to reach hearts.
But I gotta go through the storeroom.
Hopefully the storeroom doesn't need the IR goggles.
Because we have to go through them to get to the thermal goggles.
So, right, up, left.
And then instead of yellow, we blue at the end.
And then we yellow again.
I'm looking at the guide for you.
It's confusing.
It is, right?
So we're yellow.
And then we go up.
We blue.
And then... sorry.
We're going to be yellow again.
Just said!
Thank you for the hug so far!
We seriously need a clip of Wiggle Bit.
Thank you!
Thank you for the hug so far.
I really appreciate it.
Okay, I will put together a clip.
Wait, okay, here...
We blue.
She's using psychokinetic wiggles.
I've kind of been really obsessed with watching... you know the Wiggles?
The Wiggles?
I've been kind of obsessed with watching videos of The Wiggles recently.
Oh my god, this is the storeroom?
Why is it like all bricked up?
It doesn't look like storage at all.
It looks like bricks.
Okay, I'm just going to stay as a box, I think.
Ah...
Turn around!
There we go.
Over here.
We have to go onto the other conveyor belt and go as blue.
Save!
Wait, what's in here?
Oh, nevermind.
Can I... can I... can I... nope.
There we go.
Let's go!
Wait, wait, wait!
Sorry.
Red.
Red, red.
Okay.
Gave me a tummy ache.
I got so scared.
The panic.
Yay!
Derpacagos!
Where are we?
This is not open?
It's a door.
Door.
Where does this lead us to?
Nobody knows.
Oh, it's sleepy guy!
I don't remember where sleepy guy was though.
But...
Okay, he's asleep.
Where was he?
Go on, I'm sleepy.
Oh wait, I do know where we are.
Box.
I feel... asleep.
Alright.
I think we've been to this floor like maybe 500 bajillion times.
Okay, now we go back to the storage room.
And we go to Harker.
Before we do anything else.
Before...
Well, the map kind of spoiled what's coming up.
The guide map kind of spoiled what's coming up next, but that's okay.
I won't tell you guys.
Yeah, we gotta go to the dark room first.
Okay.
Sorry, I just need my mic.
Okay, let me get my guide back up.
Okay, good, good, good.
Yellow, yellow.
We are back, baby.
I'm back.
That might have been risky, but I just wanted to see.
That might have been very risky.
Oh, I don't know how long he stays there.
Okay, nevermind.
Knowledge get.
This guy moves so...
Plonk, plonk.
Alright, maybe prepare your eyes.
We could have made it.
Do I still need the mic?
Nope, we're good.
Stairs.
I think that's where we were before, right?
Oh!
I'm just a box.
Oh, I was short.
That's okay, baby.
I think I can hide in this...
Who's that?
He can't hear me.
Is that him?
Is that our wizard?
Oh, wow.
Wow, he's...
That's our...
I think that's our wizard.
Please, no.
Please, please, please, please.
Turn to the right.
I mean the left!
I meant
the...
This is what I had to say.
But I didn't want him to listen to me.
I think my box will be okay.
Okay.
Oh, goodness.
That made my tummy hurt.
What's in here?
Oh, I think the way to get to him...
There we go!
He's like, the guy is like, why is this van coming in?
Why is this blue box moving?
Hey!
The wizard.
You don't have to look... Wait, you don't look like one of those goons.
We're no gooner.
Get me out of here!
Push a mark?
Or do you want me to yell for the guard?
You a hostage?
Name's Jimmy.
Is this a real Metal Gear game?
Yeah, it's a real Metal Gear game.
Yeah, they're like, complete losers.
At first, I got to do whatever I wanted.
Then, once Metal Gear neared completion, I got thrown into this dump.
Jimmy, you're James Harks?
You can call me Jimmy, the wizard.
If you're gonna get me out of here.
He's snarky.
They let a kid lead the Metal Gear development?
They've let children pilot Metal Gear Snake, so you know.
Yeah, I may be half your age.
But I'm twice as smart as you, buddy.
I'm not that old.
Really?
You look it, man.
Oh my god.
It's just because I'm a clone, okay?
It's fast aging.
Accelerated aging.
Because I'm a clone.
Who are you anyway?
Doesn't matter.
I'm the guy sent to get you and destroy Metal Gear.
And that's all you need to know.
Whatever, lone ranger.
You with the US military?
I'm not with any military.
What?
What the?
Just a misfit.
What the hell kind of answer is that?
Snake, you're not really making yourself...
Who cares as long as you get me out.
Come on.
I'm sick of this place.
There's no way past these bars.
Any other way into this room?
No, but...
But what?
I tapped on the walls and the east one sounds different.
It may be thinner than the other ones.
Oh no, do we need the C4?
The east wall, huh?
Okay, I'll get a hold of some explosives.
And try blowing through it.
Oh, there he goes.
Oh, that's it.
Okay.
There he is.
He's wandering around.
Oh my god.
He's an absolute unit.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Wait, is he only wearing one shoe?
Oh, nevermind.
Okay, we're fine.
Oh my god, is that Doki Bird in there?
That scared me.
Alright, so now...
Do you think he laughs and grows fat?
I believe so, honestly.
Maybe he's a genius and he grows up to become Fatman.
He built a bipedal nuclear...
Well, actually, I don't remember what this Metal Gear is like, if it's bipedal or not.
But he built a...
Oh, a portable?
Maybe?
Asterisk.
Nuclear walking device?
Nuclear... Wait, device?
And then he grows up to build bombs.
As well.
B1.
What's in here?
Supplies!
C4!
Oh, we got it so fast.
Okay, nice.
Is this the one?
Ammunition.
No, this isn't west, this is east.
You need to go to the east wall.
What?
But I went to the right.
How would this...
This is the east wall.
Oh, I think it's...
C4.
B to set, A to detonate.
So this one, maybe.
That...
Did not work.
The furthest most wall?
Okay.
I'm glad no one showed up.
No one is doing their jobs around here.
It's kind of awesome.
Otacon's unused concept was Big Hacker.
Dude, what are you doing?
I'm...
Oh my god, that's so silly.
That's actually...
That's actually so silly.
No way.
Oh, I can actually go through here, okay.
Okay, I get it, I get it.
Or wait...
Nope.
Okay, that's so funny.
Oh gosh, the music scared me for a second.
At the conveyor belt?
Ah, I see.
Ready for one more ride on the conveyor belt?
Wait, let me look at the guide.
Where do I stop though?
Conveyor belt brings you to the east wall.
I don't see where to stop though.
I apologize for mixing directions.
It's okay.
Where you got the thermal goggles?
Where I got the thermal goggles... Like I go...
Wait, huh?
Where the hell did that guy come from?
Thermal goggles?
Wait.
Oh, okay, down there.
Okay, okay, okay.
I see, I see.
Alright, let's wait for him to pass.
Okie dokie.
There he is.
Oh my god.
Oh gosh, that scared me.
I'll be here for a second.
And let them pass by again.
Close one, I know, right?
Okay, sheesh.
No!
Wait, maybe I can go.
Yeah.
Maybe I should have gone the other way.
That was close.
Oh wait, now I'm good.
I couldn't go down there, so yeah, I have to go...
I'm so confused.
Where should I go?
Thermal goggles.
Okay, thermal goggles.
Wait.
I'm messing up, I'm messing up.
There we go.
Take your time, Minto.
Thank you.
Oh, I have it in my eyes.
So down here... wait.
I have to check again.
Thermal goggles is blue, red.
Blue.
And then red.
No, no, no, just kidding.
Sorry, blue.
Blue, and then red.
I'm trusting you guys, I'm trusting you guys.
It didn't tell me on my guide...
that I needed to go here for...
to blow up, so...
I'm trusting you guys.
I see, because... oh yes, there is the cameras.
I see, I see, I see, I see.
Okay.
Place.
Activate.
That took a while.
Are you really as great as you say you are?
Minutes!
Holy cow!
Jimmy!
Okay, get me out of this hole.
Terrible.
Not so fast.
First, tell me about Metal Gear.
He even got Otacon's hair.
Prototype Otacon.
I thought you were going to help me.
Talk first.
Well, that's just great.
You know Jimmy, you would be a lot more likeable...
if you didn't have this stinking attitude.
I can always leave you here.
Are you going to give me answers?
Alright, alright.
Ask away, will ya?
Daru?
No, Daru is a thousand times more handsome than this guy.
What are you talking about?
Where is Metal Gear, first of all?
In the maintenance base.
To the north of the first floor.
Wait, in the maintenance...
North of the first floor, northwest exit.
Okay, everybody.
First floor, northwest exit.
Of this barrack.
Barracks?
Okay, first floor, northwest exit of this building.
Then north.
Metal Gear's operational.
The assembly's done.
That's why I got locked up.
They're probably adjusting the power net now.
It's really nuclear capable.
Even snakes' boops and beeps are gravelly.
I know, right?
It's so good.
Yep, the South American trip was supposed to be for practical exercises.
Brought real nuclear warheads along.
That's crazy.
How could you be permitted to take a nuke out of the country?
Parker, the army chief of staff, is a big fan of the project.
The army's top brass?
Yeah, so we got all the funding we wanted.
And the project moved pretty quickly.
The army's top ass.
Ass with a B.
So why so much effort?
What were they planning to do with Metal Gear?
Project Bavel!
What is it?
It's some project of Parker's.
That's what Metal Gear's supposed to be... for.
What is it?
I don't know.
The details.
They wouldn't tell me.
Guys, this is pretty suspicious.
Not like I care.
I just want to be where I can make the best use of my talents.
You make weapons of war that can kill millions of people.
Kill millions... dot dot dot... of people.
Yeah, Snake, he could have been talking about anything.
Millions of fish, millions of snakes, millions of kittens.
Look what's happening right now.
That's to do with people who use them.
Not with me.
Not with Metal Gear itself.
What else is Metal Gear supposed to be used for?
I don't care what anyone says.
Metal Gear is a masterpiece.
Don't save this guy, right?
Jimmy Sykes!
The product of every technical genius I possess.
Nobody can build anything so...
What is it?
Power failure.
This could be bad.
Why?
They're going to go nuclear with Metal Gear.
What?
Metal Gear can launch warheads with a railgun.
Wow, sounds so familiar.
But the railgun has an enormous power consumption.
So they're charging the thing up with all the power they can get.
Who could have guessed?
Yeah.
Oh sorry, I think that was Snake saying it.
How long till full charge?
About 30 minutes!
Oh gosh, you guys, I only have 30 minutes to beat the stream.
30 minutes to a nuclear strike.
Colonel.
Oh, Chris.
Chris, come in.
Snake?
The power plant just went into overdrive.
What the hell?
No time to talk.
Then why'd you call, Snake?
I found the Metal Gear researcher.
I'd like you to take over his protection.
Okay, but what about you, Snake?
I'm going after Metal Gear.
Metal Gear?
What's going on?
There's no time.
Wait, she doesn't even know that Metal Gear is here?
I thought Project... I thought the Delta Force was supposed to be helping me.
I thought they don't even know that Metal Gear was here?
I'm counting on you.
Huh?
Oh my god, they already... they automatically put on the infrared.
Metal Gear is in a maintenance base to the north of this barrack, right?
Yeah, but...
No time to talk.
Begin tapping.
Wait a sec, what about me?
You stay here.
Hey, weren't you supposed to get me out?
Your new Delta Force bodyguard will be along shortly.
You'll like her.
She's hot.
What am I supposed to do alone?
Until then, what were you doing before?
Just chill, I don't know.
What are you, a kid?
Okay, okay.
Man, you really need to work on your... don't say social skills.
People skills!
Well, he didn't say social skills.
Snake,
put a stop to Metal Gear.
It seems to be to the north of where you are.
Get to the north of the barracks first.
Nice.
Oh, there's jamming even?
Oh no.
Okay, hold on.
Alright.
Brewed Coffee, welcome to Membo Show.
I guess I have to go this way.
I'm looking at my little guide map and I'm just going to say it.
It tells me to go where Marionette Owl is, which is one of the bosses.
So, do I go there or do I go to the first floor?
If you finish stage 5 without getting the IR goggles, Jimmy gives you a fare.
This game came out 2 years after MGS1.
Wait, it wasn't before Metal Gear Solid?
This has been an awful lot of Metal Gear ghost babbling.
Set before?
Oh, I always thought it was set before Metal Gear Solid when it came before.
It's just primitive because cartridge.
I never realized.
I never knew the date.
I wondered why you were saying prototype.
Yeah, because I was like, oh, this is...
That's my bad.
I assumed timeline equaled...
Equaled and...
What's the word?
You know.
Release date.
Wait.
Oh, I can just walk now.
Wait, where did I go?
Can I save her?
Oh, this is sleepy guy.
He's still sleepy.
Good thing the lights are off for him now.
Oh gosh, this is gonna be tricky.
So I'm assuming the power is out so the cameras don't work.
Yeah, look at that.
Okay, what floor are we on?
Oh, no way.
How?
How the hell?
Oh my god, please.
Oh, wait.
I didn't mean to do that.
Wait, there we go.
Do you think they'll see me?
They all have thermal goggles?
Messed up.
He saw me so fast too.
So, so fast.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
It's jammed so I can't tell.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna chill in my box until maybe the people that...
Okay.
Alright, let's see now.
Snake!
Snake, run.
Oh my god, this guy is a maniac.
Oh, thank god.
Oh wait, the elevator is not gonna work.
Okay, so we need to go to the northwest.
Where I was.
I didn't need to go...
Wait.
What's the map of...
I don't know the map of this place.
Okay.
Maybe save the game.
You know what, you're right.
Mailing!
Need anything?
They say you can't be in two places at the same time.
If Mito keeps getting the terrible rank, then we know why the game is called Ghost Babe L.
But if we see a higher rank, is it Ghost Babe W?
Yeah!
For west.
You can't do two things at the same time.
Either.
You're not doing something else while you play this game.
Are you?
No, I'm not...
I mean, I'm...
Streaming doesn't really count, right?
Like, it's different.
Right.
Okay, please, please don't let that guy be here.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
He's gonna come by.
He's gonna pass.
Okay, here we go.
This counts as northwest, right?
Even in the dark they're patrolling.
They're too married to their jobs.
Wait, oh, this is...
Oh, this is this room.
I think I need to go down here?
Oh, gosh.
I think I'm gonna have to box it.
No, please.
Three, two, one.
Honestly, I feel like I should just knock this guy out, but I think he'll wake up too fast.
For me to crawl around...
Crawl away.
I wonder if you can go on the conveyor belts now.
Oh, like walk on them.
I was able to before I fell down the hole, so...
I'm assuming I'd be able to do the rest of them too.
Gosh, this part is so evil.
I'm scared this guy's gonna see me down here.
I can't see him, so I don't know where he is.
Oh, there he is.
And you can't tell which direction they're facing.
The most evil.
Alright, okay.
Okay, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
This guy doesn't go up, does he?
I think he goes right to the... or to the left.
There we go, yeah.
Neon!
Box it.
And now we pray.
Let's count down from ten.
Oh, I just saw him walk by!
Just kidding!
Cool.
Why do the doors not work?
If...
Okay, now we go up.
Wait, is this wrong?
No, I need to be on the first... wait, what?
I'm so confused.
Oh, I think I need to go...
Wait, floor one instead of...
Instead of... was that considered the basement?
I see.
That's why I was so confused.
Now go to the far left, yeah.
I don't remember where the people are in this area, though.
I don't remember where they are, so it's gonna be a little freaky.
I remember a guy walks down here, but...
Oh, this is giving me such a tummy ache.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Is this the guy that turns around?
When he's like walking by?
The cameras don't work though now, which is good.
So we don't have to worry about that.
What you doing, huh?
We dancing?
Oh gosh, are you kidding me right now?
No way.
No way, how am I supposed to...
Well,
I did it.
Nevermind.
How am I supposed to?
Just like that.
Do I like crawl through?
Oh, yep.
Okay, cool.
We can't get off, but... Wait, can I go like up?
Oh, okay, hold on.
So we're going to the...
Which way does this go to?
Yeah, moonwalk, moonwalk, moonwalk.
What's fine?
What is that?
I don't know where... Okay, I think this leads to the storeroom.
Okay, nice.
Hold on, I'm going to reset it.
Yeah, this is Metal Gear, guys.
This is Metal Gear.
Chris!
Snake, I've got Jimmy.
Oh good, kill him!
Everything alright?
Is Jimmy okay?
Yes, he's not injured or anything.
I thought we were watching Donkey Kong.
Yeah, he's going up the...
What building did Rose say he goes up?
He seems to have been keeping out of sight well.
Well, it's dark, so I hope, but...
But what?
This kid's a real pain in the butt.
Oh, Jimmy, did you say something?
Oh, Jimmy!
No, nothing.
Liar, I heard you.
You're the one who's a pain.
Telling me what to do all the time.
What do you think you are?
My mom?
I
wouldn't want to be your mom even if someone paid me to do it.
She wishes she never would give birth to you, Jimmy.
Excuse me!
Nothing.
Look, I'm in the middle of a conversation.
Do you mind shutting up?
The worst she can say is no.
The worst she can say is if I were your mother, I would regret giving birth to you.
Shut up yourself.
You've got a real attitude problem.
You know that?
It's just going to make things more difficult for you as a woman in the military.
Jimmy!
Muzzle it!
You shut up when I tell you to shut up!
Oh, I want to put Jimmy through the military.
You know what, Jimmy?
You wouldn't even be able to get through one day of basic...
Not even one day, like one hour of basic training.
Sorry, Snake.
Why did you call?
Oh yeah, because you found him.
Glad to hear you two are getting along.
Ha, I never thought I'd be babysitting... again.
Especially... under fire.
But I guess it's like riding a bike.
Yeah, Jimmy, if you were so smart, you wouldn't have been in jail, okay?
This guy is so stupid.
That's what I'm counting on.
Okay.
Oh gosh, hopefully there's nobody over here.
Uh...
Let's use my rations.
Oh no.
Yeah, there we go.
Yay!
Okay, back to glasses.
Oh my god!
Okay, I guess I...
Okay, let's just go.
Scared the hell out of me.
Here we go.
Oh, crap.
Wait, which way do I go?
Have I been here before?
Oh gosh, I don't know.
No...
Okay.
Radar is evil.
Okay, hold on, before we go there...
Is there anything up here?
This is where we came from.
Oh!
Wait, so we can either go down...
I guess let's go down.
Wait.
Okay, this one.
Alright.
Don't know where we're going, but...
Okay, maybe...
Change!
Nice.
Okay.
Next.
Change.
Bye bye.
Night visions!
Night visions.
So that's what they're called.
The things... The shadows I see in the corners of my eyes.
Equip to see even in dark areas.
Is that not what we're doing right now?
Alright guys, maybe we'll have better visions now.
Oh my gosh, everything is...
Wow!
It's... Oh my gosh, we're...
It's like... Oh my gosh, why do I keep yelling...
Or laying down?
It's like we're... We're a dog.
We're not a dog anymore, I mean.
We have the night visions.
Oh, well, that doesn't help me here very much now, does it?
Okay, back to thermal.
Okay, great.
Thanks for the night visions.
Oh, I don't want to risk it.
Was there anything over here?
Why back?
Was there a door?
Top right has rations.
And here?
Oh, I have... I have full rations, so...
At least cutscenes won't be in white and red, yeah.
True!
Okay, so now we go upstairs.
Night visions.
We can at least see which way guards are facing now too, which is nice.
It shows that the cameras are still on, but I guess not, actually.
It's a lie.
Okay, now we go upstairs.
Oh.
Where does this go to?
That's a hole.
This is a hole.
And then this leads to...
Another hole!
Which hole?
But we can't get to the third hole.
Go?
Need our codec.
I'm lost!
I'm lost.
Campbell, help me.
Where do I go?
The sorting device is off too.
You should be able to crawl under it.
He's about as useful as he is in Metal Gear Solid.
This guy does no help.
Is
it a keycard?
No, that's not the problem.
The problem is I don't know where to go.
There's two doors with the keycard.
I don't know what to do.
What?
Oh.
Welcome to the darkness, Solid Snake.
Who's there?
We made it to her!
I see you've put your night sights on.
Oh my gosh, she's so cool!
I can see you fine without depending on those toys.
My night vision is as good as an owl's.
She's so cool!
The face of my prey in the darkness, overcome with terror and pain, no machine should contaminate a moment of such exquisite pleasure.
Are you one of this black chamber group?
Of course, I am called Marionette Owl.
My flair for nocturnal combat has no equal even among the black chamber.
The party is about to begin, but you won't be making it.
You'll die here, in the darkness.
Alright.
Let me introduce you to my partners.
Oh, they're like little geishas.
This is Osan.
Cute!
And Kohal.
I have no time for you or your dolls.
A doll is an approximation of the human form.
And a good doll is endowed with a soul.
Kohal?
I wish.
What nice lines your clavicles have, Snake.
Not a bad heft to your femurs either.
When you're dead, Kohal will have those.
It's kind of awesome.
Time to die.
I want to save real quick.
Sorry.
Snake, are you alright?
No.
Snake, come back to us safely.
Ok.
Wait.
Oh my God.
Oh God.
Is thermal better here?
Nope.
Ok.
Nothing.
No item.
No?
Ok.
Just kidding.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, this is horrible.
And having no items does nothing because it's just a flashbang.
Like, it doesn't help.
Oh my God.
Stop, please!
If you use... Oh, if you use thermal, she'll... Ok.
I see, you can't tell who's who.
Oh, that's kind of fun though.
At least I can see.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, ouchie, ouchie.
Oh, and then they get faster?
Am I killing her or... Am I getting lucky?
Oh, ok.
Alright.
Hold on, I want to use an item real quick.
I want to use my...
aggression.
Thermal.
I'll kill... you?
That wasn't very bad.
I
got a whole speech!
That wasn't so bad at all.
Oh, ok, here we go.
Oh my God, she's so beautiful.
Snake, do you know what madness tastes like?
Terrible!
When I was 12, Laura was murdered.
Ooh, Laura.
By some madman.
A psycho.
And I was the one who found her.
Scattered all over the field.
Just for the record, this is canonically a guy.
Oh, really?
Oh, my bad.
Sorry, owl.
Well, you're still... Owl is still beautiful.
Laura's white hands, thighs, dark entrails.
That image was burned into the back of my eyes.
Even now, in my sleep every night.
In that moment, something snapped inside me.
These dramatic pauses are killing me.
Taken over by a strange compulsion.
And soon I found myself called a serial killer, too.
I loved those women.
Why?
We should, you know, like...
For, like, beautiful men, why did we stop using the term Bishounen, you know?
Why did that term get, like, lost in time?
It used to be so, like...
You would hear it all the time in, like...
The mid-2000s and stuff.
A bishi, yeah, everyone would be like, oh my god, Sephiroth, he's such a bishi!
You know?
But, like, Bishounen...
The term has kind of been lost, I feel.
Was it stopped?
I just don't see so many people using it as often as it used to be, I feel like.
I guess Ikemen really took over.
I guess so.
But Ikemen, I feel like Bishounen and Ikemen, to me at least, feel like they have different vibes.
Like, Ikemen is like, I feel, just like a generally attractive dude.
But Bishounen is like a beautiful, you know, it's...
You have the B, the...
The beautiful part of it.
What does madness taste like?
Watermelon.
Ikemen feels more specific.
Actually, I feel like it's different.
I feel like Ikemen is more vague.
Ikemen is more handsome than pretty.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right?
People also use, like, twink.
Oh, that's true too!
But I wouldn't call Raiden, like, Bishounen.
Actually...
Maybe he is a bit of a Bishounen.
But like, you know what?
For some reason, my brain just keeps thinking Sephiroth.
Like him and Sesshoumaru, people were like, oh, they're so Bishounen.
Raiden, absolutely Bishounen.
Depends on which Raiden.
Oh, I'm sorry.
When I think of Raiden, my mind immediately goes to Metal Gear Solid 2.
I don't think of really any other Raiden.
My mind immediately goes to Metal Gear Solid 2 Raiden.
Other Raidens...
They don't feel like Raiden to me.
Not Revengeance?
No.
No, not...
No, I never really think about Revengeance Raiden.
Anyway.
I loved those women.
Oh, yeah.
I really did.
That's why I had to kill them.
There was nothing else to be done.
Can you understand that?
No.
Like hell I can.
I thought not.
But Viper was different.
Viper took me in when I was cornered by the FBI.
I thought it was gonna be much more like when I was cornered by the world.
Outcast.
When I was, you know, cornered.
But no.
The goddamn FBI.
He forgave me my sins.
Black Chamber gave me a way to sate the mad hunger in my mind.
I became the perfect assassin.
Assassin.
Sorry.
But two years ago, you cowards betrayed us.
And laced my madness with lust for revenge.
For vengeance!
There will be no absolution for you.
For what?
American Psycho?
More like American Bishi.
Viper.
He lost his left arm.
In that hell.
But he won't use his prosthetics.
Not usually.
Do you know why?
Okay, now that like this game...
I know that this game...
Cause, okay.
When I was like, initially seeing everything and all the...
I was like, oh the codec sound is from...
Is... what... is...
Like, okay.
Hold on.
Let me back up.
Now that I realize...
Now that I know that this game...
Release date came after Metal Gear Solid.
I don't know how to feel about this, because before I was like...
Before I was just like, wow, Metal Gear Solid took so many things from this game.
Like, that's, you know, so cool.
And now I'm like...
I don't know.
I'm like...
Got a lot of leftover content, yeah.
Yeah, I guess so.
If anyone is the ass-ass in them, it's me.
Yeah, it's you.
I guess this feels like Metal Gear Solid Extra, you know.
But I was like, I was actually feeling so like...
Wow, Metal Gear Solid really took so much from this game.
That's cool.
But now I'm like, oh, it's definitely the opposite.
No.
Because every time he looks at the stump...
Don't call it that.
I can remember.
His last comrades and vow vengeance on Anonymous all over again.
Anonymous?
What?
The stump.
My cat has a nub tail, but I call it a nub.
I feel like nub sounds better than stump.
His madness surpasses even my own.
And that's why I can believe it.
My sight is fading.
No more dreams of that field.
Laura, over here.
I'm...
No.
Please, you can't.
Creepy.
Looks like the gates of heaven are close to you.
Damn.
It's like they were trying to out Metal Gear Solid MGS1, right?
This still took place way before V and I'm hearing a lot of that now.
Yeah.
Snake, hurry.
Metal Gear is in the launch phase.
I ran a satellite check.
Metal Gear is already above ground.
Oh shoot.
Metal Gear is to the north.
Just keep going north.
There's no time left.
Go!
Nice.
Okay, good.
This isn't time, so...
Oh, it's one of these again.
These are kind of fun though.
Punch!
Okay.
What does this one do?
Punch!
Does this reset everything and then this resets everything?
Oh, or no it doesn't.
Okay, hold on.
Punch!
Okay, maybe this one resets everything.
Okay, so punch.
Punch?
No?
Yeah, I guess third down resets it.
Wait, but this one...
Ah, maybe this one again?
No?
What is this?
This one like...
Oh, wait.
Okay, I need the...
Okay, hold on.
What does this one do again?
I can't remember.
And then this one...
Does this shift it?
Uh...
What is this?
The top moves everything up.
Yeah, but I need it to go down.
I need to get these two open so I can do this one.
It like just does the same thing.
Wait, hold on.
What if I do that and this?
Then maybe... What about this?
Um...
No, I can't hit anything while it's moving because I'm like stuck in place.
Move them up until you can use the bottom one.
But it doesn't move them up.
That's why I'm kind of confused.
That's why I'm kind of confused because it doesn't really move them up.
It just goes...
That's why I don't understand it.
And this one for sure resets everything.
That's so annoying.
I don't need a button that resets it.
No way!
He's going to help me!
Oh yay!
Lucky.
OK OK
No way.
They just open?
Oh my god.
No way.
That's so silly!
That's too silly.
What's this?
Mine dete... Oh no.
OK.
I was going to say, there's no one around.
Easy.
Mine detector.
OK, maybe...
How does it detect the mines?
Do they show up on the...
Where do they show up?
The mines that we detect.
I guess we'll figure it out.
Oh, wait.
OK, those are...
Not people.
Those are mines.
OK, good.
Can I go over them?
Like...
I
don't feel like testing.
I can crawl over them?
Yes, you can.
OK.
I'm going to try.
Let's go.
OK, nice.
I'm collecting them.
And I'm going backwards.
I got sick moves.
Keep going north they say.
OK.
It's quiet.
What is this?
Oh god.
Snake, you won't get past this point.
Who are you?
It's finally time to send you all into hell.
This music though.
You must be Viper.
Pleasure to see you, Solid Snake.
I'm going to give him a British accent for no reason in particular.
Retribution begins now.
Stand and watch the show, Snake.
Snake!
Metal Gear!
Oh my god.
It looks like an Eva.
Christ.
This is just the beginning.
It's payback time.
We'll meet again, Solid Snake.
Oh, that's it?
There's no fight?
I don't have to fight the high...
OK, I guess I fight it later.
Oh gosh.
The next time you die.
Oh boy.
What the hell is that?
What are these?
What are those?
Oh my god.
What is... I can't move at all.
Watch out, Snake.
Firing ahead.
There's an artillery unit to the north.
Just this side of the maintenance base.
They're firing like crazy.
Sorry, I bit my tongue so I said crazy.
Get out of there now.
But Metal Gear...
Get out of there, Snake.
There's no way through that barrage.
But...
You keep biting your tongue.
I know, I don't know why I've been biting my tongue so often.
Snake, Metal Gear's already fired a nuke.
We can't afford to lose you as well.
Damn it.
Go back the way you came.
Now isn't the time to go in.
OK.
Look at your radar.
I've modified it to display the artillery impact as a point.
Oh my god.
OK.
Snake, avoid the artillery fire and go south.
Wait, so now I have to avoid the stuff and also...
Oh my gosh.
I rolled
over it and it picked it up.
What happened?
Oh my gosh.
This is...
I don't like this part.
The artillery hit me.
Oh my gosh.
This is insanity.
How did I get so far before?
What the hell?
Oh wait, I got hit by the bomb.
There should be a way without any...
What's it called?
Any landmines, I feel.
Oh my god.
Snake, the warhead launched by Metal Gear just impacted on mainland US.
Oh god.
Casualties?
None.
What?
It was a fake.
The coordinates were set to an unpopulated area.
A nuclear testing site in Nevada.
Oh my god.
What kind of a sick...
Oh, make a bride!
All the same, there's a huge crater at that site.
We need to get a cover story to the press.
Metal Gear's existence cannot be made public.
That appears to be the CIA's forte.
So not a fake.
By fake, it felt like he meant it was a dud.
Like it was a blank.
Be the CIA's forte, after all.
Certainly, but it won't be easy.
Constructing a plausible denial for the masses requires preparations.
I hope nobody was there visiting that site.
Imagine they're like, today we're doing a site... a tour of the nuclear testing site.
Luckily, today is our day off.
So there won't be any nukes today.
And then...
Snake, GILF transmitted a message to the American President just after the impact.
I'm sending it to you as well.
Who is that?
Who is that behind him?
Hello, Mr. President.
Did you like my present?
I'm sure you did.
It is, after all, made in the USA.
No doubt you know the gist of my message.
Withdraw the UN troops from Gindra immediately and recognize our sov... sov... sovereignty.
Sovereignty.
With US backing, the motion will face no delays at the UN Security Council.
You can save face and millions of lives.
Voting lives.
You need the people to vote.
Not a bad deal, I think.
But I'll set a deadline just to save you the procrastinating as well.
3 hours.
OK guys, I have to beat the game in 3 hours.
If our demands are not met within 3 hours, a real nuclear warhead will be launched.
The target will be... New York City!
Or Los Angeles.
OK, make up your mind.
Or perhaps, Washington D.C.
You should start saying GILF is transmitting a message instead of MATARO is going on Discord.
OK, I'll try to remember that for next time.
We'll see how I feel at the time.
I expect glad tidings soon.
OK guys, I hope you don't live in Washington D.C.
or New York City or Los Angeles.
Of course the U.S.
government will make no concessions.
Certainly not!
OK McBride, hold on.
We don't negotiate with terrorists.
But we can't get to Metal Gear.
He may not look it, but Jimmy did head the unit's development.
Sorry, the timing on this is so hard to read.
He may know how to stop the strike.
Get him on the codec.
Chris.
Hold on one second.
How much more do you think I have the game realistically?
I have about 6 chapters left it seems.
Maybe 2 or 4 mini-bosses, yeah.
3 hours, didn't you hear the message?
Please save New York City again.
What?
Snake?
Is Jimmy there?
He is, but...
Put him on.
Oh, OK.
What?
Jimmy, how do we prevent Metal Gear from launching?
Well, like I said before, the rail gun uses a lot of power.
So?
But no power.
The gun is useless.
Yeah.
Snake, you could destroy that power plant.
Yeah, but what about Metal Gear's...
What's happening?
What is it?
What's going on?
Hijack?
Jimmy, Chris, respond!
What's happening over there?
The wizard, he's gone!
I keep wanting to sing The Wizard and I, because it's wicked.
I want to go see the Wicked movie.
I don't know, but I heard gunshots.
Were they attacked?
No, the power plant has to be destroyed first.
OK McBride, this guy has no care for any lives at all.
Mr. McBride!
They're about to strike.
Millions of civilian American lives are at risk.
OK, maybe he does care about...
This is the trolley problem, right?
Do you kill millions of people or do you save the wizard?
Snake, your mission is to destroy Metal Gear.
Don't let your emotions lead you astray.
Every operation has its casualties.
Snake...
What's it going to be?
I'm going for the plant.
Snake!
I think they'll be fine.
But I'm not abandoning Chris and Jimmy.
First, the plant.
Then, I'll find them.
Can you sing Defying Gravity after?
Yeah, hold on, let me drink some water.
Not for Defying Gravity, but hopefully it'll help me wake up.
I don't allow casualties.
Except when it's by my own hands.
Snake...
God, you're soft.
Oh, sorry, this is Weasel.
No, my name is Solid Snake.
It's a wonder you managed to live so long.
Oh my god.
Don't forget.
Preventing the nuclear strike is your first priority.
Soft Snake.
Go, Snake.
Take out the power plant and stop the launch.
Okay.
One second.
Let's see.
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
I was gonna look at the guide.
But I'm feeling like maybe I'll just...
Okay, we have one way.
I'll just explore some and figure it out.
If I get stuck, then I'll use it.
Oh, wait, I thought the power...
Is this the power plant?
Oh, here we go.
Is your head feeling better?
It's not bad.
It's just like there's a pressure.
But it doesn't hurt.
It's just annoying.
Megoromorox, welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Snake, destroy the power plant's main turbine.
It's located in the B1 floor of the plant.
Oh, nice.
They gave us money... or health.
Not money.
I wish they gave us money.
Do our car keys work here?
No.
Sad, sad, sad.
B1, B1, B1.
Okay, there's a few places we can...
The floor is on... It's electric.
Snake, can you hear me?
Chris is alive.
Chris, what happened back there?
Or what happened back there?
They took us by surprise.
What about the wizard?
Is he okay?
Chris?
Jimmy was captured.
Come on!
What?
I saw a chance and ran.
Oh, she abandoned Jimmy.
She...
You had one... Chris, you had literally one job.
Chris...
Just myself again?
Chris, don't blame yourself.
But...
I can't.
Better that you're safe than neither of you.
I'm so useless.
Jimmy can't run.
We don't know that.
I was supposed to have protected him.
Chris, maybe he's just big boned, okay?
I can't blame her.
I wish I were the one taken.
No, what would Jimmy do then by himself?
What's that guy gonna do?
I can't do anything right.
Oh my god, I don't wanna hear your sob story, Chris.
Chris, you were in the power plant.
Weren't you?
What?
Oh, yes.
Tell me how I get in.
Sections of the floor area are electrified and can't be crossed.
But there is a control panel for the floor's electrical grid.
If you take that out, you should have no problems getting through.
As long as you use some weapon with a long range, like the Nikita missiles.
Got it.
Use Nikita missiles to go after the power array.
You've been in the plant once.
I'd like you to give me a backup with what you know.
Sorry, it's so slow.
But I could use your help.
They need to keep Metal Gear in operational state.
So they can't afford to kill Jimmy yet.
I think this mint was made for game.
Yes.
Thanks, Jordan.
I'll get him out before they can.
Snake.
I'm asking you to trust me.
OK.
Anything you need to know about the plant, just ask.
Snake.
Thank you.
Jimmy abandoned, but the Nintendo championships.
Ripperoni.
OK.
I'm guessing the Nikita missile is in here.
Oh, this is an elevator.
Just kidding.
And we can't go through there either, so...
Up we go.
Up, down, down, down we go.
Hold on.
I'm sorry.
I'm going to look in the...
To the basement.
Do you think mint would sound like a teleprompter?
I don't know.
It's so slow.
Probably, actually.
C1.
Teleprompters are faster.
I think someone is controlling a teleprompter.
So that you technically...
Wait.
It told me to come here.
Oh, wait.
Here we go.
So, you technically have someone controlling the speed.
So that you know how fast or slow...
You need to go.
Oh.
I'm here to relieve you.
Hallelujah.
Thought I'd never get to dry off.
This is a hell of a mess.
What happened?
It looks like the drainage duct got choked off somewhere during that squall.
We've got drainage water backing up into...
The plant.
That's why he's relieving himself?
Hey, that doesn't sound too good.
They say there's no problem with generating power itself.
Not exactly impressive in a high-tech installation.
Control led by a state-of-the-art computer system.
Well, as long as the cells get charged...
Everything's doing fine.
It's all yours.
Okay, bye.
What?
Oh, electricity's leaked into some of the puddles.
It looks like regular water.
But make sure you stay away from it.
Oh shoot.
Frosty, welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Wouldn't want you getting hurt.
Or dying.
You know, if you step in a puddle.
Alright, good to know.
Oh my god.
Okay, can't go over there.
Wait, how am I supposed to...
How do I get through?
Crawl?
We'll be blue.
I
don't know where he goes.
Just the puddles touching the electric panels?
I'm not sure.
Oh no, there's another guy!
This part's tricky, huh?
What if I just run for it?
Screw being sneaky.
I'm done with this lifestyle.
Oh my god, oh my god!
I sure hope they didn't hear that!
What?
Sorry.
I think I got away with it.
What are all those guys doing down there?
Oh, are they looking for me?
Oh shoot.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Get up, snake.
Screw being sneaky!
Oh my god.
Wait, is this a place I can crawl?
I'm in the ducts.
I'm in the vents.
I'm venting?
Maybe there's a kid of... in here.
I'm somewhere.
Oh my god, I forgot about the water.
Holy moly.
You think this water's fine?
I say, you think it's normal water, but it's not actually normal water.
It's scary.
I hear him sloshing around.
If I walk, he'll hear me for sure though.
Oh
my god, I gotta get the Nikita first.
Why are you awake?
We're fine.
Everything's OK.
Everything's A-OK.
I think that's it.
Is this electric?
How the hell am I supposed to get the damn missiles if everything is electrified?
What about this one?
Oh gosh.
Now I'm dancing with a guy!
This is so...
ID card 4!
Nice.
Excuse me.
It's right there.
Snake, do you copy?
Ever heard of this?
Wait, didn't we hear this one before?
Don't you think it's about time you talked about...
Yeah, we've heard this one before.
OK, nevermind.
Lame!
They only gave me three lines!
OK.
Oh my gosh.
There's no way to go around.
How the hell am I supposed to...
Oh my god, even this one.
Stupid, stupid.
Oh god.
It's surrounded.
I don't understand.
That was a unique one.
She just used the name of the same guy.
No, it wasn't.
We got that one before.
Where she said, do you think this is a compliment?
And I'm just like, yeah.
And she's like, no, it's not.
You can't crawl through it?
Oh, it's electric.
Why would I be able to...
There, for everybody who says, crawl through the electrified water.
I don't think crawling through electrified water really makes a difference because it's...
You can damage the green box.
You can?
I didn't get one guy.
Multiple people said it.
I was just proving them wrong.
How do I damage it though?
C4.
It'll make everybody angry.
Wait,
what was it again?
B to set.
Yeah, that's electrified water.
Evasion?
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
I cannot stand this game.
Why did this guy go up here?
Why did he go up here?
Why?
It didn't... Guys, it didn't work.
Guys, it didn't work.
Everything is bad.
It didn't work.
Everything sucks.
Guide says go back to the elevator.
After you get the key.
I'll do that.
I'll go back to the elevator.
Ouch,
ouch, ouch.
Wrong way.
Karma.
Oh, I crawled through here.
That's right.
I can't stand this game!
Just kidding.
Yeah, there we go.
Little lizard.
I feel like when I look at him from the front his eyes are bugging.
It looks like I can see his little tongue go...
At any second now, you know?
You know how lizards do that?
That's what I feel like I'm gonna see.
Oh, there's a ration right there.
Good, good, good.
I can't even be mad.
Oh my...
Okay, at least it starts us from...
From the...
Oh my gosh.
From when we got the card key.
I can't...
Love you, Mito.
Good luck.
Thank you.
Where does this guy come from?
Okay, I'm gonna box.
But he can't go in this water.
Oh god.
I can't.
I'm like...
Ration, safety.
Yeah, goodness.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I hate this game.
Oh gosh.
Thank you, Chido-chan.
Thank you.
Wait, does he come down here?
I don't think he does.
I might be mistaken though.
Okay.
We made no mistakes this time.
There's also another hole trap next to the one you fell into?
Oh my gosh, really?
Thank you.
Is there a way to tell?
Hold on, we'll look closely and see.
The floor has the mark, okay.
I can't.
Oh, it's a square.
I see, I see.
Okay, thank you guys.
Let's
eat.
Ration?
Grab other ration.
Perfect.
Alright, nice.
Alright, now we're heading back to the elevator.
That's what the guide told me to do.
Stealth.
Was this one fine?
And then it says...
Press the button.
Go berserker mode.
Alright.
Call to get key card.
Go back to elevator, go to second floor.
Okay.
I don't care anymore.
I tried too damn hard to get that stupid Nikita missile.
Second floor!
What's that?
Electricity?
And there's only... okay.
I hold my breath sometimes during this.
Holy moly.
Wait, are these not...
Are these not on or something?
We just go?
Okay.
Wait, what the hell?
Oh my gosh.
No way.
I have to figure out which way I'm sliding...
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
So close!
No!
Turn sick!
You can turn!
Sister 21!
Oh my gosh.
Avaliss, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Avaliss.
Sorry, I'm trying to figure out this puzzle.
You have to plan your moves, yeah.
I just wanna see what's...
I feel like I have to go here first.
There's no really other way...
Top was the right answer.
Yeah, I have to go this way first.
But...
I wish I could like swap, you know, to a different side at least or something.
Okay, hold on.
Let's go down some.
Ah, here we go!
Okay, I just didn't go down far.
Or, no.
Just kidding.
Stop!
There we go.
Slippery slaughter daddy!
Welcome to Mamba Japan!
Okay, and then this way.
Over, over, over, over, over, over, over, over, over, over, over, over, over.
And either I can continue... Oh, what's over here?
What's in here?
Ah, that's right.
Let me back in!
Is there any... I don't think there's a way to go up right now.
Okay, I think I have to go that way.
Where's my boxer?
There.
Alright, let's see what this guy does.
He walks up here...
And then he turns...
And then...
Goes down there...
And he turns...
And... What is over here anyway?
Oh, a sleepy guy.
Sleepy guy!
Okay, let's try this.
Nice.
Oh no.
Ammunition.
Run!
I almost didn't see him there.
Maybe I can knock him out and then run and go explore before he wakes up.
What is that?
Oh, this is a place to crawl.
Crawl!
Just crawl!
Alright, we're good everybody.
We're following, we're walking around, we're finding places, we're crawling through vents.
And where does it go?
Nice!
Wait, what's this?
No one's in here.
Body armor!
That's huge.
More C4, let's go.
Body armor is huge.
Wait, where do I shimmy?
Wait.
No, I'm in the wrong shimmying position.
No!
Okay, I think I have to crawl all the way back.
And then I have to go past the guard.
Back through the vent.
At least I got the body armor, that's good.
La la la la la la...
At least when the guards fall asleep, from me punching them, they don't wake up and be like...
You know, they don't get angry about it, they just fall asleep.
It's pretty nice actually.
See?
Fell asleep.
Wait, here.
There we go.
Okay.
Lucky, lucky.
Yeah, I think...
Wait, I think we go here.
And then maybe this way.
Nope, just kidding.
There you go, it's downwards.
I don't think so either.
No, that's where I came from.
I'm an idiot.
This way.
We go all the way to the top.
Yes.
Okay.
I don't recall how I got on the floor, must be nothing.
Yeah, exactly.
They're just silly.
I don't really think about how they got there.
They're silly, silly.
Oh my god, we're so close.
Wait a second.
No, this is different.
Wait.
No, this is the same...
Joy!
Oh my gosh, thanks for the 50!
Down you could go left, I could.
Here?
Where?
Right then down left.
Wait, here?
Oh, I see.
Oh, I missed that.
I missed the left over there.
Okay, thank you, thank you guys.
I see it, I see it.
I missed it.
Right here.
I see it, I see it.
Yeah, thank you, thank you.
Nice!
Good eyes.
Oh my gosh, it kind of looks like his butt is like twerking against the...
Whoa, spreading those cheeks.
Go snake, go!
Okay, and then we...
This way.
Up.
This is it.
This is the run!
Yeah!
We made it!
It's not the Nikita missile?
Wait, you don't think I needed to chaff there?
Wait, did I just only need to chaff at that one spot?
And it would disarm the electricity?
Oh, I had chaffs this entire time!
No!
This can't be right.
I'm drunk.
Don't super chat and drunk!
I mean drink!
Thank you, Joy!
Carry on to the northwest is what... Wait, northwest.
Northwest, here?
Here?
This is east, this is not northwest.
How do I get to that little area?
This doesn't count as an open area, does it?
No?
You can go down again.
But the guide says grab the chaff grenades, carry on, and open the door to the northwest.
Is the guide wrong?
Take the Nikita.
Wait, what?
Left of those two crates here?
Isn't this where I came in from?
Wait, northwest.
Now this should be it.
Okay, here we go.
Goodness gracious.
Wait, wait.
Actually, I'm just going to equip the body armor.
What is this person doing, anyway?
They're wandering.
They're taking a little walk, a little stroll.
What's this?
Oh, come on.
Here?
Where is it?
Where?
Is it in this corner?
Oh my goodness.
Nikita, B to fire, control with D-pad.
Okay.
Oh, that was close.
I don't think anybody will come.
Nice.
This
is part of the mission!
Oh, I'm so dead.
Evade and disappear.
Go away.
I hate you.
Please, please don't do this to me.
Yeah.
Fuck you.
Ouch.
Oh my god, let me through!
Dumb every time.
Okay.
We can leave this floor.
Holy cannoli.
Who needs stealth anyway?
Exactly.
So I guess we go to the first floor.
And we...
I gotta go get some more water soon.
Is this a wall?
Wait, how many missiles do I have left?
I accidentally wasted one.
I have five.
Maybe I shoot down this way instead.
Okay, I think I should...
What?
I wasn't even...
Shut up.
Shut up, game.
Okay, here we go.
What do I do?
It went rogue, you guys!
I couldn't do anything!
It went rogue!
Okay.
Gosh.
Go!
Oh my god.
I can't...
I
can't win this game!
You don't think there's gonna be more guys down here, right?
Okay.
Might as well just go with it.
The shy missile.
Okay, you think they're gone?
You think the people are gone?
I honestly can't tell at all.
I can't even shimmy under it!
No, do I just... Oh, chaff.
Yeah, it's chaff.
Thank you, I forgot that I picked those up.
Are they under this?
No.
They're under this.
It's done.
And I just...
I throw with the beat.
I miss not having the...
The things go crazy, you know?
It's fine when they go so crazy.
No?
Still boo-boo?
Okay.
Oh my god!
Oh, he's down there.
Okay.
I got mistaken.
It's weird because it doesn't show this hole in the wall, you know?
The luckiest person...
In the world!
Oh my god, stop!
How am I the luckiest person in the world?
Oh my god!
Did I go through?
This is where I'm supposed to go though, right?
Gosh.
Oh my god!
Literally pixel perfect.
I wasted all my luck for the year with that one single...
With that one single...
Moment.
I hope this is the way because it's really long.
Nikita ammo.
And...
There's no reason to make it this long.
There's no reason.
It's just...
So...unnecessary.
Destroy the control panel.
Wait, there was one?
Oh, there was a panel.
Oh my god.
Thank you guys.
Wait, where?
Where?
And
then it's gonna go...
Can I only Nikita these?
Where?
Okay.
Weird.
Alright, well I did it.
Only Nikitas are so precise.
It can't be any explosion.
It has to be THE explosion.
The one explosion.
Okay, well I guess I'm glad that there was a purpose to this madness.
And now I know we came from the right, but can we go up?
Let's go to the left.
And down.
This part is really long, huh?
I thought the box level was long, but...
Oh, I'm here again!
Wait, unless...hold on.
Wait, let me see.
No, nevermind.
Sorry, I made a mistake.
This is a different place.
I saw the...
I saw the ration and I got confused.
Okay.
Card.
Still no?
Okay.
5.7 ammo.
Oh, there's another control panel.
Just run for it.
Wonder if we can get this one too.
Yeah, maybe.
Okay.
It was right over there, right?
It was right over there, right there, right there, right...
There.
There's gonna be a lot of cars that run.
Why?
Why is that a mechanic?
They're like, what if we made the parts with the electric floor even more difficult?
What if you shot any gun in the...
In the game, it sounds an alarm.
Will it get shot down if I go straight?
Maybe I have to, like, go through a maze.
They're like, it's too easy if you just...
I'm gonna... Oh, okay, I have more missiles.
Chaff and Nikita?
You guys are so smart!
Chaff?
Why?
I can't chaff and... Okay, well, uh...
I guess I can't do that.
I think I have to make it so that they're not active.
It was a good idea.
It was a very good idea.
But I guess it makes sense that, like, the Nikita is controlled by...
Gosh, I wish I could... Okay, hold on.
Alright, I have to go down that way, but...
How will I avoid the ones on the...
Maybe the ones on the left aren't gun cameras, you know?
Actually, they were.
Because I saw one at the very bottom.
From the left room is easier for me?
Over there?
How do you get it from there?
I shall see.
I'm gonna go in a circle.
Like, behind the...
Across the pit there's no wall.
Oh my god, are you kidding me?
That's untrue.
You know what, this is fine, because I wasted a lot of ammo.
And we get more.
Okay, this is fine, actually.
The strat was to get the... Oh, that's right.
Was to get more.
Okay.
Wait.
But how do I get back...
Ah, they didn't shoot it, though.
Okay.
The dapper sapper, welcome to membership!
I have to... I think I have to wait for them to calm down, though.
Maybe it's fine.
Yeah, they're fine now.
Because I think they shoot from... They have, like, a higher... I don't know.
Maybe... Maybe it just...
Oh, that's right.
This has been a sanity draining past few days for me, so...
I need a break next week.
But Batara is coming over!
I can't catch a break.
And I'm even... I'm doing it to myself.
Oh, that's right.
Do I have to go under it?
What?
Cameras can shoot missiles while they're going slow, but not when they're going fast.
I know, that's why it's so tricky in that part.
Okay, I'm gonna have to, like...
Okay.
I'm gonna have to angle it in the most...
How do I get it to go fast there?
To speed up... There's... But I have to turn there.
Maybe I have to be all the way...
Okay, I think I see where.
Okay, hold on.
Fast!
No, I was going fast!
That's so unfair!
I don't think I hit the desk.
I hit the wall, actually.
Maybe I was just, like, pixel perfect hitting it.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Why does it have to be... This is... I don't feel like...
I don't feel like they would make it that it has to be pixel perfect to get through.
I feel like I'm missing something.
I'm doing something wrong.
Like, I actually...
Like, I'm sitting here, like, crafting...
Shit.
Oh, my God.
If I'm over to the right or to the left anymore, I'm gonna hit the first wall.
Okay, I have two shots left before I kill myself.
In Metal Gear.
There is another route?
There is?
I don't think there is.
Okay, on the...
Maybe, like...
Sayonara, cruel world!
The guide I'm looking at uses this route.
I don't... Yeah, the other route shoots you down.
This one... This one seems to be the only one that works.
It's just so... I don't understand what I'm doing wrong.
Turn after passing the first security system.
Turn?
Wait.
See, like...
I'm trying to get it along the line that you see right next to the desk.
But it hits the desk.
And if I turn in front of the...
In front of the thing...
Unless I get past the first camera and immediately...
Okay, I'll get past the first camera and turn immediately.
Go to the right?
I don't think that's a route.
Oh
my gosh!
Yippee!
I just need my...
My mic.
Oh my gosh.
Yay!
First try in the...
In the new life.
Goodness.
Thank goodness.
Huh.
Why sometimes it would shoot it down and other times it doesn't?
It's a mystery.
To me, it's a mystery.
Sick spin, Snake.
Okay.
Now, chaff.
Oh, there we go.
I don't know what I'm doing in here.
I don't know what my goal is.
But...
I'm in here.
Oh, maybe this?
C4?
I already had that.
And what's this?
R5 ammunition?
I guess I need that.
Oh, there's a door here.
Back to the game.
Save?
Good idea.
I'm gonna save and I'm also gonna get some water.
Ouch.
Need anything?
Yeah, I need sanity.
Ever heard of this?
Dr. Coplethorne says...
Okay, I'll go through it, but...
Oh, Mei Ling, you're...
Never mind me.
Tell me about yourself.
Oh, why'd she flip the script on us?
Me?
Like, why you're back in combat?
I've heard that you've given up the military.
Did the colonel tell you that?
Uh-huh.
And other things too.
Like what?
Like the bandana...
Wait, the bandana underwear?
Bandana underwear?
Let me see!
And barbecued bugs?
And...
That stuff too?
Oh God!
That blabber mouth.
Bandana underwear!
Why has no one ever told me this before?
So, why did you come back?
I had something to finish.
And decided to stop running away.
That's all.
And after that?
After?
When it's finished?
What are you going to do?
This makes me so sad.
I think about 4.
And it makes me so sad.
SMH can't believe Madi never drew that.
And she played Ghost Babble!
I haven't thought about it.
As long as the score is settled.
That's all I care about.
Sad.
Oh, the other side is another camera.
Thank goodness, I thought it was a person.
Bandana underwear was your reward for going through Nikita hell.
I feel so rewarded.
Thank you all.
What is this supposed to mean?
Good thing the cameras suck.
It says C4?
I don't think that is literal, right?
Where is it?
There it is.
Okay, nice.
I feel like I've made all progress and no progress.
Oh, the fury.
A flamethrower.
Okay, number 3 buddy.
Oh my god.
Wow, that is just Vulcan Raven.
This is your... sorry.
This is our last day in your shadow.
Shadow?
Yes, but you wouldn't know, would you?
How much blood was shed to purchase your glory?
Snake, you're no legend.
You're a sinner.
Oh my god.
I think Snake knows that.
Snake denies the legend allegations.
He's like, I'm no legend.
And you will make your reparations now.
The price for your sins is your life.
Every human being burns differently.
Did you know that?
The way the skin scorches.
Okay, when he does his death speech, I'm not keeping this up.
I'm just letting you guys know now.
The way the skin scorches, the fat burns, the innards char.
Changes from person to person.
And you see there the burdens of their sin.
He's still going.
Save it for when you're on your deathbed please.
I wonder how you'll burn.
I'll know soon enough.
Yeehaw!
Oh, burn!
Alright.
Maybe a machine gun and body armor.
Wait, I shot you, but... I should probably...
Oh my god, the music is so messy.
I'm gonna use this just in case.
And body armor, there we go.
So I just gotta stay away from him.
It's not so bad, I think.
And I... Oh, ouchie ouchie.
And then I bait him, and I'm on fire.
And then I shoot him, and I miss.
And I shoot him, and I miss.
Or did I get him?
Did I get him?
I think?
Did I hit him?
Is he... Is he burning up my...
Is he burning up my bullets?
Ouch.
Oh, he's... How did I take damage?
How did he take damage the first time?
What?
I'm so confused.
Maybe only behind him.
I don't think so.
Oh, he takes damage sometimes.
I don't... I don't understand.
Huh?
Oh, it's recommending grenades.
Ouchie ouch.
Oh my god.
I think when I shot him from behind, he was facing the other, you know, like...
Oh.
Oh, got him, got him, got him.
You know?
I'm gonna switch to grenades.
Let's try that instead.
Damage!
Oh, just kidding.
Ration!
There we go.
Grenades do good.
Where'd he go?
Oh.
Yikes.
Oh, now he's running.
Oh, I thought I still got him though.
Got me.
Thank goodness for body armor, huh?
Oh my god, he's running.
He is running, guys.
He's running man.
Running man.
Maybe like one, two more?
Come here!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
One more, one more, one more, one more.
Oh, shoot.
Ouch, ouch.
Oh my goodness.
OK, fine.
Got him.
Terrible!
You cleared the stage, but you were the worst.
Ars, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
OK, here it comes.
Snake.
I know that I'm a sinner without you having to tell me.
But why, Shadow?
Alright.
Oh my god, his voice went up so much.
You'll learn what your sins really are.
I didn't actually realize... I didn't see how long it took me last...
Last stage.
It was a long time.
Hold on.
You guys listen to this killer song and I'm gonna go get some water.
It's kind of creepy, actually.
Last stage... This is 48 minutes?
Oh my god.
Here, I'm gonna go get some water real quick.
Sorry.
I got pizza!
Awesome!
Pizza!
Yay!
Leftover pizza from yesterday.
I was gonna heat it up and then I was like...
I said I was only gonna get water.
I'm taking too long.
What kind of pizza?
Just cheese.
Nothing special.
The black chamber...
Was born in the shadow of Foxhound.
Yeah, I have no...
No poop.
Seven years ago...
You destroyed Metal Gear here...
In Outer Heaven.
And put Foxhound in the headlines.
Everyone in the world knew the name...
Solid Snake.
Which seems kind of insane to me.
That, like, they didn't keep it under super wraps, you know?
But, you know, you have Nastasha just publishing a whole book about...
About Shadow Moses, so...
I guess it's whatever.
I think they tried.
Famous espionage agent should be an oxymoron.
I know, right?
Like...
It's a little bizarre.
That's what I leaked at first.
That guy.
It's bedtime, Oyasumi.
Oyasumi, thanks for staying around for so long.
And so you became the legend.
But Foxhound got too famous.
Since Outer Heaven.
It's every move was watched by intelligence organizations.
Everywhere.
Truly covert operations became impossible.
So Black Chamber was created.
We took over every covert ops that had.
Been Foxhounds...
Foxhounds.
Assassination of anti-American foreign leaders.
Removal of domestic civilians.
Engaged in anti-establishment activities.
These are big words.
Intervention in strife and civil wars that affect American interests.
Skywriter.
Thank you for the two months.
Doing the dirty work in the dark.
On and on in the shadow of the great legend.
I mean, then don't...
I don't know what to tell you, man.
You joined the organization, right?
Like, how did you get in?
If they asked you to join, just say no.
What do you want me to...
And you are going to blame him for your shortcomings?
Okay.
I never wanted to be called a legend.
Liar.
Ask yourself why you volunteered for difficult missions.
Why you are here right now.
Is that real?
You've killed 17 people here already.
Is that...
My actual death count?
Okay, but 17 in 7 hours?
Ain't so bad.
Oh my god, it's already been 7 hours of streaming.
You guys.
I'm going to take it easy a little bit next week on the...
Of course you want to be a legend.
Deep inside, you want the glory.
And you keep killing for it.
Because it's the only thing you're good at.
Everybody always tells him what he already thinks.
It's so sad.
I've got more good news for you.
My pathetic friend.
There's one of us among your trusted rank.
Ah, we knew it.
Thank you, Minto.
For what?
What did I do?
What?
Didn't you think it was strange?
That we knew about you coming?
That we were waiting for you every step of the way?
But...
When you were talking to each other...
You were talking to us.
So who is it?
I still think it's McBride.
It's McBride all the way.
But that's not possible.
We literally tickled this idea earlier, Snake.
Is that M.
Bison from Street Fighter?
Yes, Snake.
Suspect.
Suspect everything.
Everyone.
And die without knowing.
That sucks.
Your doubts and suffering.
Your hatred.
That would turn Snake into a ghost actually.
Probably.
Because he would die with unfinished business.
And then...
And I'm a ghost, you know?
Best tribute to my fallen comrades.
Two years since the trap closed.
Only five of us left.
The rest of Black Chamber dead at traitor's hands.
Five?
Oh, the one guy that's in our party?
This is planned payback.
To Foxtown.
To you.
And to Anonymous.
What the hell?
Did they watch that Guy Fawkes movie?
What's it called?
V for Vendetta?
Guilf are just pawns in our greatest game.
Viper will take care of the rest.
I can die in peace.
But I don't need your help.
I'm not going to help you die.
Do it on your own.
Fire.
Gentle fire.
It cleanses all things alike.
It is the great equalizer.
I've never seen that movie before.
The V for Vendetta.
But isn't it basically that?
It's pretty good.
Read the graphic.
Oh, there's a graphic novel.
It's pretty good.
You'll be fine never seeing it.
I like watching movies.
Of both the sinful and the innocent.
That's where I'll die.
On fire?
In the heart of the fire.
I thought he was going to say the heart of the flame.
Oh my god!
He was talking so much.
I feel like if I just left him he would've been fine.
But he chose this.
The heat.
This is what I've been looking for.
I'm burning!
Oh god, yes!
Oh yes!
The fire!
Yes!
That was weird.
I heard Snake.
Don't let the enemy get to you.
There is no way a spy could be among us.
I
was supposed to say the brain rot.
You're not supposed to speak it aloud.
Wanna bet?
I think it's McBurger, whatever his name is.
What did you say?
There are too many weird things about...
this mission.
Including this committee.
Oh McBride.
What the hell are you saying?
McBurger.
Take you for example.
Why is the CIA putting into an army operation?
And you're a little too full of advice, eh?
Weasel, stop this.
You too, Campbell.
Aren't you retired?
What the hell are you doing here?
That's because...
And you know something about Black Chamber.
That you are not telling us.
Uh-oh.
I need scissor 61.
Doesn't...
In the...
When Colonel goes crazy in MGS2, doesn't he...
He talks about Gallowade.
He's like, infiltrate the fortress Gallowade.
Yeah, that's why I recognize the name.
That's so fun.
Am I right?
Cat got your tongue.
He does, yeah.
Right to remain silent.
Weasel Loki sounds like my friend.
Stop it.
Hey, sweetheart.
You're no exception.
Hey, you can...
You can not trust anybody in this entire operation.
Don't touch her, Weasel.
I don't care what kind of hot shot techie you are.
A grad student on a classified mission?
That's weird.
You...
You, Weasel.
What do you mean?
I don't care if Mei Ling is betraying us, honestly.
But she wouldn't ever do that anyway.
You think I don't know?
Five years ago in that war...
Your own brother and...
What's it to you?
I'm just saying that you can't be trusted.
Brother?
Good.
It's no compliment to have your trust.
Weasel is such a little...
Oh, he's such a weasel.
It's a perfect name for him.
Enough of this.
There is no spy.
Okay, when you...
Campbell, the fact that you're not even like...
Entertaining the idea makes you way more subtle.
This is an enemy tactic to confuse and divide us.
Snake, just think about preventing that...
Nuclear strike.
Take out the power plant.
Snake, you have to trust me.
Don't say that.
I'd like to.
When heavens divide.
Who's calling?
Chris?
Campbell.
Destroy the plant's main turbine.
It should be on the floor B1.
Hurry.
Feels so good, baby.
Feels good to be good.
I want to get out of the power plant so bad.
Okay, I remember someone saying that I would need a guide for the power plant.
And I...
I understand why you would say that.
How many more missions do I have?
Let's see.
One, two, three, four?
Four more?
Five?
I can't tell.
Alright.
Call the elevator, go to the basement, go to the air duct to skip the poisonous room.
Thanks, guide.
Thank you, guide, for telling me about the poisonous room that I would have...
would have gone into otherwise.
A bunch of them are fights.
Okay.
This is honestly...
so much for a Game Boy game.
This is...
so much...
for a Game Boy game.
Like, holy...
What?
It's insane.
Like, sure, these levels get a little...
like, you know, annoying.
The bosses haven't been so bad so far.
Wait, let me make sure I'm in the right spot.
Kill the guard and go east.
Did I go the right one?
Did I go in the right air duct exit?
What guard is there?
Why do you think...
Why is the guide telling me to kill?
Huh?
You want more death...
more murders under my belt?
What's in here?
Oh, this is... okay.
Snake.
How is it going?
I just got here.
Chill.
The perimeter of the main turbine is...
secured with electrified flooring.
It didn't need to go this hard.
Kojumbo did it again.
I don't think Kojima actually had anything to do with this game though.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
I can't get close to it.
Damn.
We have no choice but to take out...
the plant itself.
What about the Nikita missiles I just acquired?
What about the missiles?
The missiles that I can control.
The missiles that I've been using to cross...
the electrified flooring this entire time.
Snake.
Take the power plant out.
Set C4 explosives on four key points...
to destroy the structure.
You should see four columns clustered around...
the main turbine.
There are a total of four points on the columns...
where the corners are missing.
How do you know this?
This is like...
This is the most sus thing you've said this far.
I... What?
They are the weak point in the plant's structural integrity.
If you blow up all of them with C4 explosives...
the plant should be destroyed.
I love if it's actually Colonel that's the bad guy.
Like the... What's it called?
The spy among us.
And...
You know, some kid played this and then played too and was like...
Hey, wait a second.
Why'd they do the same twist twice?
That would be messed up.
I would actually probably be kind of angry about that.
Fool me once, shame on me.
Fool me twice, shame on you.
Don't waste any C4 on innocent locations.
There are only so many that can be set.
Alright.
So four.
There are a total of four points on the columns around the main turbine.
Where the corners are missing.
Plant a C4 on every single one.
Okay.
Columns around the turbine.
Is this...
Is this C4?
Good, nice.
How do I get around it though?
Thanks for the info, dumb Colonel.
Is this a...
I'm
kind of confused by this, but give me a second.
Is this a...
One of them?
Like one of the...
This just looks like storage, it doesn't look like a column.
And then something where the corner is missing.
Huh?
Okay, hold on, let me go to the other side.
This way.
They look distinct.
They change location every playthrough.
What?
Probably be really obvious, okay.
Let's go check out the other side.
If the story is alright, I can imagine people wanting to defend it despite not being a full Kojima thing.
Yeah, I know, the story is great.
Oh, nevermind.
Wait, what?
Where the hell am I supposed to go?
Okay.
They change location, speedrunners might say this, right?
They're probably so like...
No!
And then I can't leave, so I'm just like...
What?
I have no idea what I'm supposed to be looking for.
Colonel, give me...
Give me a sign!
Is that a pillar?
Alright,
go back to the elevator.
Go back to the elevator.
Okay, this guide is saying where...
Wait, this guide is saying...
Go back to the room where you fought Pyro Bison.
But if you guys are saying it's random, then...
It won't let you plant C4 in incorrect places.
Oh, okay, that's kinda nice.
Okay, um...
One of yours was in Pyro Bison's room.
Oh, you saw it already!
I kept note of yours.
Oh my gosh, blue!
You're so smart!
Thank you!
Alright, what floor...
That was just one floor up, right?
Okay.
Oh wait, no, it was right here.
No, it was not.
Okay, at least if I can go and see what it looks like...
I'll know where to find...
Or how to locate the other ones.
Here.
Okay, a pillar, a pillar, a pillar.
A pillar, a pillar, a pillar.
A pillar?
Like this?
Or...
The right side?
This?
C4?
That's one!
How am I supposed to find these?
What?
So it looks...
It's like that, but...
What?
Okay, so I just have to...
Run around and...
Guess?
Spend hours of battery life finding them.
No way!
Another one was in that isolated panel area...
When he tried using C4 instead of Nikita.
Access by the vent.
I think I know what you're talking about.
Wait.
This area I tried to use...
C4 instead of Nikita.
The one that I had to shoot the Nikita outside?
I can't get through here?
How did I get...
How did I get down here before?
A place full of puddles.
Oh!
Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
That was in the basement.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, yes, yes, yes.
I know where that is.
Okay.
So funny, I tried using C4 in that room...
Only to...
Only to have to actually use C4 in that room!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for keeping note of these.
Honestly, I...
Oh, whoa!
I never would have...
Thought about it.
That's not one.
I'm just looking around to see if I notice any others while I'm...
Here's the vent.
Wait, maybe I need to go down one more.
Do I need to go down one more?
Yeah.
Wait.
Is this just gonna take me to the turbine?
One second.
I think there's a B2.
It's B2.
B2.
Never mind!
What?
I'm confused.
I hate having to go through these long ass...
If only the vents weren't so slow.
I guess you take the vent if you want the slow, long, but safe way.
And then you go through the poison room if you're like...
I don't care.
I don't care!
Okay.
Was there a way...
Hold on.
I'm so lost in this place.
Oh, see!
What?
How do I get there?
Oh my god, I'm so lost!
I bet speedrunners know to...
Oh my god.
I'm an idiot.
Gas mask?
I hate, I hate, I hate my afterlife.
I hate my afterlife!
I'm lost and I...
It was B1 though, wasn't it?
What?
Because that's where you said to go.
There's only two floors!
Is there like another elevator somewhere?
What?
How am I...
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm...
I can't even go through here, but it's because I don't have an equipment.
And then...
This one?
I don't know anything anymore.
I hate this part.
In there?
There wasn't anyone in here though, right?
I'm just checking to make sure before I leave.
No.
I go to the vent.
I'm trapped in the vent.
Okay.
This place is so maze.
Go down or to the right?
I don't know.
Oh.
Do I go down?
I'm just gonna...
Wait.
Oh my god.
This is actually just the most...
nonsensical part of the game, so it just becomes so frustrating.
Down and left.
Wait.
Down this one?
Down and then I go left when I leave?
Okay.
I'm back.
I was ghost babbling.
Welcome back!
It was fine until...
this moment.
Oh my god, his butt looks like a creeper face.
It was really fine until...
just this moment.
This is very tedious and...
I'd rather go back to the box.
Like, why doesn't the guide have a map for this area?
Like, I just need a map for this hole.
And having to go through vents for certain parts does not help.
It says the ghost creeping on his butt.
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
Oh, okay.
Press...
It's B to set.
Okay!
Alright!
I got that!
Are you able to set these before you...
No?
Before you have the codec call with Colonel?
That's messed up.
Okay, Blue!
Tell me where!
Sorry, I'm really depending on you here.
I...
One is in that large puddle area where the guards first talked about electric puddles.
Yeah, I just don't know how to get there.
I thought the elevator would take me there.
But I guess there's different elevators, which also doesn't make everything horrible and confusing at all.
You know?
Of course not!
Doesn't make it so much more difficult to figure out what's going on.
How to get anywhere.
There's a visual aid on game facts.
There is?
Go to basement one.
Yeah, that's where I tried to go before.
Okay, this is the elevator.
That I was thinking I was at.
But I wasn't actually at.
Okay.
This is the elevator.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, this is where I was like, why am I at B1?
Why isn't it working?
Oh my gosh.
To
the puddles!
Alright, now I search around.
We got blue on codec.
Blue, thank you so much.
Seriously.
Especially, you even had the idea to write it down.
Like, thank you so much.
You're saving me a crazy amount.
Forget what this guy does here.
I wanna be a box.
Did you see it?
Wait, I missed it.
No, I didn't see it at all.
Is it next to where this guy is standing?
Yup.
I do have the C4 on, right?
Okay, yeah.
I have to go now.
On C4.
Okay, and run.
Okay.
We got that one!
Okay!
Last one!
Last one is by the elevator here.
No way.
I looked around, I didn't see it.
Elevator?
Elevator.
How did you see that?
Oh my gosh!
We did it!
Once you get to the elevator, go left.
Yeah, thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Colonel, all the C4 is set.
Good work, but if you detonate them now, your own life will be at risk.
Leave your present location and detonate the C4 once you are out of the plant.
How do I get out of the plant?
Love the voice acting, thanks.
Snake, we've got problems.
Metal Gear is out on the surface again.
They're planning to go nuclear right now.
Wait, has it been three hours?
Oh gosh.
There's no time left.
Snake.
I know.
Light the fuse.
Now.
Wait.
What?
What if you do that?
Don't worry.
Bombs have a way of making me run faster.
Sorry, Snake.
Shut up.
Shut up, you knew this.
I can't with this guy.
Ordering you to take a risk like this.
Forget about it.
I'm used to it.
I like how, because of the way I guess our bomb was...
We immediately put down the C4 and then they immediately tell us...
Nevermind, we have to blow it up with you in there.
Snake.
Once the C4 blows, the whole structure will begin collapsing.
When the countdown displayed on the radar goes zero...
The plant will cease to exist.
You must reach the exit before then.
Okay.
Oh no!
I wish I could see.
Wait!
Oh my god.
That was close.
Hello?
Wait.
Is this...
I didn't mean to do that.
Okay, hold on.
I need to get rid of this.
Oops.
I think I messed up.
I'm still trying to burn it down faster.
Real.
How do I get out?
I'll take that.
Cool.
Where is the exit?
Game?
Maybe down here.
Oh yeah, because I shimmied through.
That's right.
I shimmied through.
I remember now.
I had to shimmy.
And then there was this door right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember, I remember.
Oh no!
The shimmy shimmy.
The shimmy shimmy shimmy.
Shimmy mimmy mimmy.
The shimmy mimmy mimmy.
Terrible!
Yeah, that level really was terrible now, wasn't it?
Colonel, I've neutralized the plan.
Good work, Snake.
They should be incapable of a nuclear strike... now.
Did someone say nuclear strike now?
You need to destroy Metal Gear next.
Four F-22s have just taken off from one of our African allies' base to strike the artillery units with cruise missiles.
Oh, nuclear strike now!
Snake, as soon as the artillery is silenced, infiltrate the base and destroy Metal Gear.
Understood.
Snake.
What about Jimmy?
Oh, wow.
Forgot about that guy.
No lead so far.
I have not thought about Jimmy in probably like two hours, Mei Ling.
But I will get him.
Yeah, when I get my hands on Jimmy.
I know.
Wait, Snake.
What is it?
A message just came in from GILF.
From the General.
I'll forward it to you.
Cool, I can eat my pizza.
I have two slices.
Mr. President.
Why are you locked in this door?
Thank you for the best introduction.
Thank you so much.
You may be rejoicing over the destruction of the power plant by your faithful dog.
But I assure you that you celebrate in vain.
The warhead can be launched without the railgun.
I am very disappointed by the insincerity of your methods.
Oh, shoot.
I could opt for immediate reprisal, but I pride myself on being a gentle man.
I shall abide by my original decision.
I say it once more.
Withdraw the peacekeepers and recognize our independence.
If I do not hear from you within one hour, the U.S.
will find itself under nuclear attack.
I mean, all they're asking is like...
Notice me, senpai.
It's literally...
Would you risk it all for foolish pride?
Don't underestimate my resolve.
They want freedom and the U.S.
is just like...
We'd rather like...
Risk it.
A nuclear strike without the railgun.
How?
Metal Gear's development was a classified army project.
Even the CIA is not aware of all the details.
Okay, so you...
Thanks for that, McBurger.
You literally...
He was like, I don't know.
I wasn't asking you.
Thanks for your input.
In other words, you know Jack.
Like, the weasel gets it.
Snake, head for the maintenance base.
The only option now is to destroy Metal Gear itself.
Looks like it.
Alright, he knows...
Jimbo!
Jimmy!
Oh my god, he killed a man.
Snake?
Oh my god, Jimmy!
Snake, wait...
Isn't the power plant destroyed?
And we are standing right next to it.
Jimmy!
Were you safe?
You were safe?
Yeah, I got captured.
But this guy was in the same cell.
He got us out.
When the guards left after the explosion.
Same cell.
Who could this be?
But, but...
He took a bullet, shielding me.
And...
Who was he?
Lieutenant Smith of Delta Force.
Delta Force?
I thought Chris was the sole survivor.
Is Jimmy evil?
I don't trust this guy.
Me neither.
She wasn't.
What do you mean?
I don't know.
But the lieutenant said...
Chris wasn't even there when Black Chamber wiped out Delta Force.
Is Chris the spy?
Gosh, I never consider the women.
No, Snake.
Chris!
Anyway, that's what he said.
Maybe she is one of...
Don't be ridiculous.
Oh my god.
No.
I can't stand this anymore.
Is Metal Gear Minto?
It's always the women.
No.
Only one woman has betrayed us in Metal Gear.
Only one.
Oh, two.
Sorry.
Sorry, I was thinking of Eva and Naomi.
Or Eva at first.
Oh wait, and Pies.
Sorry, I never think of my favorites.
Eva, Naomi, Pies.
But that's Rose.
No, Rose was just stupid.
Rose doesn't actually betray you.
Oh, the boss?
Okay, you guys make a valid point.
I never think of the women.
No.
Naomi saved everyone though.
Yeah, by killing herself.
Thank god.
I'm sorry.
I'm just kidding.
I thought she was like nice.
No women, just the box.
You can't trust anyone or anything here.
You don't know what to believe anymore.
Metal Gear was a mistake too.
Everyone else I worked on that thing with was murdered.
We were all okay yesterday and just now...
This happened in 24 hours, that's insane.
I saw their dead.
How could that...
I want to go home and start over.
Oh, Jimmy, Jimmy, Jimmy.
This time, make something good to make up for what I've done.
It's still okay, isn't it?
I can still start over, can't I?
Yeah, as long as you got the will, you can always start over.
It's never too late.
That's true.
Go live, Jimmy.
Live your little life.
I love how much of a blueberry snake looks like.
Listen, I destroyed the power plant.
Can they still launch a warhead?
Yeah, that made the railgun useless.
Naomi didn't betray Snake.
She actually betrayed the government to save Snake by altering Foxdie.
She betrayed Otacon, which is, in turn, a betrayal of Snake.
But also, she did betray Snake by giving him the Foxdie.
You can't tell me that Naomi did not do...
You can't try to make Naomi out to be the hero here.
She caused the mess.
I would hope that she fixes it.
It's all her fault to begin with.
Naomi apologizes.
I know, right?
On my channel?
I can't believe this.
Naomi has to have the last word...
What's her name?
Naomi...
Hunter.
Oh my god.
How could I forget Hunter?
Jaeger.
Naomi's stupid, stinky... hate her.
But I love to hate her.
It's so good hating her.
It feels good.
Oh no, I summoned the Hunter means Jaeger.
Metal Gear can...
The handcuffs exploded.
Oh my god!
Snake!
God!
Why?
I thought I could start over.
Is it all over?
Oh my god!
Jimmy.
Snake.
I wanna go home.
You're going home, buddy.
Jimmy, you're going home.
They can't make me sympathize with you, Jimmy.
Vipers work, most likely.
Booby.
Booby traps and explosives are his specialty.
Probably had a mic in the cuffs too.
Was listening in.
Mint certified Naomi hater.
Yes, I am.
And I wear that title with pride.
Everybody hates on Rose, but not enough people hate on Naomi.
I like Rose.
So funny.
He deliberately blew the thing in front of Snake.
Oh, in front of... question mark?
It wasn't her decision to use Fox Die and we don't talk about... What do you mean we don't talk about MGS4?
What?
Brandon, you're drunk.
Stop drunk super chatting at me.
We don't talk about the game that made Naomi into the worst actual character in the entire series.
That's just...
No way.
Stop.
You're just trying to get a ruse out of me.
You're just trying to get a...
No, this is bait.
I'm getting baited hard.
You guys know how to bait me and I fall for it every time.
I'm just a little fishy and I see just a little worm dangling from a hook and I go...
I do it every time, but if it's about Naomi...
Naomi is fine if you ignore canon.
If you ignore her entire personality and entire plot line, Naomi is great.
This is your sign to play MGS5 as game never stops.
She is fine though.
Are we saying like fine as in like yeah she's fine or are we saying like she's fine?
I don't know.
I mean she is pretty.
She's very attractive.
Yeah, she's hot.
I'll say it.
Naomi Iwuga.
Okay, I wouldn't go that far.
She even faked having a British accent.
Like everything about her is terrible.
Who does that?
Unless it's for attention.
What does this Naomi hate?
Newie, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know if you're new here, but this is an anti-Naomi zone.
I genuinely hate 4.
It is very poorly written.
Okay, I'm gonna continue ghost babbling.
I'm not gonna take the bait.
Viper.
Minto bite.
I'm not doing it.
We're playing Metal Gear Ghost Babble right now.
We're not arguing Naomi's charm or lack thereof.
I'd respect how willing you are to die on the hill.
You're already a ghost.
Snake.
Bison said there were 5 of the black chamber left.
That's right.
Why 5?
Does he mean in total?
Slasher Hawk.
Marionette Owl.
Pyro Bison.
Black Art Viper.
And... Chris.
One unaccounted for.
Oh my gosh!
Lambda!
Screw Naomi.
All my homies hate Naomi.
Couldn't it be her?
What?
Look, if Chris is the 5th black chamber, everything makes sense.
The leak.
The ambush.
What happened to Harkz?
What the hell are you saying?
Hell yeah!
Yeah!
Snake, calm down and think about this.
Shut up!
Oh, damn.
Okay, Snake.
Chris, can you hear me?
Chris, come in.
Chris!
Snake is getting really defensive over Chris for having known her for like 2 hours.
Looks like that's settled.
She got blowed up.
Snake, the F-22's have already left their base.
And the attack will start any minute.
I know this is tough.
But get yourself together.
Oh, sorry.
To the maintenance base.
I'm filling in the blanks.
They changed the names to be more English.
They're named Naomi and Mike Hunter.
Oh, really?
That's so funny.
Understood.
So it's not Frank Jaeger?
Why Mike?
Frank is a...
Wait, what?
What did I say?
It's real though.
It's real though, right?
Impossible to learn.
It's been 8 hours of the stream.
Please!
No!
Enter the Gindran airspace.
Gindran.
Cruise missiles launch.
Missile launch now.
Oh god, I'm crying.
Why do you guys do this to me?
That was really close.
Oh, I can't move yet.
No.
Alright, they're attacking the artillery.
Boom!
Good job!
Did you say we needed to up... You did say we needed to up our game.
So now you're hiding it in facts?
Satellite confirmation in.
Target destroyed.
Snake.
Keep going north.
OK, why don't you guys do that to Metal Gear also?
It was so easy to destroy the artillery.
You can also do that to Metal Gear.
Infiltrate the maintenance base and destroy Metal Gear.
Man...
Golly, guys.
Oh, OK, nevermind.
I thought that was a truck I could explore.
Do I need to...
Mine D.
OK.
Oh, yes.
The mines are still here.
Good to know.
Na na na.
Nice.
What is this?
A trap, that's what that is.
Oh, Nikita ammo, OK.
Don't need that, I guess.
I don't know how that got here.
Looting time!
Is there anything down here?
We're so close to beating the game, guys.
We got this.
I think next I have to fight the helicopter, right?
And then I fight...
Metal Gear.
Oh, I think I'm good.
OK, we'll go past the artillery.
I disagree with you on this, but I still agree.
No ill will.
I'm glad we can agree to disagree, Brandon.
I understand why people would not have a problem with her.
I think it's just... she's just so silly.
And I really don't like how she treated Otacon.
Grenade!
More grenade!
No, I hate her.
Ration!
How many rations do I have?
Can I still only hold two?
Oh, I have three now!
Let's go.
Keep up my mind just in case.
No, no, no!
Chris?
In front of my salad?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god.
OK, wow.
OK, let's see.
Body armor.
And what would be best for this?
They gave me Nikita missiles and grenades.
I'm gonna try the grenades.
How do I use these again?
Sorry, hold on.
Ouch!
Oh gosh, the splash damage.
Is he on this side now?
Where is he?
Oh my gosh, he hits so hard even with the...
Even with the body armor.
Yikes!
Oh dang it, oh dang it, oh dang it!
Oh my gosh.
I got him.
Didn't do so much though.
Maybe, you know what, I am gonna do the Nikita.
How many do I have with that?
Twelve.
Oh my gosh, splash damage.
Splash damage!
Oh my gosh.
Now would be a good time to take a...
Thank you for...
What the heck is going on?
I can't read it right now.
Why am I...
I'm such an idiot.
I'm so stupid.
I'm so dumb.
Did that work?
How is this happening?
I don't understand.
What?
I was sideways!
You guys saw that, right?
Gosh dang it.
I don't like this fight.
I think this one probably will take another try, but that's OK.
That's OK.
Good thing we have the body armor.
Holy hell, if we didn't...
Practice run, yeah.
Where did he go?
There we go.
Did that work?
You can shoot your missiles.
Yeah, I got that.
I don't understand why that keeps happening.
I actually...
Is it blowing up through the rock?
Like, I just... I'm so confused.
Oh my god, please, please, please.
What?
Oh, this is so... This is so fucked.
This is actually so fucked.
Let's go back to grenades, I guess.
And I won't use this for the second round.
I won't use this for round 2.
At least he has a pretty high range of...
Like...
I guess...
Kodak time?
No, I don't think...
Oh my god, how does he get me through the rock?
This guy is so... He's using unfair tactics!
What's the point of the rock to protect me from that?
Oh my god, I threw it the wrong way.
Hell.
I'm basically just...
Ah!
What the hell?
More grenade!
I wish there was ration.
Is there any down here?
Let's check.
There might be some.
No ration?
That's cruel.
No ration is cruel.
How are the missiles doing that?
I don't think that's...
OK, when he shoots again...
And then when he stops...
Whenever that is...
I got him to half health, but I've used all my rations, so...
Honestly, I don't think I have any left, right?
Let me double check.
Nope, none left.
OK, this is fine.
Try and fist fight it.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
Still avoid this!
With the rocks, don't help me!
How the hell?
Oh my god.
OK, there was...
Oh, OK, it starts me back down here.
You know what?
This is fine.
I'll take that.
I don't think I grabbed that before.
Wait.
Oh!
I've wasted all my rations!
No!
I have no more!
It didn't give me the ones!
Oh gosh!
No!
I didn't save, so I can't load... What?
Oh wait, I have three!
I'm sorry.
Sorry, I'm... OK.
OK.
Wait, I see.
I have three.
Sorry.
OK.
I'm losing it, you guys, for real.
I have three.
Oh, goodness gracious.
OK, more grenades!
Nice!
Grenade all the way!
I'm losing it.
Chris.
Chris!
Guys, how many phases are in this fight?
I wonder.
I'm scared.
I wonder if Chaff does anything.
Oh, that's not where that is.
What?
I like when he's up here and shooting those things.
I wish he did that more often.
No, no, please God!
I don't know how to avoid you when you're like this!
I don't know how to avoid these!
Why?
It makes no sense!
Maybe I have to be closer?
Closer?
I don't know.
How to avoid you!
I don't know!
OK.
Alright.
He's back here.
Ouch!
OK.
Nice!
Yes, keep doing this.
I
wonder.
If I hug the wall...
Wesker Chris!
Now it's an even fight.
Oh my God!
Well, you know.
Ouch!
Give me a second to get behind this rock please.
OK.
Item.
Come on.
I'm just gonna wait for him to get to the front again.
Come on, go to the front please.
Go to the front.
Oh my God!
Wait, it doesn't work every time!
That's messed up.
Oh my God.
No!
This is
so...
I can't even move before he starts attacking me again in my...
See!
It's so unfair!
Even fight my ass.
This guy is so not playing fair.
Oh thank God.
Oh my gosh.
Oops.
Just a little bit more!
Wait!
Still
going?
OK.
He crashed!
No phase 2?
This guy!
Terrible!
Chris!
No you're not.
Sorry to disappoint you.
Oh it's her!
The sexy lady.
Let me read your Akasupa.
Naomi is a hot sociopathic narcissist and we should all remember the terrible things she did.
Just because she helped us during MGS4...
Doesn't mean we should support her.
But yes, she's very pretty.
Kojima knows hot.
Fool me once, shame on me.
Fool me twice.
Ain't gonna happen.
Good try though.
Good try.
I think you've been fooled a few more times.
Hey, not in this stream.
Well actually I don't know in this stream.
Whatever.
For his life?
No, but I don't plan on being killed by you.
My, you're pretty confident.
You're all being used.
OK, that's rich coming from you Snake.
Are you talking about Black Chamber?
No, actually we're the ones using them.
The one using them.
Wait, oh?
Revenge against Foxhound and the US?
We know their real objective.
You know and... oh wait.
You know and still...
Yes.
Exploitation in the name of justice and ideals.
We have all the aces now.
Why don't you use the sexy voice more often?
Because...
Because it's hard on my throat.
They'll be mad if I kill you here, won't they?
Justice.
The justice and order being given...
Or rather, it's not hard on my throat, it's just really uncomfortable.
Is all.
Because I have to like, open my throat up.
It's just kind of uncomfortable for me, is all.
In your society applies only to that world.
Free trade, world order.
All the trappings of your private, exclusive ethics that keep bleeding.
Gindra.
For the sake of first world prosperity.
We finally said no more.
And troops were sent to bar our way.
But this time, we will break free of first world meddling.
Is that your ideal?
Or the general's?
Mine.
It's 12 AM Eastern.
Oh my gosh, it's 12 AM Eastern.
It's my pal Isaac's birthday.
Do you mind singing a sweet tune for Isaac?
Isaac.
So I can surprise him with something in the morning.
Yeah.
Isaac.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Isaac.
Wiener.
Happy birthday Mr. Wiener.
Oh my gosh.
What a great friend Mr. Wiener has.
That was a good shot.
That's a lie.
Oh my god.
Did the helicopter explode?
The tables have turned I see.
I have the turns tabled.
Will you plead for your life?
$10 to MGSCon because you said Wiener.
Keep it up boss.
Thanks.
No,
I'm not afraid to die.
For the ideal?
Yes.
Why so fervent?
Have you ever been treated like a piece of dirt?
Do you ever feel like a plastic bag?
My father was French.
Have you ever felt like dirt?
This song is so good.
Wait, I think I've heard it before.
I fully forgive her.
Sacre bleu.
Your father was French?
Every day he fed me baguettes.
And every night he fed me escargots.
Correct me if I'm wrong but I think Eric...
Eric Sean.
That's not a bait is it?
Some of the pixel art for this game.
I love the way it looks.
Is that a bait name?
It is?
How?
How is it a bait name?
Eric Sean.
Eric... Eric Sean.
Eric... Sean.
Eric Sean.
Eric...
I don't get it.
Tell me.
Erection.
Eric Sean.
I switched tabs for a second and realized the con in MGSCon...
No way.
No.
How?
Oh god, I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Sophie.
He met my mother after his farm sent him to Gindra.
And I was born.
But she was nothing but a little local.
Color to him.
When his term was over, he went back to France.
Without giving us a second thought.
The accent changed.
I was still just a baby.
I went to see him once.
I was grown.
But all he did was give me some money.
And demanded that I never bother him again.
As soon as the French lord dropped...
Their monitor was really loyal to the con.
I'm so sorry.
I learned that...
That day that neither I nor my country could expect anything better than that.
Okay, I'm really not good at French accents.
From your kind.
I used the money for university education.
In Britain.
To take the knowledge and the skills back to Gindra.
While I was there...
The genocide policy went into effect.
My mother and...
Wait, why does it sound more Australian than...
Nice Aussie.
It sounds more Australian than British.
Oh my gosh, I've never been able to do an Australian accent though.
You're all over the map.
Okay, her tragic backstory.
Tragic backstory.
Died at the hands of government soldiers.
I flew back to Gindra and joined Gilf.
Deeds, not words, I thought.
But the government was winning.
And we were almost gone.
That's when he, the general, appeared.
She's very sniper-wolf coated.
Suddenly, turned things around.
Plentiful funds, new weapons, and most of all...
The ideals he brought us.
A true independence for our people.
A country for ourselves.
On l'aide du fromage.
Everyone saw the future in him.
I did too.
There was a time when he was everything to me.
Is he still?
No.
Oof.
Rejection.
Goodbye, Sophie.
Accent disappeared like MGS1 to MGS4.
Let me ask you something.
Why did you call me a liar?
Call?
For the terrible children fund.
Thank you, Captain!
Your eyes don't have the hardness of someone who lives for that single cause.
Instead, you looked as though you were struggling to hold on.
They're rookies' eyes.
You are, perhaps, right about that.
Nevermind.
Oh, Snake wouldn't do that.
If I had a nickel for every hot black French villainess that has appeared in this...
Memes, brain rotting prediction mastering series, I would have two.
What?
The other one is...
From...
Revengeance?
I can't remember.
I can't remember her name though.
Mistral.
Yes, yes, yes, Mistral.
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Fortune?
Fortune was not French, right?
Or was she?
Yeah, Fortune was not French.
Can I get one?
What's a...
Thanks, Freakazoid.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
I don't know.
Oh, gosh.
I took French a long time ago.
Fortune is American.
Yeah, I thought so.
You won't kill me?
I love this song during that scene.
No, I'm not reading anymore names.
I'm not doing any...
Out of ammo.
Oh, my gosh.
That is such a Snake thing to say.
No, Snake, I have five grenades right there.
I know you're lying.
You're free to go.
Snake.
Your friend is still alive.
Are you talking about Chris?
Yes.
Viper's taken her.
Go and help her.
Well, then who's the mole?
What if Jimmy didn't actually explode?
It was a fake explosion.
I know she's waiting for you.
I would, even if she weren't.
Damn.
She's a lucky woman.
She would have been luckier if she hadn't had anything to do with me.
Damn.
Okay, Snake.
Snake is unparalleled.
Everybody falls in love with the legend.
I doubt that.
I like how she looks like a...
She's so sexy, but they make her look like a literal troll.
As that sprite.
Like I can't... I don't understand the angle at all.
She's like squatting or like sitting, but she looks like...
Just like a grandma.
I don't get it.
FonFurco, welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Snake, we're almost out of time.
Metal Gear should be further below.
Hurry.
That's what I like to see, baby.
What's in here?
Okay.
Wait, hold on.
Not grenades.
The music is so...
Cool.
Yeah, there we go.
Hello?
How did I... I didn't mean to...
I switched...
Wait.
There we go.
Not bad.
What the...
Why did he... Why did he jump around like that?
Nikita ammo?
Am I gonna need all of this for...
Metal Gear?
Okay, the music is weird now.
What?
It sounds like a Zelda soundtrack.
What's this?
Nice.
Very Link's Awakening.
Yeah, right?
I'm glad you understood what I meant.
It's tight.
We made it.
This is a person or a camera?
Camera...
You can't catch me through here, idiot!
Yeah, dummy.
I can't believe we are still having to explore building stuff.
Holy moly.
Oh my god.
These guys are ruthless.
Oh, these are the guys that are still...
Like, searching.
I think they are glitched.
They are not leaving.
Oh no.
Please leave.
Okay, there they go.
Alright, the one stays.
Alright, there we go.
Ah...
Maybe?
Actually, I can't tell.
Is this part specifically that sounds very...
Very, uh...
Oh, that's my father.
I was wondering about that much.
Very Zelda to me.
What is that there that's moving so fast?
Is that a guy?
I can't tell at all.
Is he like a glitched guy or something?
What is going on up there?
I need to get over there.
Please.
A dog?
No, it's just some dude.
It's just some guy.
Look at him.
Hold on.
I know what to do here.
Hopefully this works.
It's B, right?
They can't come up the stairs.
Yes, they can.
We are fine.
C4.
I don't like the music though.
I'll be honest.
Not a fan of this.
There, there.
Nikita Missile!
Shoot!
OK.
I don't think that...
There is more than one?
I guess.
Up here?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Let's go exploring.
OK, nevermind.
Ripperoni.
Explodable wall?
I don't think so.
I'm afraid to go back up there.
I wish they gave me more stun grenades.
Kind of awesome.
C4 the wall.
Which one?
This one?
This wall you think is thin?
I can try.
It's not staff.
The grenade that gives you staff infection.
OK, please.
There we go.
Sometimes it's easier to do these with an analog stick.
How do I want to get through here I wonder.
Is she close to beating the game?
Yeah, I'm on the last mission I think.
Second to last?
Last or second to last?
Second to last.
Where do I go you guys?
Only one boss left.
OK, this guy here.
Really?
Top right?
Yeah, that's where I'm going.
I'm watching his every move.
I almost went.
Watching his every move.
Punch his ass.
I'm so tired.
I'm so tired everybody.
It's really this camera I hate.
I don't like it.
It's so tricky for me.
Do a part two?
No.
No, no, no.
I'm not feeling that.
I'm just tired of...
some of these gimmicks.
You know what I mean?
I did go into this room, didn't I?
This is where... Yeah, they had the weapons and stuff.
Where's my key card?
Yeah.
I'll take more though.
I think my chat froze everybody.
I'm so sorry.
Hold on.
Let me refresh.
Dead chat happens every time.
I'm surprised
it happened so late here.
Okay, there we go.
Free us.
You're free.
So over here was this guy.
I don't like this.
Actually...
I don't like the soundtrack in this area at all anymore.
It's like really grading me on me.
The little beeps.
Are you trying to finish this in one go?
Yeah.
I'm almost done.
Just a little...
Just a little bit left.
Oh please.
And the beep, beep, beep, beep.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Oh wait, I already destroyed this one.
I'm so stupid.
Okay, nevermind.
I'm an idiot guy everybody.
I'm dummy dum dum dum.
I can go through here.
And then...
What's down here?
Where does this go to?
Boom, boom, boom.
There's another elevator.
Oh my god, why are these buildings so big when it's like...
Okay, let's see if we can shoot our...
No!
These damn guns again.
Oh gosh.
Oh.
Why did that explode?
It's because the cameras there have guns on them and they explode the...
They explode it.
They blow it up.
What is...
I love you?
Oh.
Explain that one, somebody.
Yes!
Baby!
Holy cow, that one was crazy.
Oh my god, that one was so crazy!
Yes!
That felt good.
That felt so good.
Oh no!
Okay, we need higher level.
Yeah!
That's the power of love.
What?
Yeah.
The power of love.
Do you believe?
In the power of love?
Huey!
No, Huey!
No, that's chat.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, I was looking for box and I completely forgot what I was looking for.
Huey Lewis.
I don't get that one either.
Huey...
I know you guys are sending bait names.
Huey Lewis?
I don't get it.
Oh, it's a band.
Back to the future.
It's actually a singer.
I don't trust anybody anymore.
I love you too.
Oh, I think I hear it.
I hear it, I hear it.
That's silly.
Don't come here.
Rude, rude, rude, rude.
Don't turn around.
What is he doing there?
He's like shrugging?
Huey Lewis sang the power of love.
Oh, I was singing the one from... What's it called?
From the Sailor Moon movie.
That's the one I was singing.
Okay, so now we can go to the left.
I don't think we got the one that disabled from the right.
Please, there we go.
Sailor Moon R, yeah!
I love that song.
Do you believe, do you believe in the power of love?
I love you is the superior goddom.
That one is so wholesome.
That one is pretty cute.
I'll end it.
I didn't get this one.
I have to go to the other side.
I thought that was the one I just blew up.
I go from the elevator, maybe that's the end, right?
Probably.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Okay, this is the one I fixed.
What's down here?
Oh, duh.
The place that I just came from and shot my missiles from.
Oh, no pot item.
Chaff grenade.
Health!
That's awkward.
Okay, from here.
Weapon.
Nikita.
Oh, Nikita, Nikita, Nikita, Nikita.
Wait, how am I supposed to get this one?
Wait, oh gosh.
I still don't know how.
Maybe this is actually a wall that I explode.
Weapon.
C4.
Yay!
Okay.
Thank goodness.
ID card 5!
Nice.
Can I punch it to death?
Okay, Nikita again.
Since apparently that's the only way you can destroy these things.
It's so silly.
I don't know where is it there.
Yay!
Okay.
How did I get to that elevator?
Oh, I remember.
Wait.
Was it down here?
I can't remember.
Yeah, I think I remember.
Yes, yes, I remember, I remember.
Okay, so I go through here.
Don't get caught.
And we go back down.
Oh, I'm going to grab more Nikita missiles while we are here.
Do you remember?
That's what first night of September.
Stop the immediate...
I am going the right way, right guys?
And then they are here.
And then I punch this guy out.
And then he falls asleep.
Oh my god.
And
then...
Guys, I don't remember.
Guys, I think I don't remember.
First
night I was just jorking it.
Sorry.
Wait, no.
I'm sorry.
I
didn't mean to.
No.
I didn't mean...
I didn't mean to.
I meant to say I was joking.
Oh
no, please don't clip that.
god, okay.
Oh gosh.
It's okay, we don't care.
I was jorking it for after stream.
No.
More than jorking it.
You know how you are like, I'm joshing.
It just slipped out.
It just came out.
I didn't mean to.
B43!
Oh my god, B45, 6, 7, 8, 9, 50!
Please new soundtrack.
Who's that?
Wait, am I supposed to pay attention?
Oh no.
Wait.
There's mines here, aren't there?
Oh god, wait, oh no.
Okay, hold on.
Holy moly!
There's so many!
It's okay.
I can lay down.
C4!
Sleep guard.
I
think if I just punch him, he'll call me.
True, let's call her.
Need anything?
Francis Bacon said that revenge is a kind of wild justice.
But revenge isn't very productive.
Is it, Snake?
Wow.
The door doesn't open for me.
So I'm wondering if I must knock.
Oh, the body armor.
I think you're right.
I think that's why.
Oh, this is so...
No!
Alright.
Thermal goggles, ahoy!
Hopefully I can go up and avoid the camera.
Hopefully this is a viable option.
8 hours?
Hell yeah, dude, so cool seeing you play.
Thanks, Endwatcher!
Thank you.
Thanks for the super chat.
And change.
I know, I saw this.
Oh, there we go.
But is there anything to collect in here?
Maybe not.
Maybe it's fine.
Wait, what do you mean, Beep Beep?
What do you mean, Beep Beep?
No R-Style!
Thank you.
Level 6?
Where is level 6 at?
Why can't they write the numbers on them?
I see.
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Oh my god.
Oh gosh.
Is it coming back?
Yes, OK.
Sorry, I was standing right in the line of...
Oh my god, I almost about died.
That was so close, huh?
That was pretty damn close.
Oh god, I'm glad I caught it though.
I'm kind of glad that they make getting the boxes a game mechanic.
Like, you know, you wouldn't have been able to get through that one part without them.
So it does make sure that you actually get the boxes and all.
It's kind of smart.
Beep Beep Beep.
Oh, when is it over?
You bastard!
I wish I could dodge roll.
Wait, what is this?
Is this a door?
Open.
Open sesame.
I can't tell if this is a door or not.
Just run!
It
matters!
No!
Dodge roll, snake!
Oh my gosh.
Snake, get up!
Snake, take the body armor.
Take your body armor.
Take your body armor, snake.
We made it.
Gun?
Then I have to aim.
It takes too much time to shoot.
It takes too much time.
Night vision.
Please pick a different soundtrack.
OK, back to thermal.
Boom!
Switch!
OK, and switch!
Switch, go away.
Go away.
Disperse.
Leave.
Vanish.
Oh my god.
I thought that one changed.
That was so close.
Please!
Switch!
Vanish!
Disappear!
Leave!
Why is it everyone that I go up to doesn't disappear?
I saw you disappear before!
Why is it happening to me?
See?
I knew it.
Why is this part blown up?
OK.
Golly!
Hide up?
Wait.
Is it?
Are we able to see in here now?
Nope.
Is this a door?
I don't know if this is a door.
Is that it right there?
I'm actually gonna hear this in my nightmares.
This damn song.
What the hell was that?
Were you threatening me?
Was that a threat?
What was that?
I was like, don't do it.
What the heck?
Threatening me.
Wait, let me...
Did it actually...
No.
OK.
How do I get through this?
Is this not a door?
Switching between this and this game seems annoying.
Yeah, it's not ideal.
C4 the wall?
OK.
I wish they gave you more of an indication when you got a C4 or something.
Everything is bad.
Everything is not good.
How do I get in there?
Do I crawl under the desk?
I wonder.
I still see them.
Wandering around.
Leave me alone.
Oh my god.
Let's see.
Just a box.
Yup, yup, yup, yup.
Oh my god, I was about to move.
You just checked this room!
Sir!
You're too paranoid.
Oh my god, he's back.
Leave me alone!
Leave me alone, please!
Maybe that's his route.
I'm gonna use one of these.
No!
Where is the damn car key?
Well, good to know though that I can crawl under this at least.
Alright, C4.
No!
C4!
What's the point?
Down?
I see another electric flurry.
Okay, thanks mod!
Bomb the left side.
This?
No, I don't need to bomb.
Wait, maybe...
Here?
What?
I don't understand.
I don't understand at all.
The wall above it.
This one?
Oh my god, snake please.
It only let's me put it in the middle.
I'm out of...
This one?
Oh my god.
No...
I don't even know if they're here or not.
So...
Stupid.
So stupid.
What the hell is the point of this?
Let's change my weapon to a gun.
I'm gonna murder people now.
I'm ready to kill.
Is it dark in here or can I put on my...
Leave me alone.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, please let me leave.
Okay, I'm leaving.
Don't worry about me.
Oh...
Do I blow up this one?
This is horrible.
The game was so fine.
Until it became so tedious.
Oh wait, I don't know why I took off my night vision.
I'm an idiot.
Oh...
This one?
Please.
Oh my...
I'm gonna die here.
I'm gonna die here, you guys.
I don't know where to go.
I have nothing.
I don't know.
Oh fuck!
Please don't stay here.
Please.
Give me a chance.
He like ran away with his arms up.
Oh god, I'm so tired.
There it is.
Where is the panel at though?
Do these ones have guns?
Oh, they don't.
Why do you do this to me?
How do I get back?
Why is this a mechanic that every time you... Oh my god!
Every time you fire anything...
I'm just playing the fucking game.
And they're just like, yeah, by the way, that's gonna set off an alarm.
Hope you don't mind.
That's gonna really ruin your plans here, buddy.
Oh gosh.
Oh, we're here.
We're here.
Okay.
Wait.
Isn't this where I came from?
No.
What do you mean?
No?
What do you mean no?
Okay.
What do you mean by that?
Why can't you give me more rations, please?
Oh, now it's fine?
Isn't this where I came from though?
Where am I going?
Thermal.
Isn't this where the camera is?
Where was I trying to go?
Everything is blurred.
The far left door.
Okay.
The one in here?
It's meant to need a small break.
No, it's just...
These levels have gotten so tedious.
Like, have content, have lots of stuff for your game, but like...
You gotta give people a little bit of something.
Like, there has to be, like, if you knock on the wall, you'll know that you can blow it up.
But that doesn't work.
You have to, like, give some people...
You can't just have people blindly, like, blowing up everything.
It just doesn't...
It just...
That's not how this should be.
Okay.
It was this room, right?
Where does this guy stop at?
Right there, okay.
We don't worry about him.
Oh gosh.
We worry about...
There's more...
Ways...
Let
me be free.
Let me be free, please.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Please.
No, no, no, no, no.
Don't do it.
Don't do it, mister.
Please, mister, mister.
Mister, mister, mister, mister.
No!
Please, mister.
Mister, please go.
Thank you.
Jesus!
Oh my god.
This guy...
He was like...
He was literally inching towards me.
Oh my god.
God damn it.
We're going more down?
Please, is this it?
Is this it?
Am I done?
Please.
Please let this be the end.
Please let me just fight Metal Gear.
Here we go.
B74, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 80.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
We're going...
We're getting to Matara's age.
This place is huge.
No, right?
98!
Oh no, please.
End.
End this song!
This is me when this song starts playing again.
Mei Ling, put us out of our misery for 2 seconds, please.
You rang, Snake?
Oh, Mei Ling, your sweet, sweet voice.
I think I would be less mind-broken if the song wasn't just horrible in my ears.
Snake, according to Dr. Copel-Thorn...
I know, you can quote other people a lot.
Some money towards the therapy you may need after this.
Thank you.
No.
But don't you have anything to say for yourself?
For myself?
Yes, I'd like to hear your own words.
Okay.
Well...
I'm sorry.
I can't think of anything.
Yeah, she's not going to be able to think of anything on the spot, Snake.
Maybe I'm just an accumulation of facts and quotations.
Oh no, you're giving her a crisis, Snake.
Beanie, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I have nothing of myself.
That's not true.
What you just said were your own feelings, right?
It's a lot better than being trapped.
In the past.
Like me.
There it is!
See, this music would have been great for just this room.
Elevator again?
How do we want to do this?
I wish these guys stayed asleep for longer.
Shove grenade.
Grenade.
Shoot.
No.
You will not!
You guys ran in here way too fast.
I swear.
You will not do this to me.
Leave!
Where even were they?
Where did he go?
Are they gonna leave?
Ok, one guy left.
They're all doing their little rounds.
They're being good soldiers.
We can't blame them for being good soldiers.
Well, not good, but like proper soldiers, right?
They're just like, we gotta do our rounds and we gotta do them very thoroughly.
Except we can't look under desks because that's...
Ok, that guy is lazy as hell.
That guy is a slack...
Ok, it's just this one fanatic up here who's not leaving because he's crazy.
Oh, I think he's actually bugged.
Just run.
Nice.
What's in here?
We'll let him go to the other side of the room again.
Proper soldiers would have object permanence.
I'm meaning proper in that they're following protocol, you know?
They're following protocol.
Is all I'm trying to say.
Now, what do I do here?
Uh, colonel?
Colonel, save me from the madness music, please.
Didn't they say that Metal Gear was above ground?
We're in basement 98.
This does not look...
Snake, Metal Gear is down below.
Oh, now it's down below.
Make up your mind!
This is it.
There's the target.
Right there.
Stay focused.
What does that mean?
Let's talk to Weasel.
We haven't talked to this guy the entire time.
Hey, Weasel.
Weasel.
How'd your brother die?
Oh, damn.
I haven't talked to this guy the entire time.
And this is how we...
Okay.
I killed him.
McBride said so.
Don't you remember?
But that's not true, is it?
Why do you think that?
I just have a feeling.
That wasn't a quite...
That wasn't quite how it happened.
I feel like Snake is...
Relating with him.
You know, with like Gray Fox.
Frogbert?
No, no.
That is not my...
That is not Frogbert's voice.
This is Weasel's voice.
Yeah, Frogbert is Frogbert's voice.
They're completely different.
There's a patch of hell reserved just for killers.
Who turn against their own flesh and blood.
I know something about that.
Okay, that was a little far.
Now I'm getting it all mixed up.
There's no getting around you, huh?
My brother...
He was a dumb kid.
He didn't have the talent for it.
But he became a mercenary anyway.
Anyway.
Always copying me.
During this one conflict, I was hired by one side.
And he by the other side.
The side that was going to lose.
Just like I thought.
His side got pushed further into the corner.
Every day.
Good night boss, good luck with the ending.
Thank you!
I know some of you guys are staying up pretty late.
If you have to go to bed, no worries.
One day I was told that we were going in for the final kill.
With everything we had.
I thought he was going to say got.
I could have warned him.
But I didn't.
The next day, his entire force was wiped out.
And he was dead.
It was war.
Not something for you to...
Maybe that's true.
But I know he died blaming me.
When I found his body.
He had the lucky pendant.
I had given him.
Half bitten through.
Between his teeth.
V has come too.
Thank you for the five minutes.
The chain ripped to pieces.
That's pretty...
What am I supposed to do here now?
Hello!
Hello Metal Gear.
Maybe I go through here?
Take the elevator?
Yeah.
We are going more down!
Nine.
Seriously?
Actually messed up.
Please change the soundtrack!
You know what?
Oh wait.
I just realized I can't put on other music.
Wait, I can!
Hold on.
OK, we are going to put on this.
Oh my god!
He woke up!
Wake up!
Oh my god!
No, no, no, no, no!
Why did you wake up?
Hello?
OK, another elevator?
Who designed... Who is actually designing these places?
This is ridiculous.
I hope it's not too long.
Sorry, too loud.
Is it?
I think it's... Hold on.
It's OK?
OK, good.
Much better than...
Much better than the other music.
What's over here?
What's happening?
Maybe I should have music on.
Pause?
Geez.
Sorry guys.
Sorry, I didn't mean... I didn't mean for it to happen.
This is what we didn't hear, I think.
What is that?
Looks like...
Wait!
Oh my god!
It's...
Oh my god, it's the...
I recognize this room and...
Oh my god!
Wow, it's the destroyed Metal Gear!
No way!
That's so fun.
What does Campbell have to say about it?
Let's hear.
Campbell!
To an evil past.
It ends right here this time.
I wish... I wish that were real.
What?
Oh my gosh!
Wow, that's so cool!
That's so awesome!
Oh my god.
That's so cool.
Wow!
Okay.
I'm gonna switch my body armor.
How much rations do I have?
I don't think a lot.
I think I'm just gonna have to be good at this fight, honestly.
We're at the base.
Do we have to save?
I guess I can, but I don't... I mean, if I die, I just press continue and it's fine.
What's up, Snake?
I'm saving.
The worst is not.
So long as we can say...
This is the worst.
William Shakespeare.
Again.
Don't give up.
The long road.
Suspicious.
Oh my god.
Think about the prize at the end.
Your comfy bed.
Go back?
Too late!
Thank you!
MGS Con overlaps with another convention that weekend.
No!
You skipped the ration.
Mod, I'm about to time you out.
You're sounding a lot like a backseater right now, okay?
God damn it!
What the hell?
Welcome... What?
Do I reset and reload?
No!
If I die, whatever.
I'll get the ration then.
Welcome, Solid Snake.
Viper!
He's awesome!
Wait, he looks so cool!
I made a promise to you.
And now is the time for you to die.
Where's Chris?
Kaiba.
Yeah, he looks like Kaiba.
Seto Kaiba.
Patience is a virtue, Snake.
You'll see her soon enough.
Viper, I know about Black Chamber.
Being Foxhound's shadow.
But why revenge?
What happened two years ago?
Alright, I'll tell you about it.
And having learned what your crimes are, you'll rot in hell.
Two years ago, we, the Black Chamber, were given a top secret mission.
The recovery of Metal Gear.
The game is quiet?
Did you hear that?
Why is Mr. Vector so stupid?
Metal Gear's development had been underway for several years at that point.
Under CIA supervision.
There was no music?
Yeah, but I thought they meant it was quiet because they couldn't hear the...
CIA?
I told you it was McGregor.
A South American terrorist group seized it two years ago.
He said he didn't know anything.
The CIA didn't know anything.
And Black Chamber was sent in.
Just as you were this time.
We took heavy damage, but succeeded in destroying Metal Gear.
But some in the government were afraid that the fact of Metal Gear's development, the existence of Black Chamber, and above all else, the work we had been doing, would become public knowledge.
When we came home, many of the unit missing, the rest wounded.
We were met by government sent...
Government sent assassins.
Foxhound.
What?
My men were cut down, unarmed, caught in the trap.
Without a chance, without even knowing why.
Senseless and sudden death, crushed like insects.
I can never forget that night.
I still don't know who ordered our deaths.
The real name appears nowhere on classified records.
He is only referred to as...
Burger.
Anonymous.
That's why they were like...
Yeah, down with Anonymous!
I have a feeling it's because of Updog.
Anonymous.
Those of us who survived bowed vengeance.
When I settled here.
Outer Heaven.
Metal Gear.
Project Babble.
I haven't heard Project Babble.
What's the ghost part?
It all began here.
I have waited two years for this moment.
Anonymous.
Now, for the happy reunion.
I'm sure it was worth the wait.
Chris!
Snake, I'm sorry.
She's really something.
Even let her Delta Force pals die.
While she got busy destroying evidence of Project Babble.
As a reward from Parker, I will let her see the show.
Of the end of the legend.
The execution of Solid Snake.
No, Chris is coming with me.
After I take you down.
I'm going to enjoy this.
Come on, show me what you've got.
Well, let's finish this.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
How is best to fight?
They were giving me a lot of...
A lot of chaff.
They gave me a lot of chaff, but I don't know if that's for Metal Gear.
Use the landmines.
Feed them like Grape Box.
Oh, my God.
He's running away.
Oh, I see.
Oh, my gosh.
Why did it do that?
Oh, my God, you guys.
Okay, now I can go back for that other ration.
So misleading.
Didn't I think people were just going to go to the end of the map before they go through the first door?
I thought the battle would be at the end of the map.
Wait, do I have to go through that whole cutscene again?
Oh, man.
Okay.
Let's heal.
And armor.
And go through.
And can I skip?
Save.
You guys, I click continue.
It doesn't matter if I save or not.
Hold B.
Okay.
This fight seems a little nasty.
Save after the cutscene?
You know what?
Sure, why not?
Oh, my God, Chris.
Oh, my God.
Maybe I'll save it in battle, actually.
The show.
The downfall.
Okay, here we go.
I have to switch my weapon anyway.
There we go.
That scared me for a second.
Dang.
Snake.
Oh, I almost just knocked over my phone.
Are you alright?
Not really.
Snake, come back to us safely.
Thank you, Meiling.
Where is he?
Oh,
I got him though.
Is he down here?
Oh, my gosh.
Where the hell is he?
I couldn't avoid that one.
I'm trapped.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, my God.
You little bitch.
Piece of pain in my ass.
Yeah.
Oh, he hopped over me.
Oh, my God.
This is a pain in my ass.
This is such a silly fight.
Oh, you bitch.
No, you bitch.
No, no.
I can't avoid either.
Oh, okay.
Phew.
Hello.
Where are you?
I think he's...
Ouch!
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
We're doing something.
What a weirdo this guy is.
Okay.
Can't tell.
Viper, you little bitch, you.
Come here.
I'm like so concentrated.
Sorry, guys.
Did I get him?
Where is he?
I don't know at all where he is.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, shoot.
No!
Viper.
I didn't have a good time with that.
I can't avoid it.
That's so unfair.
Oh, my God.
I think I got him, though.
Did I hit him?
Oh, where is he?
Where is he?
Is he down here?
I don't know.
There he... Oh, damn it.
Okay, at least I hit him.
It was not in vain.
Please stop putting me in this terrible situation.
I think he is in the top right... or top left.
Damn it.
I hate fights when it forces you...
And it wouldn't let me use Nikita.
So I couldn't... I can't use Nikita missiles on him.
I don't think.
Let me double check.
Yeah, I see.
I think because of the strings, technically, you can't use it.
Celebrating my 5th minute anniversary of my birthday.
Why 7th birthday?
Please remind me about it after this fight.
Someone, please.
So I can sing you happy birthday.
I don't want to give you just a quick one, you know?
I want to sing you a proper happy birthday.
Oh, my God.
Please let me out of here.
Let me out!
Oh, my God.
I keep getting the save.
What is this?
This is unfair.
The game is broken.
Let me out!
Oh, thank God.
That's right.
Finally.
Get your stupid ass.
Stupid.
You stupid bitch.
Stupid!
Being found 12 times.
No.
No way.
Good.
But it isn't over yet.
What's that?
Oh no.
Damn!
Grab her.
Oh, okay.
Good.
Help her and then make her run.
You know what?
That's so much better.
Alright.
One last final battle, everybody.
Chris, are you hurt anywhere?
No.
I'm so sorry.
Wait.
Hold on real quick.
Okay.
I'm so sorry.
Don't be.
I have to be.
Sad Chris.
Oh, birthday!
Yes, thank you!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Bryce.
Happy birthday!
Okay.
I have to be.
I've been lying to you.
You mean because you weren't there when your team was wiped out?
You knew?
Yes.
I was given orders directly by Parker.
The army chief of staff.
What kind of mission?
The destruction of all data on the project Babel.
And Outer Heaven.
And the assassination of the general.
What?
I was told that the information had to be buried for the good of the world.
Snake looks like Ben Stiller here.
He really does.
He looks straight out of Zoolander.
And that the general would have to be as well.
Before he was arrested and talked.
You believed that?
For my country.
For the world.
What else do I have to believe in?
Chris.
That's why Snake spins around sometimes.
He can only turn left, you know.
So he's trying to turn, but he can't, you know.
He can only go one way.
And so I fell away from the rest of the team.
And they...
I thought I could find something to cherish.
Something sure and concrete.
But there wasn't anything like that.
And insisted I lost...
Oh, instead I lost something that I cherished even more.
I was so afraid of losing it again.
But I just couldn't tell you.
I love you.
I'm getting so sleepy, you guys.
It's almost 2 AM for me.
This was much longer than I anticipated.
I thought it would be like 8-9 hours.
Not 10 hours, but that's okay.
Oh, Chris.
Oh, shoot.
I didn't get to read that.
Sorry.
Find us something fast to escape on.
So that we can get out of here quickly.
Once I've destroyed Metal Gear.
You still trust me?
It's true that you didn't tell me the truth.
But I trust you.
She looks pregnant in this sprite.
I don't know what it is.
Why?
Because I want to.
Do you guys see it too?
It looks like her hand is on her tummy or something.
Yeah, it looks like the pregnant emoji.
I don't understand what position...
I think maybe it's supposed to be similar to Snake.
But they gave Snake's left leg more...
Pushed forward.
So that's why it works out that he looks like he's standing diagonally.
But not her.
Do
I need any other reason?
Thank you.
I'll find something.
I promise.
Alright.
For the baby.
Snake.
Metal Gear is through there.
Hurry.
Nice.
I can go through here.
That's fun.
Yay, new music.
C4.
Okay.
Grenade.
Anything else?
How many rations do I have anyway?
Two or one?
Two!
Okay.
Nice.
Already missing the beep beep?
You are alone in that, my friend.
You are alone in that.
Jam?
I'm nervous here though.
Oh, is that just a regular item?
Landmine.
Oh, okay.
I don't know.
I feel like they would do something like this, you know.
Grenade.
Okay, I don't want to get run over by a truck.
Oh my gosh, it's a...
It's just what they call...
Phantom no nazo.
Make sure we don't miss anything, guys.
Oh.
Nikita ammo.
Okay, maybe there's nothing here.
Okay, maybe I'm safe.
I'm so paranoid.
I'm like, oh, they didn't throw...
They didn't give us a landmine section.
In the very last building.
Surely there's landmines here.
Grenade.
Oh, there we go.
Stop.
I see that the little vendetta has been played out to its conclusion.
Wow, Metal Gear!
Why does it have big ol' hands?
Oh, those are the ray guns.
General.
Once a loser, always a loser.
Eh, Snake?
I think...
I'm...
I wiped out your whole team, General.
What do you mean, once a loser?
I also defeated the previous Metal Gear.
I'm kinda confused with that...
What is he on about?
I don't know.
Liquid Vamp?
Yeah, he does look like Vamp.
The last one standing is the winner.
Snake!
And that would be myself.
Not you, not Black Chamber, and certainly not America.
I used them all, you see.
Parker, Black Chamber.
What?
I triple-crossed them!
Or just set the cover on Outer Heaven.
And Project Babel?
Or rather, the truth about GILF and the US.
The Metal Gear crosses, of course.
Nobody has loyalty in this series.
Except Ocelot, because he has way too much loyalty to one person.
And therefore interferes with his other loyalties, you know what I mean?
Villain arrogance?
Yeah, maybe.
Just like that woman.
GILF and the US.
GILF and us?
What truth?
Ha ha ha.
So you're nothing but a pawn to...
Just like Viper and his lot.
There's a connection between GILF and the States and Outer Heaven?
Wait, there's a connection between GILTS, the States, and Outer Heaven?
Fine.
I will tell you all about...
If you win.
Winner takes it all.
Loser relinquishes...
All.
That is the way of the world.
And you will abide by it, Snake.
Wow, this Metal Gear is really cute.
It kind of looks like a Stingray.
I'm a bit of a fan.
But I wish it had a name.
What do you call it?
Metal Gear Babel, I guess?
Snake, Metal Gear must be destroyed.
It looks like Rex and Rey combined.
It's Gander.
Gander?
Damn Gander?
Damn Tender.
Damn Tender?
Funny.
I've always wanted to tell Raura that I love that moment so much.
I think of it often.
Take out its legs first of all.
Hit it hard with mines and C4.
Oh my gosh, Campbell is being...
He is being so useful.
Amazing.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh god.
Warning though, please.
Thank you.
Alright.
C4.
Oh my god.
Ouch.
That didn't work as planned.
Where the hell... What the hell is this fight?
Run!
I think I'm not doing such a good job, you guys.
Why isn't... Why are my...
Why are my things exploding?
It's stepping on you.
Yeah, I know.
I'm trying to put... Oh my god, I'm all the way back here.
I'm trying to put...
The C4 under its foot and explode it.
Use mines?
Okay, we'll use the landmines instead.
Or isn't there another thing over here?
He said C4 also works.
I'm not crazy!
I'll try the landmines instead.
It's just... How do I see where he lands?
I thought that...
I thought that I would be able to blow it up.
But I feel like there is more items.
You know, whatever.
It's fine.
Oh.
Brand-night.
Okay.
You have to detonate the C4.
Yeah, but I couldn't get... That's the issue.
I couldn't because I would get exploded upon.
I would get exploded upon and then I would press A and it wouldn't work.
That's why.
Okay.
This goes bad with one of the non-canon games.
I think it's like pseudo-canon.
It's referenced in...
In MGS2.
Take out its legs first of all.
Hit it hard with mines and C4.
See?
I'm not crazy!
Okay.
Okay, hold on.
Alright, weapons.
Landmines.
I collected a good amount of those because I...
Metal Gear looks really like Rifleman.
I don't know what that is, but it sounds cool.
I'm just gonna keep running.
Okay, got one.
Oh, shoot.
Dang it, I missed.
Oh, I missed.
I'm gonna run out at this point.
No.
Dang it.
This is hard.
At least I'm not getting blown up by the...
Oh, come on!
You ass!
You stopped!
You did!
No.
There.
Yeah.
Absolutely baited.
Yeah!
Ouch.
Ouchie ouch.
Snake can really take a beating, can't he?
I love that about...
Oh, classic.
Classic Minto.
No!
That one should've hit!
Thank you!
I'm assuming that was...
Phase 1.
Metal Gear's down?
You did it?
No.
Not yet.
It's not over yet.
What does that mean?
Hold on.
Can we save?
I'm gonna try, actually.
Attack those targets.
I'm gonna first use a ration.
Nice.
Body armor?
Grenade time?
I think so.
I think it might be half time for the grenade.
APs!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
One second.
I have an itch.
Okay.
Bling!
I don't know if this will work, but...
Snake!
Don't let him get to you!
Okay.
Throw!
Oh, goodness.
Oh my God.
Where are those weak spots?
Throw!
Come on!
That's so... What?
Weak spots?
How?
Excuse me?
Oh my God.
What the hell is that?
Alien creatures.
How the hell am I supposed to get his weak spot?
There we go.
Wait!
It didn't even do any damage!
And I'm trapped?
I'm sorry.
What is this?
What the hell is this?
Evil tops.
Oh
my God.
Oh my God.
When is too close?
When do you... Sometimes he just wants to throw wherever the fuck he wants to throw.
Excuse me, Snake.
You have to be more consistent.
This is very upsetting.
This is very upsetting for me.
Snake!
Why are there tops?
Oh my God.
Why do these exist?
Jimmy!
Jimmy, I swear to God.
Jimmy.
Am I doing any damage?
I don't know.
I can't tell.
Drones?
It doesn't feel like drones.
Feels like evil tops.
Jimmy is just a child.
He truly was... Am I doing any damage?
I don't want to have to go through part one again.
Oh my God.
I don't understand this part.
Maybe I... Shoot.
Throw here.
I'm still throwing in the same exact spot.
I can't throw... It will not aim anywhere.
I don't know.
Please put me at part two.
You're gonna look it up?
Okay.
Look it up and let me know.
I don't know.
I'm trying my best.
I'm gonna need more water in a minute though.
Jimmy from mouthwashing?
I watched someone play through that recently.
Because I wanted to understand the hype.
But I didn't really feel like streaming it.
Okay.
I need more water.
Did I live up to the hype?
It was good.
But like... I felt...
Because I've seen so much about it before.
I felt like I already...
Well, I didn't know the story.
But I already was just like...
I know who to hate because of everything that I've seen on Twitter and stuff about it.
So I was kind of just like...
Oh, okay.
That guy sucks.
Got Jimmy spoiled?
Yeah, basically.
But I liked it.
I don't think... I mean, not to say like...
It wasn't the greatest thing.
Like it was still very stylistically cool and everything.
And Watcher, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh gosh, okay.
Oh wait, you?
Landmine.
I wish this was just the fight.
I wish it was just this.
Alright, and boom.
Well, I still got him, I guess.
Not me, Snake!
I just wanna cry.
Snake, when you're so dumb...
Snake, it makes it really...
Oh my god, oh my god.
Wow, that was actually extremely unfair.
Okay, sure, sure, sure.
Triple fake out, yeah.
Like, crazy.
I wish also it didn't put him at full health.
After I did this.
With like the tiniest chips of health.
I mean, it's the final boss, what can you expect?
It's the final boss.
They gotta make it challenging, I get it.
I get it.
Yeah, I was doing some serious splits there, for real.
Alright, Metal Gear's down?
No, not yet.
Okay.
Nikita's sides and pods.
What's the pods?
The...
The tops?
Or...
Or those, the pods up there?
The backpack, okay.
Give me a second, guys, I need water.
Desperate.
Let's kick this guy's ass.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait.
Where do I...
Where do I shoot it to?
Did that do it?
That didn't even hurt him.
That didn't do any damage.
Do I do from the back?
I have to go in order?
I have to be destroyed in order.
Okay.
Nevermind then.
Alright.
Cool.
Grenades it is then.
Okay.
I can't get this second gun, though.
That's the issue for me.
Oh my god, please.
I really can't get this second gun.
Because I can't reach it.
Leave me alone, stupid tops.
Oh my god.
Like, how do I...
Oh, fuck you.
God, fuck you.
Said the fuck you ghost.
Is it dead?
Oh gosh.
Maybe from the side.
Okay, there we go.
From the side here.
Please.
Let me damage you.
Oh my god.
No!
No more tops!
Oh
my god.
Oh my god, please.
Please leave me alone.
This is so...
Why do they have 50 things going after me?
How do I know when it's dead dead?
Like...
I guess it'll be gone.
It'll disappear.
I guess it'll stop working.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch!
Hit...
Oh.
No, I'm supposed to hit and dodge.
But the timing is...
Oh, you're not supposed to time...
You're not supposed to do that.
Okay.
Oh wait.
Grenades!
Only four though.
That's fine.
That's
fine.
That's fine.
That's good.
I wonder why the tops aren't coming out.
You know what?
That's fine.
I'm not gonna complain about it.
Ouch!
Oh wait!
Oh, I think it's dead!
Oh, you could've exploded or shown me or anything?
Why?
What the fuck?
Why didn't it, like, tell me?
Oh, uh...
Ouch!
Oh, what is this?
Okay.
Uh...
Nikita time?
Yeah, but...
Where do I stand?
I hate this.
No, please.
Please work.
Oh, it doesn't work anymore.
Everyone said it was Nikita time.
I just listened.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's this thing again.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
I think I'm out of...
Yeah, I'm out of...
Rations.
Rations?
I don't know where to run!
I'm scared.
This one's so scary.
Oh, what the hell?
That was my last grenade.
Please.
What?
They're both working?
No, no.
Wait, this doesn't make any sense!
Fuck, it's this thing again.
Oh my god.
I
can't tell when this is...
Oh my god.
Opened up, you know?
So it's like...
I have to hear it and it's...
And then I'm scared.
I'm scared to do this and...
Miss.
Oh, I need to be back further.
Oh god, no, I'm gonna miss my chance!
Oh my god.
How the hell?
Oh god.
Oh, well, that doesn't work anymore, I guess.
It doesn't...
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh shit, there we go.
There we go.
Ouch, ouch.
Bitch.
Bitch!
Fuck you!
I'm empty!
I fucking ate you!
Fuck you!
Oh my god, I got stuck on the fucking rock!
No!
What is this?
Oh, fuck it.
Fuck me.
This sucks.
This is...
This is awful.
This is awful!
Okay.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
Calm down.
I'm gonna concentrate.
I am concentrating, but it's...
Oh, I have one more.
Okay.
Weapon.
Change.
To.
Nikita.
And.
Shoot.
Where is the Nikita?
Shoot!
I think I missed my chance.
Yep.
That's so...
That's not nice.
I don't like...
Oh, shit.
I'm gonna die.
I'm not gonna...
This isn't the ride, you guys.
How
am I supposed to...
Sorry,
guys.
I'm not talking much because my throat hurts.
This thing in the back is working.
Wait, it is working?
The health is going down.
It doesn't give you a good visual indication.
Oh, so it is working.
In general or only when it's open?
You did a lot of damage.
Yeah, we got really far.
That was my phone.
I don't know when I'm hitting it right though.
I don't know if I'm hitting it correctly though.
I still can't tell.
I can't get the timing right on the back missiles, you know.
I have to get far away from it so it doesn't do its stupid flamethrower.
You got me through a very difficult day today.
I'm glad.
I hope that works.
Steppy!
Nice save.
Oh,
come on.
What the...
You came down faster than you normally do.
Unfair.
See, look how much time he usually gives and with that one he came down immediately.
Bitch.
Fuck you Metal Gear whatever your name is.
Nobody calls you by your Metal Gear name though.
Everybody just calls you Metal Gear because everyone hates you.
They hate you enough to erase your identity.
That was too slow.
It looks like Snake has a little cat tail, doesn't it?
Sorry, I'm...
I'm getting... I'm missing these.
I'm missing these, so I'm...
Oh, I got hit twice though.
I got hit twice though.
I don't think this is the run.
That's stupid.
I don't even know how to hit those other... The circle-y guys.
I don't know how to hit those at all.
Like, I think it's actually impossible.
I have no idea.
You hit them at an angle.
Aw, that's hard.
Why am I at... Why did I have my card healed?
Go in the armpit and angle it.
I want the tops to not come out.
Wait!
Oh.
I just hurt myself.
Oh, did that do any damage?
Nope, of course not.
That would be too easy.
Oh, the tops!
Oh, the tops.
I think the tops...
Stop once you...
Oh my god, please.
I can't move with you.
I can't work under these conditions.
I'm just gonna keep doing this.
And chip away.
I'm just gonna keep doing this and chip away.
And the tops will maybe come down.
Oh, fuck me.
Fuck you.
Fuck this game.
Fuck this boss.
Oh my god, ouch.
Everything moves so fast.
Oh my god, there's no way to dodge when you get stuck on the things.
It moves too fast.
You just have to be... You just have to hope you're not in its line of sight.
Oh my god.
Asshole, asshole, asshole.
And I get stuck on these fucking boxes.
The hitboxes, I don't understand the hitbox at all.
Because I truly... I don't understand it.
Okay, I'm gonna need to go get more sand.
And I'm gonna just use my... I'm just gonna use this while I have it.
Can you imagine if I didn't have the body armor?
If I hadn't gotten that, I don't think I would have been able to survive any of these.
It would literally be like, get good or you'll never...
Oh my god, come on.
No, no.
Wait, why... Oh, there.
If I could just see where the boxes are.
Oh my god.
Thanks for the warning.
This guy is such an ass.
I hate you.
Oh my god.
Why are they always random too?
Like, the way these fire are random, so I can't, like... I can't, like...
Detect what pattern it's gonna be.
There's no warning sign.
There's nothing.
It's like I said with the walls and everything.
Like, you have to... Okay, okay.
You have to be able to, like...
Let the player have some sort of indication of something.
There's no rhyme or reason.
No, I'm not talking about when it fires.
And it's not always when it shoots.
It just kind of go... Like, it's not always when I hit the gun.
Because sometimes it just goes.
Like now.
See?
I didn't hit the gun and it just decided to fire.
I didn't hit the gun there though.
And it decided to fire.
Oh my god.
I'm talking about though its pattern.
Its specific shot pattern.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Because it's very fast.
And then also, see?
Like...
It's fucking ridiculous.
There is no pattern and that's what makes it so difficult.
I can't.
I can't with this thing.
Oh my god.
Please.
Stuck on the box.
Oh god.
Oh
my...
Oh, what's the point?
What is the point of anything?
What's the point of anything anymore?
Imagine if there were a part...
This is it.
This is it for me, guys.
Oh, it does do damage.
I see it.
Please.
Oh god.
Let me
try...
I'm just waiting for it to launch more.
I'll just wait here until it launches another.
I know it's not damaging you guys.
I'm not fucking dumb, okay?
Is there anything over here?
No.
I think if I just stand there though...
The bullets can't hit me.
It'll just be hard to dodge the missiles.
But I think that might be the best strat.
At least let me just try it.
I just have to dodge the missiles.
I wait for it to open up.
I shoot.
Dodge missiles.
Keep waiting for it to open up.
Shoot.
Dodge missiles.
I think it's all I can do.
You can see the missiles on the mini-map.
You can?
I had no idea.
Thank you.
And look at the membership.
Shut up, colonel.
I don't care.
Run away far, far from the Metal Gear.
Try not to get hit.
Nice.
He was fast there.
It was fast on that one.
Splash like a bitch.
Nice.
That was like right in the middle.
Big damage.
If only it mattered in phase 2.
I had a feeling it was going to be a fake out.
That's what stepping on Legos feels like.
Yeah, step on my Legos.
Step on my Legos.
Step on them.
I'm glad I didn't go for that one.
Step on my Legos.
Step on them.
No hit.
Okay, I almost spilled my water everywhere.
Okay.
Put my drink down.
You know what the final icing on the cake is going to be?
I'm going to get to the stage clear and it's just going to say, terrible.
Terrible.
I'm going to get to the stage clear and it will be like, wow, horrible job.
I can't wait.
Oh my gosh, the tops.
Oh my gosh.
And throw.
Throw.
Oh, the tops.
The tops.
Have you guys seen that animal, like the heel...
Crux, whatever it's called, and it goes...
Stop it!
Leave me alone!
That was close.
Oh my god.
At least touching them doesn't do anything, it seems.
It's just...
Oh, that was close.
Oh shit.
Nice dodge, nice dodge.
Oh, not dodge there.
Please, no more tops.
Oh my god.
I can't tell what's going to hit me.
Is it the guns?
Is it the tops?
Is it the things up there?
Like, holy hell, there's just so much shooting at me.
At all times.
Please.
Oh my gosh, I just ran right into it because...
How the fuck was I supposed to know where you're gonna spawn your satans?
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
No!
I'm out!
You could've told me!
Okay, getting close there, so...
Let's use this.
That's...
I can't throw diagonally.
I'm not good at it, so I'm not going to attempt, honestly.
Oh my god, please!
Jesus!
God,
you don't give me any chance to dodge!
Oh my god.
They just turn on me.
Sometimes the guns work and sometimes...
Okay, I see what you mean.
What is...
Oh god, I can't look at the radar.
My self is too huge.
I can't look at the radar.
No, no, no, no.
No.
My box is too big and I can't tell where I am and versus and stuff.
Amanda!
That's the MGS Con boss!
Oh gosh, don't be here.
I'm being descended into madness.
Please, don't watch this.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, I can't look at it.
Oh wow, okay.
I don't know if that...
Guys, I'm just...
I don't know anymore.
I'm just gonna...
There's nowhere that is safe to stand.
Oh, fuck me.
Thank you, Tim!
You guys know that you're super chatting, but I'm just gonna send it back to the Kickstarter.
But thank you!
We got it halfway.
Only halfway.
I know that area is really tight for dodging, but...
I don't feel safe standing anywhere else.
Why hit harder spot than easy spot?
It's just different slightly damage.
Because the missiles are gonna come otherwise.
And I can avoid all the other attacks and hopefully avoid the missiles.
Or, I can be hit by the missiles and the other attacks.
That's why.
Nevermind.
Faded.
God, you're such a little bitch.
I'm gonna restart.
Restart.
Oh, there's stuff down here too.
There's more grenades.
Okay.
Save right before the boss stage?
I did.
I've done that before and it still makes me pick up everything.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
I just got my landmarks.
No way, I look like a little monkey.
You can see my big ol' ears.
My big ol' ears on the side and my little monkey tail and my little monkey nose and my little monkey legs.
Are you gonna bait me?
Yep.
I know you're gimme.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, alright, alright.
I can... I will...
Do...
Now.
Sometimes I wish I just could keep running and running and running.
And that I don't have to lay anything down.
Just run away from my problems.
Oh, you...
You ass.
Customer Johnson, thanks for the birthday gift!
Thank you!
Okay.
Yes.
Run, run, run.
You still going?
Yeah, I thought this was gonna be a faster stream than it really turned into.
It is what it is.
Hopefully I can beat it within an hour so that I can go to bed and...
Oh, you...
You...
And also not have to make a separate bit of offer.
For...
Phase two is time consuming.
It is.
We've only done it a couple times.
So...
I saw some people saying that, like...
The game forces you to hit everything on it.
But I don't think that's the case.
What, does the health just stop dropping if you start attacking...
If you only attack one thing?
I feel like that's not really the case.
I don't think that's really the case.
Okay.
Believe in yourself.
In the minky that believes in you.
Defeating the circle turrets is good because they stop shooting at you.
But they're so hard to hit!
But also...
Also...
They regenerate, so it doesn't matter.
They regenerate.
Stand next to them and aim sideways.
No, no!
I end up getting hit.
The circle turrets don't regenerate?
No way.
Okay, that's big news.
Okay, let's go try it.
Okay, aim diagonal.
Sideways.
See?
This is why.
Sideways.
Like, you can't stand diagonally, which is the issue.
Okay.
No, leave me alone!
Leave me alone!
Maybe they are leaving me alone.
Is this the strat?
Do nothing?
The strat is... do nothing.
See?
I can't hit them.
I don't know how, you guys.
I do try.
I am legitimately...
Oh my god!
It worked!
But I have to...
Yeah!
Ouch.
Open.
Open wide.
Open up.
Here comes the grenade.
Open.
Ah, bad.
I wonder how we know when...
Oh, ouch, ouch.
Don't worry about it.
Don't think about it.
Open.
Big news!
Now I can just stand here and blow this thing up.
Wait, is it still taking... No, okay.
Heal.
Shoot.
I don't think he can reach me back here.
Ah, dummy.
Shoot.
Heal.
The longest ever iframes I've ever seen on a boss.
Ridiculous.
Are you gonna run out?
Yeah, I know.
Kill the other side.
Yeah, I should.
Okay, let's run.
Let's run to the other side.
Gosh.
Okay, now I have to...
There we go.
Right here.
Open up.
Open up, please.
Taste my...
Open.
Okay,
open.
Oh my gosh.
Open.
Yes!
Okay, we found the spot.
We found the spot.
Sorry.
Nice.
Open.
Oh no!
Oh no.
No, guys.
Not good.
Oh my god, I'm trapped.
I'm trapped.
It's doing more?
I don't understand.
I tried moving!
Oh my god, please.
Open.
You know what?
I'm just gonna kill you.
There you go.
No!
No, I'm trapped.
I'm trapped.
Oh shit, man.
Man.
Why is it like this?
Open?
No!
Wrong open!
Wrong open.
Not you.
The other open.
These are killer.
These are... Oh my god.
I don't think I threw it.
You know what?
Oh, wrong.
Screw it.
It's fine.
Life is pain after life is pain.
Everything is pain.
Where's the grenades?
Please spawn!
Oh, here they are.
They're like, what if we didn't spawn where you wanted them to?
Oh...
I'm gonna wait again, I think.
I don't know.
Girl, I thought I was gonna be able to watch this VOD tonight.
Fuck me too, man.
Oh, uh... Run!
Okay.
At least I can get to an area where they're not...
All concentrated, you know?
Run, run, run.
Ah, shit!
I tried running up.
They're so fast.
Oh my god, again?
I hate this move.
Please, no more.
Okay.
I
gotta pee.
Pee.
I've had so much water.
I wish I had one more ration.
I wish the game was kind.
What the hell is that?
I see something on the map.
I think it's bullets?
I can't tell.
Wait, what's happening?
What is this?
Phase... Uh oh.
Someone's raiding me.
Thank you!
What's going on?
What is this?
Flamethrower.
Maybe I can need Kida from here.
Nope.
Hold on.
Attack the front.
Oh shoot.
That's evil!
Nexy, thank you for the 10 gifted.
That's so evil of them to have it be like that.
Oh, nevermind.
Wow, the one time I get it in.
Okay.
Open up!
Did it eat it?
Is
it doing damage?
No, I didn't think so.
Did it do damage?
It wasn't open?
I think it was.
I don't think it's... Let's see.
That's my fault.
Oh, come on!
I don't wanna get in front of it.
No, I didn't hit it there.
You might have to grenade it.
Oh shoot.
At least you're still laughing.
I'd be throwing...
Amanda, many tears have been shed.
Don't worry.
Oh my gosh.
I'm not strong.
I'm not strong enough for this.
This is nonsense!
Face him!
I'm gonna die for real!
I'll do it.
I'll keep going until my Nikita missiles run out, okay?
Let's keep trying until...
Nikita runs out.
I think his fire explodes it.
I'm not gonna lie.
I think his... I think his...
I think his fire explodes it.
Guys...
It's been nice knowing you all.
Throw!
Eat it!
Eat up!
There's none over here.
Where are the grenades?
Grenades!
Grenades, please!
Over here.
Yummy!
No!
Oh god!
I was so close!
It's sickening.
Sickening, sickening.
Oh my god.
Thanks for the raid, whoever's raiding me!
If you're coming in and you don't know who I am...
Click off the stream, please.
I don't want you to see me like this.
Please!
It's an embarrassment.
You can just go, I understand it now and it's over for this.
Wait, what do you mean?
I don't get it.
They're about to see you win.
Don't jinx it!
Red, don't jinx it!
Alright, let's not waste any grenades on myself.
And maybe we'll have a good amount for when he starts throwing up.
Bucket capacity, I'm about to...
I'm about to ban you forever.
Don't be mean!
This is not the time to be mean, please.
I'm serious.
I need my little vest on.
Alright, run, run, run.
I don't know what that...
I don't know what that super chat just said.
I only saw a doki bird.
I'm confused.
Is that a bait?
No.
That's close enough.
Like, I saw some comments from people being like, Minto, you always get this way during final bosses.
But it's mostly I get this way, I feel, when I've been streaming for a long, long time.
And I get a little grumpy.
So I apologize for getting grumpy and frustrated.
But sometimes...
Some things are not fair.
And I think I have a right to be grumpy about the unfairness of certain fights.
Gamer rage is natural.
Exactly.
My skills as a gamer.
Nice.
So I apologize.
And I cry out of frustration.
It's not like I'm like, I'm so sad.
It's just when I get really frustrated.
Which is so annoying because I'm one of those, like, if I get angry I cry type of people.
So it's just like I can't be taken seriously because I'm crying when I'm angry.
But it's not like I'm like suffering, you know.
I'm just like...
It's a ghost thing, you know.
I'm a ghost and I'm always, you know...
I'm always angry and I cry, I moan, you know, stuff like that.
Oh.
Colonel didn't even talk to me.
In about 20 minutes he'll break the record of longest solo stream.
Mine?
That's so funny.
Okay.
Guys, I think I have to go to the bathroom now.
I gotta go!
You can listen to this sick sweet song.
At least the song is way better than the previous levels.
I've
been answering...
I've been answering...
Discord messages.
Metal Gear or the MGS con people are messaging me.
They're just like, good luck!
You got this, good luck!
Thanks!
Vulcan versus Solidus.
Who wins in the twerk off?
Vulcan.
He has experience.
Okay, grenades!
Alright, let's get back in.
Right in here?
Does this seem correct?
Maybe a little closer.
Open!
Oh, not there.
Not there.
Once about two...
Open?
Why not?
Oh, there we go.
I think.
Maybe.
Maybe I need to get closer.
Chill, chill, chill.
Chill, top.
Chill, chill!
What happened to when you guys were dumb?
A little closer.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Open, please.
Okay, we got it.
Nice.
Is the VOD gonna survive?
Hopefully.
Please!
Stop it!
Leave me alone!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna become the Joker.
No!
Ah, shit!
Guys, I took too long of a break.
I think.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Open?
No, top!
Leave me alone!
Okay, they're a little stupid.
We appreciate that.
Okay, open!
Please.
Where are you?
Why is it?
Why is it not being so good now?
I don't understand.
I don't get it!
Why is my RNG so bad?
Is it... like this, maybe?
What?!
Nade the gun?
Yeah, but I don't have enough time to get into position.
Oh, it's done!
It's done!
Holy shit.
Let's go?
Okay.
I wasted so many grenades.
And I'm about to waste a ration.
Oh, you bitch.
Oh, where did my nades go?
There we go.
Ouch.
Oh my god.
You know what?
Screw you!
And screw you!
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
This angle is really tricky for me.
I don't know why.
The one here is really hard for me.
Okay.
So, about right in front of this rock.
Stop it!
Oh, okay.
You know what?
That works, I guess.
I can't get the angle on this one!
Guys, I'm restarting.
I'm sorry.
It's really bad.
This isn't good.
This is bad.
I've taken too much useless damage.
I'll still try.
Don't get me wrong.
It's just, if I get hit by even like two missiles, I'm donezo.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Eat!
Redo.
Just kill me!
Kill me!
No!
Thank you.
I craved death.
Okay.
Alright.
Really, thank you!
Feeling really eepy.
I'm gonna give you an early congratulation.
Thank you.
Grenading the machine gun seems to activate the turret.
I know.
I do know that.
I just can't... Since it's such an awkward position to grenade the turret, it's easier for me to wait it out.
Because...
Otherwise, I grenade it and then I just immediately... I basically immediately get hit by the turret.
Like, it's harder for me to grenade the gun and then hope that I get the turret.
Easier to stick to the right side.
Well, once I blow up the one thing, I should get both of them, should I not?
You know?
Because it's such a specific position.
And on the left side, it's so awkward because that one rock...
It's so tricky.
They deactivate once you get to the mouth phase?
Okay.
Shut up, Cardo!
Not that.
Not yet.
I'm getting ahead of myself.
Wow, the first step is a bait.
That's insane.
Guys, honestly, I don't even care so much if I lose the VOD of this.
I don't wanna make a new stream just for it.
My throat hurts so bad.
Hopefully I'll be able to beat it in time, but...
Honestly, if I go over a little, we'll see what happens.
I don't want to put pressure on me, though.
I don't want to put pressure on me to be like...
Okay, I have 30 minutes left.
I need to do it now.
That's just gonna stress me out more.
I just arrived, so I'm hoping it gets saved.
Go,
go, go.
General, you suck.
This guy sucks.
Okay.
Alrighty, and...
Ben Stiller.
Yeah, go Ben Stiller!
Go Ben Stiller!
Viewers are encouraging Minty Fresh Kyle.
What?
Kyle's stealing my thunder.
Okay, you know what?
Fine.
Fine, fine, fine.
I can't do this perfectly.
Fine.
You know what?
Whatever.
Sometimes... Wow, what is this?
What?
Fine, fine.
Sometimes you're gonna come down faster than you do normally.
I can't stop unseeing the monkey, honestly.
Oh, I missed.
I can't stop seeing a monkey when Snake is running forward.
I'm sorry, everybody.
I just see a monkey with his ears.
I hear vibing.
Don't bring me to your words, you wuss.
Oh, I should've gotten that one.
Shoot.
I just went a perfect run because I take so much damage in the second part.
Why is that so much to ask for?
Ape escape?
Oh, I don't know if that'll... No.
One more.
And I waste... Oh wait, these are landmines, not grenades.
Nice.
No!
You bastard!
The left one seems to come down faster.
It does, and that's why I don't always go for it.
It actually... It does.
I don't think the right one ever comes down faster like that.
Just the left one.
Which is why I have... If you see me sometimes skipping the left side, that's why.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, here we go.
But the right one does juke you.
I don't know if the left one does too or not.
Emperor!
Welcome to my membership.
Thank you!
This is not the last thing in the game?
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Is there an escape sequence too?
Because if there is, I'm mostly fine with that.
Oh, let's see if we're...
There's more?
Wait, no, there's not another boss.
No, there's not.
Oh my god, you're right.
Ouch!
Immediate hit, bro!
Open!
Oh, how is it hitting me?
It's facing the other side!
How is it hitting me?
What the fuck?
Okay.
What time is it anyway?
Oh, I did it though.
Oh.
Guys, this is not it.
This is not it.
Am I getting hit here too?
The other gun?
That's ridiculous.
How does it reach?
Okay, I'm not.
Okay, good.
Ah.
No, I can't.
Okay, thank god it's not opening up.
Oh my god.
Oh, the tops.
I took it out before the tops even arrived.
That's crazy.
Okay.
I'm just gonna work on this.
I'm just gonna sit here and do this instead.
Wee, wee, wee, wee, wee.
It turned around.
It was like, I don't want to shoot at you anymore.
Did you see that?
It was shooting over here and then it was like, fine if you're gonna be like that.
Alright, little chips, little chips, little chips.
Soon is going to be missile time, baby.
And about now, I think.
Next shot.
Next shot?
Wait, is it not... Oh.
Is it not taking damage anymore?
One more.
Okay, it is.
Just kidding.
Why is it not taking damage?
Okay, there we go.
It's two grenades if you don't move sides.
I see, I see.
That's how they get you.
Open up.
Sorry guys, I know I'm taking this really slow, but...
I'm just nervous.
Slow and steady.
Hello?
Don't say it might end up being a 24 hour stream, it's so rude.
You mean 12 hour?
I mean, yes.
24 hours on one boss.
Move up slightly.
Hello?
Whatever.
Oh, shoot.
Was I too late?
No?
Oh yeah, you're making up for lost time now, huh?
Oh god.
Shit.
Don't shoot me.
God.
I don't know how I have any reflexes left after all this time.
I don't know how.
Ah,
shit.
I tried to overcorrect.
Big damage.
We're at the fire!
Oh my god!
We made it to the fire!
Holy shit!
Oh my
gosh.
Terrible!
Yeah!
I might need to get some more water, you guys.
Solid Snake.
The name legend may have been propaganda, but it seems no exaggeration.
Sorry, I pressed B instead.
Also, if I...
Okay, does anybody know if I lose to him if I have to start over the Metal Gear fight again?
Do I have to do all of it again?
We're frozen?
Oh gosh, the chat is just stinky.
No, it's another stage.
Yeah, baby!
Thank you guys for the superchats!
Thank you!
Okay, it's a new mission.
Oh yeah, you're right.
It is a new mission.
Because we got the stage clear.
Ducky, thanks for the 10 guilted!
I want the truth.
All of it.
Why is he looking at me like that?
Easiest boss ever.
Why did that last round go so well?
That last round went insanely well.
A winner's privilege.
After all...
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
I'm gonna try and be less chatty, so hopefully we can save this VOD, right?
After all, you have the right to know about Outer Heaven, Metal Gear, Project Babel, and the link between GILF and the US.
Your dodges were on point.
Thank you!
Outer Heaven was a US-backed venture that provided mercenaries to its clients.
It was a way to unofficially check anti-American forces.
And the idea apparently originated with the DDCI of the time.
What's DDCI?
What?
But the field commander?
Big Boss?
Was a loose cannon that broke out of the program.
And Outer Heaven was brought down by you.
It's actually kind of funny that it's like hired mercenaries.
Outer... well, like...
What's it called?
Oh my gosh, my brain is fried right now.
Mother Base was kind of like that, right?
What's it called?
Yeah, MSF.
As a part of the plausible denial of their involvement in Outer Heaven, the government constructed a hero myth.
Handed you and Foxhound to the international media.
PMC!
Yes, thank you.
I was combining GMO.
So I was like, PMO?
No.
That is the truth behind your rise to the status of a legend.
Now imagine doing all that boss in a small GBC screen.
Chemical Burgers.
McBurger.
Shocking, isn't it?
To learn that your glory was a staged one.
Put on a good show, man.
And the connection between GILF...
Okay, I hate when they say stuff like that though.
Because Snake still had to do the effort, right?
Unless they were just like...
Yeah, you know that super hard fight?
It was staged.
Connection between GILF and the U.S.
Even after Outer Heaven collapsed.
Rory, thank you for the 10 guppies!
Thank you.
The relationship went on.
Right into Project Babel.
Taking away Snake's coolness.
Yeah, I still did the job.
The U.S.
provided covert support for GILF.
I was their field controller.
The objective was diminishment of anti-American forces.
In the African continent.
Provoke an ethnic minority in Gindra.
Into a calculated conflict.
Then involve other...
Snake and Ocelot, my favorite GILFs.
Grandpa, you'd like to friend.
Then involve other neighboring nations.
Create a climate of hostility to discourage organized alliance.
Then send in a contingent of U.S.-dominated peacekeeping troops for an indefinite stay.
Where they can exercise control over the entire region.
It was a bid to build a new world order.
In the confusion of the post-Cold War era.
A means to establish the U.S.
as the sole superpower.
A single hegemony...
Over an artificial Babel.
Non-negotiable chaos.
This was Project Babel.
You can see how all this got wrecked on.
The brainchild of Parker, Army Chief of Staff.
The return for my services was a lavish reward.
Hegemony.
And guarantee of safety.
What is that?
The philosopher's legacy?
Take this.
This disc contains all the information.
That Parker ordered that woman soldier, Chris, to destroy.
It's all here.
Proof of what I have just told you.
Including details of all bank transactions.
Oh my gosh, it's basically the philosopher's legacy.
Oh my gosh, what if the last fight was just when him and Rock, Paper, Scissors.
There is enough dirt here to bring down some of the highest people in the government.
This is like a bomb ready to explode.
This too is the winner's privilege.
Sorry, I'm looking at the guide for how to beat him.
I have exactly a minute and a half to beat him.
Okay.
And I have to wear the thermal goggles.
Alright, cool.
Do with it what you like.
Okay, cool.
Then I'm going to leave.
You've deceived your people all this time.
Your followers believe in you.
So does Sophie.
Yes, Sophie.
I left her, cruelly too.
But still she stayed with me as my lieutenant.
But I never saw her smile after that.
I just saw her.
When did you see her again?
What do you mean?
It's been like an hour in game probably, right?
I didn't deceive them.
I had no intention of being Parker's henchman in the first place.
It was the aid I needed.
And with it, I was going to break the bargain and build our country.
The end justifies the means.
Especially when others have faith in the fiction.
Yikes.
This guy kind of sucks.
I only gave them the truth in the guise they wanted.
Can a nation built by those means have any value?
Said Snake.
Sorry, I can't do the voices anymore, guys.
My throat.
Doesn't the world operate on what you call those means?
Code Mercy!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Everyone just pretends otherwise.
Justice and ideals are nothing but words.
After all.
Well, well.
So this is the way dreams end.
Well, it is not the worst thing.
Kind.
Don't turn your back on this guy, little monkey.
Viper!
What?
What is he doing?
Oh, wait!
Viper!
Oh my gosh!
I told you, it's not over yet.
Oh my god.
No, wait.
I was thinking of General.
Wait, I'm fighting Viper?
Viper!
Still!
He's like...
You have blue eyes, Snake.
Just like my blue eyes white dragon.
It fills me with energy.
Thanks for saving me the trouble of removing the General.
He controlled Metal Gear to the end.
And I had the pleasure of listening to your conversation.
And so finally I know the identity of Anonymous.
It was worth the trouble of leading you all the way out here.
You?
This was all a ploy to bring Anonymous out into the open?
Everyone is like 10 steps ahead of each other.
But they're all like going in different directions.
I'm 10 steps ahead of you, going east.
And Viper's like, I'm 10 steps ahead of you, going west.
Like, it's ridiculous.
Seizure of Metal Gear.
Leading you and Campbell out here to Outer Heaven.
All part of the plan.
Of course it was.
You know what, if I ever get myself in some deep shit like this.
If I'm like, oh my god, I'm gonna die.
I'm the villain and everybody's figured out my plan.
I'm just gonna pretend that...
Whatever happened was according to my plan.
It seemed like I'm so smart.
Puddles, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
What does the colonel have to do with this?
I can't unsee Zoolander and Owen Wilson.
Oh my god, I see...
I see Owen Wilson too.
You don't know what he did?
Your dear friend Roy Campbell was in command of Foxhound that night two years ago.
Firedack, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
The colonel.
I figured that when Metal Gear's history repeated itself and you and Campbell were pulled into the fray, Anonymous would have to get involved.
Okay, I'm just gonna... Two years I have waited for this moment.
Two long years.
Damn it, the decision to call Campbell in and to send me was made at the highest level.
How could I have been involved in that process?
Mrs. Howe!
Part of greed.
Wait, is it Burger?
Snake, we have a problem.
Burger, Burger, Burger, Burger.
The fifth black chamber was Burger.
Hey, what?
It's Burger.
Burger, Burger.
Colonel, what's going on?
Burger, Burger, Burger.
The fifth black chamber was right here.
This is so silly.
Who is this?
Burger!
I won!
Guess who?
Nick Burger!
Surprise, Snake.
After I survived two years ago, I parted from the others and slipped into your side.
I changed everything.
My face name passed... Oh my god, you gave yourself that face?
Burger!
Thank you, Puddles!
First McDonald's, then McBurger.
To gather information for our cause.
Everything I did was for this moment.
Do it, Viper!
This is it!
Oh my gosh.
You may forget or refuse to acknowledge it, but our hell goes on.
Thank you, Viper.
Yes, my hell does go on because there is one more fight.
And it will go on until we destroy all of you.
Not just Anonymous.
What did you just do?
The Bolts of Vengeance.
Preparing for nuclear strike.
How can that be?
Metal Gear was destroyed.
You should have gotten the other plate, Dumbo.
You are a fool.
Did you think Metal Gear was just an armored transport for a nuclear payload?
What?
The nature of this beast is an integrated launch system with real-time relay control of seven armed satellites.
All with nuclear capability.
The railgun is just a cherry on top.
Armed satellites?
Nuclear strike from planetary orbit?
That's right.
Able to strike on any point of Earth without relying on ICBMs.
And impossible to defend against.
The railgun's a cherry?
Yummy.
Space nukes.
You're going to murder millions of innocent people.
For your personal vengeance?
Innocent?
Crising on spoon-fed justice and order?
Content to ignore what goes on behind the fine words?
Their crime is equal to that of Anonymous.
No.
Their complacency is what makes Anonymous possible.
He's losing me.
This strike is for my murdered comrades.
But that won't be the end.
This is a declaration of war.
Against Anonymous.
OK.
This is so silly.
I love it though.
Of course.
It's Metal Gear.
It's going to be silly.
What is that?
I've just activated my trap card.
I just activated the elevator.
Once Metal Gear is out on the surface...
Black Chamber is kind of dead cell coded.
Maybe.
I feel like all...
I feel like all the groups besides Cobra Unit are very similar, right?
Its signals will be transmitted and those...
7 satellites will enter attack mode.
In 90 seconds.
I will stop you.
OK, Snake.
Give it your best shot.
This is your last fight.
Come on!
OK.
Alright.
So, from here...
I still have a ration, I believe.
Or not.
Oh, I do?
OK.
Thank goodness.
And then...
I get...
My R... Wait.
What do I get?
The F7.
Or 5-7.
Is what it's recommending.
I guess I can do that.
Which one's...
Which one shoots better?
R5?
You seriously aren't done?
No!
This is the final, final boss!
Assault rifle.
OK.
So, he turns invisible.
Do you think that I fight dirty?
If I use any means, I see fit to carry out our revenge.
OK.
Now we... Wait.
R5.
And thermal goggles.
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
We will have our vengeance no matter what!
Oh gosh.
Oh, that doesn't do so much... As much damage as I wish it would.
Please, God!
Oh my God, he's just a slippery little man.
Viper, you snake!
Oh my God.
Oh my God, he's so slippery.
Bing!
Hurry!
I'm trying!
Oh my God!
Where the hell is he?
Where'd he go?
My every move...
...is a testament to my comrades... I'm not gonna make it, I think.
Oh God.
Shit.
What?
No, this is the end of the road everybody.
We got him?
I will see, but I don't... Sorry, I don't care.
Oh my God.
Two seconds?
Do you think that I fight dirty?
Yeah.
Oh, there it is.
Wow, I got through this cutscene immediately.
We're above ground!
The command has been relayed to the attack satellites just now.
Oh, sorry.
The nuclear something-something-something vengeance!
OK.
Does the gun do more damage?
Let's check it out.
OK, good.
It starts from here.
This isn't so bad.
Item.
Let's try the pistol.
And our thermal goggles.
It's hard to tell where he starts.
Slightly more maybe?
What does the anonymous mass hacking group have to do with this game's story plot?
No, it's not actually them.
It's...
Nice.
It's a guy named Anonymous.
Victory is ours in 68 seconds.
OK, buddy.
Eat shit.
Every move is a buglelelelelele.
Oh shit.
Wait.
Oh God.
Slippery, slimy, slimy sucker.
I'm always chasing...
He doesn't attack.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my goodness.
His attack kinda hit.
We'll see.
Blahblahblahblah.
I don't care.
Sorry.
I don't care about what you have to say.
Where are you?
Where'd he go?
Where the hell is he?
Guys, I lost him.
Guys, where is he?
Oh my God.
Just keep blasting.
I'm trying.
It might be... We might get him.
Nice.
OK.
20 seconds, but maybe one more hit if I can get him.
Please.
Yes!
Terrible!
How fast do you expect me to beat him?
And the VOD is saved.
I've shut the controls down.
There is no way to launch now.
I'm out.
Thank you for the superchat!
Welcome to the map-o-ship!
Terrible to the end, baby!
Terrible to the end!
Hopefully this isn't a 15 minute...
How could I be beaten by you?
OK.
We're gonna have to speedrun this ending a little bit.
Snake, how do you do it?
How do you keep fighting?
Living?
For what?
Whom?
In the name of what cause?
It's over.
My comrades, I didn't do right by you at all.
This is so beautiful by the way.
Like the sunset is so pretty.
Goodbye Viper.
I don't feel sad at all.
Viper.
Who's walking over here?
Hello?
Oh, curse.
Sophie, just kidding.
Snake!
Oh no.
Sophie is also pregnant.
It's you.
They did a good job with the graphics.
They really did.
The general.
Terrible.
I heard.
All of it.
Including the part about GILF in the US.
I see.
What will you do now?
Hello?
There we go.
Stay here.
With GILF?
She's staying with her GILF.
Next time the bonus missions?
Maybe.
We'll see.
Continue the general's work?
Right now, I don't even know whether I loved him or hated him.
I just couldn't leave his side.
His ideals may have been faked, but they weren't empty.
That's what I think.
And there are many here still who believe that too.
Worth ruining my sleep schedule.
No!
Me too though.
We'll work together to build a country.
Of our own.
For ourselves.
This time with real ideals.
And there is Chris.
Snake!
Oh she found a car.
Nice.
It's her.
Don't keep her waiting.
I won't.
Nice.
This is so much for a game boy.
I can't get over it.
He called your name, you know.
At the end.
No he didn't.
Did he?
Snake is always giving people false hope.
He's such a good guy.
Snake!
Amazing mint.
Thank you, Sova!
I got us a jeep.
Good work.
Is it over?
Yes!
It's all over!
Is it?
What a great stream.
Thank you!
What about her?
She's strong.
And she'll become even stronger.
You don't have to go with her?
To GILF?
Why?
Nothing really.
Let's get out of here.
Right.
Oh colonel.
There's the codec.
She won't ever show up again.
I only have 10 minutes, please!
Snake!
Colonel, everything alright?
Yeah, I put a bullet in McBurger.
Ok, Weasel.
You?
Snake, I owe you an apology.
It's true that I was in charge of Black Chamber's termination.
We were told that there was a terrorist group coming in.
Secret liquidation on a dark night.
Only when it was all over was I told that the target had been one of our own.
An American unit.
Was that the reason for your retirement?
Yes.
I lived with the guilt these two years.
Colonel is always getting screwed over just like us.
But when they hijacked Metal Gear, I was called in by NSA chief Steve Gardner.
The mission controller.
Mint is a freak, not lewd, just endurance wise.
So you took the job to confront the past.
A job which was offered to me with the alternative of making the incident public.
Along with evidence that it was I who planned the thing.
The thing.
Blackmail, huh?
But how would Gardner know about that?
Probably dug it up somewhere.
He is a former CIA director.
Former DCI.
Don't tell me.
Seven years ago, during the Outer Heaven incident, who was the DDCI?
Now you've got it.
Sorry.
Gardner was deputy director of central intelligence, alright?
Weasel.
He was the one who organized Outer Heaven and the development of Metal Gear.
Oh my god.
Metal Gear used to be under CIA control, like Viper said.
Rest in pepperoni, McBurger.
More like rest in pickles.
I love pickles on a burger.
Gardner was also the one who salvaged the Metal Gear you totaled from Outer Heaven...
and continued the development program.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
This has been a wild 12 hour ride, but it was worth it.
Never get tired watching you play Metal Gear.
I'll donate more to MGSCon later this week.
So we can see you there.
No, thank you though.
Thank you, thank you.
In other words, Project Babel was actually his idea.
But two years ago, Metal Gear was seized by foreign terrorists...
and as a result, the control of the weapon and the leadership project Babel...
was transferred away to Parker.
The real gilf was Sophie.
Yeah.
And the army.
And Gardner had Black Chamber erased to ensure their silence.
Gardner is anonymous?
Weasel, you're not.
Under Gardner's direct command?
You guessed it, Snake.
What?
And another thing.
Gardner knew who McBride was from the beginning.
What?
Well, it was Gardner who leaked the intel about Metal Gear to McBurger...
and Black Chamber to begin with.
Oh my god.
For what purpose?
I see it.
Gardner was setting Parker up.
It's really hard for me to keep track of these people when I don't have a face for Parker...
I don't have a face for Gardner, things like that.
Right.
If gilf seizes Metal Gear and goes out of control...
the blame will land on Parker with his long time aide to gilf.
And Metal Gear Project Babel will return happily ever after to Gardner's arms.
Yeah, I'm gonna have to read up on the story after this.
Some parts are, especially because I'm tired now, some parts are flying over my head.
Could he possibly have engineered Black Chamber's contact with gilf?
I don't know, but it could be.
That Gardner planned this whole thing?
Just to regain Metal Gear and Project Babel?
Oh god, oh hi Meiling.
Weasel, if you're under orders from Gardner, don't you have another job to carry out?
To kill us all once the mission has succeeded?
Yeah, but he's a weasel.
Sharp Snake, that's exactly right.
So that's the real reason a mercenary of your standing wasn't sent on the field?
Right again.
But he's a weasel and can't be trusted.
I'm about the only person who can take on the legend.
Weasel, you're going to kill us?
Like I said, it's a policy of mine to earn my keep.
How can you?
So I'd like to say, but unfortunately, I kind of like you people.
Especially your bleeding heart ways.
Totally wrong for a combat situation, you know.
It's been a while.
It's been a while since I met people like you.
Weasel.
Get out of here.
I'll feed some story to Gardner.
Probably get only half my pay for letting you escape, but who cares.
Are you going to be alright?
You could be in danger.
I know how to take care of myself.
Don't you worry.
We never got a game to fight Weasel.
Thank you, Weasel.
I quit.
Don't think I can take it seriously though.
I'll repay the debt someday.
Except he doesn't, because Weasel never shows up again.
I won't be counting on it.
If I could live the way you people do, maybe I wouldn't have had to let my brother die.